SO GOOD GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY- AS WE ALL KNOW IN
RESPONSE TO THE OF IT EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC THE
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
ARE LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HEARING TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE BUILDING ESSENTIAL
HEARING AND IS MADE NECESSARY
TO NORMAL PRACTICE IN ORDER.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WHILE CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY. OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. AS WE
COMPLY WITH HIS ORDERS. WE ARE
HOLDING COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
IN DEBATE REMOTELY. WITH THE
USE OF A VIDEO CONFERENCE.
SYSTEM I FOR MEMBERS WHO WILL
BE ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY
PLEASE MU YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GENTLY
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATE ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU. HAVE A COMMENT
OR QUESTION RAISE YOUR IF YOU
USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOUR
KNOWLEDGE TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE
PLEASE SELECT I MEAN FOR USE
BEGIN SPEAKING ARE IT
PERSONNEL. PUT YOU BACK ON IT
WHEN YOU'RE DONE. ONCE IN A
SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND BILL NUMBER. WHICH ARE. NOT
TO OUTPUT ACCESS WHICH OF
COURSE IS VERY WE ADMITTED
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS. HERE IN THE
BUILDING TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW WE ALSO USING A
TELECONFERENCE. SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. WE HAVE A COUPLE
PEOPLE. WHO WILL TESTIFY FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATE TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT HERE IN A
MOMENT TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THAT'S 1-844-291-6364 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX ONE ZERO
FOUR ZERO NINE NINE. SIX ONE
ZERO FOUR ZERO NINE NINE. WHEN
WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY CAN TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO COMING TO
THE MONEY OVER THE PHONE YOU
KNOW WE'VE ALL MADE THAT
MISTAKE BEFORE. IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
WITH A VERY ROWDY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC HERE AND SO I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THEM. PLEASE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC. BOB SORRY. THERE WE
ARE ALL RIGHT WELL EVERY EFFORT
WILL HAS MADE TO STE THE
HEARING AND CONDUCTOR IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MAN AS IS
BECAUSE THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS CORD TO
THE USE OF NEW ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO ALL
INDUSTRY. INTERESTED PARTIES
CAN BE HEARD. ALL RIGHT. I WANT
TO FIRST RECOGNIZE OUR OUR OUR
VICE CHAIR SENATOR BEATS. I GOT.
OKAY INTENT THIRD SO OUR VICE
CHAIR CENTER BATES IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTE THERE SHE
IS PAIN HAS SENATOR LOOKING
GOOD SHE'S TO BE SB REMOTELY
FROM ARTISTIC OFF AND SHE WILL
BE PRETTY COM QUESTION AND
DEBATE SHE WILL NOT BE VOTE
BECAUSE SHE'S HERE IN. I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE TO MY FRIENDS
ARE HERE WITH US TODAY CENTER
HERTZBERG AND SAN MCGUIRE
THEY'RE TAKING PLACE OF. STIR
CENTER SKINNER JUST TODAY. HI
THIS GREAT FEES OF SEVERAL. NOW
WE HAVE SO BILLS TODAY'S. AND
WE HEAR PRESENTATION THE BILL'S
STOP SO SEX. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AND PLEASE TURN ON YOU
MICROPHONE. ALLEN HERE ON.
DOLLY HERE NOW IT HERE
HERTZBERG. BUT PHIL HERE THE
BILL HERE MCGUIRE AIR FIRE HERE.
BY CAST. IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT WOULD AND WHAT HAS WILL BE
HIS WAY HE THE IS HERE IN THE I
SAW THIS MORNING. OKAY SO
SECTOR NOTES THAT A- HAS BEEN
THE STATE. BY NOW YOUR EFFORTS
BILL WHATEVER MEMBERS WHO ARE
PRESENT FOR ON THE CAN CALENDAR
ONLY ONE ITEM ON CAN AS I
NUMBERS. SB ALLOW FIFTY SO TO
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE CAN
MOVE BY SEN HEALTH THANK YOU
SENATE WE HAVE M<c.cyan>. ASPECT</c>
PLEASE THE ROLL. AND IT. PLEASE
TURN ON MIKE'S. SONIC CALENDAR
IS ITEMS TO. ALAN I ALAN I
DAHLE HI HOLLY I HERTZBERG. I
BY HILL AYE MCGUIRE HI BAR I
WHITE HOUSE OKAY THE COUNTY HAS
PASSED WE WILL SEARCH THE ROLE
OF FOR OTHER MEMBERS ADD. AND
NOW IT'S FROM OUR OFF THAT IS
SENATE JACKSON WHO IS HE TO
PRESENT HER BILL ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB FIFTY. A GOOD MORNING
CAN YOU HEAR YES WE CAN WELCOME
SIR. THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
THEIR UP TO PRESENT SB NINE.
THIS IS A BILL TO WIN. MAY MORE
OF FISH. AND STRENGTHEN OUR
STATE VENERABLE IN. QUALITY AND-
UP BEFORE. I WILL TO AND NOT
THESE. WORK OF THE CHAIR AND
HIS COMMITTEE STAFF ON BEHALF
OF THIS BILL- ARE BOTH MY STAFF
AND I. VERY OF YOUR APP AND I
WOULD LIKE ACCEPT. AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS SET IN THE AND
NOW. THIS BILL IS SOLD FORCED.
THE SEQUEL F. BY THE LAW. OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS. TO
BRING SOLUTIONS TO LONG
STANDING SHAPE OR CONCERT. AND
THE EFFORTS VETERAN SEQUEL. AND
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WHO
INTIMATE UNDER THE OF THIS. AND
HOW WOULD PLAY OUT IN REAL
WORLD SORT. ARE LIKE TO THE SPA.
PLANNING AND CONSERVE WE FOR
MARCH SEVERAL OUR STATE TALK
SECRET PRACTICE. BOTH WHO
REPRESENT THE DEVELOPERS THE IN
MARIN CA THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
THE- FROM THE SCHOOL THE
VARIETY A WIND SWATH OF
PRACTICE BACK. ARE AN ORGAN A
FOR BY WHICH THESE ARE PARTIAL.
WERE ABLE TO THE MEASURE THAT
IS YOU TODAY. AND I AM WANT. TO
PARENTHETICALLY IN THE THAT I
HAVE BEEN ON TO WHERE TO
IMPROVE. THE EFFICIENCY. AND
THE- THAT SHE WHAT. THE KID
MATTERS ARE GOOD GALA ON IN
COULDN'T TO BUT THEM OF MANY
YEARS AND HAVE PREVIOUSLY TO
GET STATE. TO TALK ABOUT THERE
IS A COMMON OFFICE AND NOW I
WE'RE COULD MAKE SURE SHE
COULDN'T TO DIDN'T IT WAS TO
ALLOW THE PUB TO. IN MAY DOES.
AFFECTING THEIR CA. WHILE AT
THE SAME TO WHAT WE TO SURE
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE THE KINDS
OF THE- AND GAMES WHEN. THAT
THE PER THAT HAVE LED TO SOME
THE- IT. AND THE LADY SO. WITH
IMPORT FOR OUR SO WE KNOWS QUIT
THE CORE. OF CAL ARE FAR MENTAL
POLISH. FIFTY YEAR FROM ITS MY
THE LAW REMAINS A FOR AND-
PROTECTION AND FOR. INVOLVED IN
PROJECTS BY LAW FOR ON THEIR
BEHALF AT THIS TIME HOWEVER.
THE STATUTE HAS STRONG. SOME OF
IT MAY. AND SOME OF IT. THIS
BILL IS PREMISED ON THE I. THE
MEANINGFUL SALUTE CAN BE FOR
THROUGH COLD EFFORT IN ORDER
MOVE PASS HELLO THE V. AND HARD
FOSTER. IN THAT IS PREDICT
THERE ARE THOSE ARE OUT THERE
THAT SEAT SHE WHAT NO MATTER
WHAT WE DO WITH IT THEY LIKE TO
TELL AND INDEED ANY EFFORT GET
THE KIND OF PART TO. AND
FRANKLY ARE GOOD TO INVITE
POLICY AND THEN THERE ARE THOSE
WHO FOR IT CAN BECOME AND TO BE
WORKED. AND THE THERE ARE THOSE
USE ARE TOO MANY TO WOULD BE.
ARM IT IS MY THAT THE
ALLEGIANCE AND I THIS IS A BILL
IN. IN PRAGUE BUT IT IS MY HOPE
THE THIS BILL ADVANCE CHAU
IMPORTANT SOLUTIONS. ALONG
STATE SINGLE CONCERT. FOR
EXAMPLE THIS BILL ADDRESS THE
LARA THE CRY ISSUE OF DOCUMENT
DUMPING WE'RE SOMETIME THE
ADOPTION OF AN FOUGHT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS OR
DELAYED WITH LATE WRITTEN
COMMENTS REQUIRING ADDITIONAL
AGENCY RESPONSE BEFORE FINAL
ADOPTION OF THAT REVIEW CAN
PROCEED. THIS BILL EMBODIES THE
SPIRIT OF BALANCED AND FAIR
PROCESS BY ALLOWING AGENCIES TO
ELECT AN ALTERNATIVE PROCESS
WHEREBY THE AGENCY PUBLISHES
ITS FINAL ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
THIRTY DAYS BEFORE ADOPTION AND
SUCH A DEADLINE. FOR WRITTEN
COMMENTSUP TO TEN DAYS BEFORE
ADOPTION. THIS COMPROMISE
PROVIDES THE PUBLIC GREATER
TIME TO REVIEW THE FINAL
DOCUMENT AND ALLOWS THE AGENCY
AMPLE TIME TO RESPOND TO ANY
FINAL COMMENTS WHILE STILL
KEEPING THEIR ADOPTION SCHEDULE
ON TRACK THIS IS CRITICAL THAT
WE KEEP THE PROCESS MOVING
THERE ARE THOSE WHO CLEVERLY
ARE ABLE TO DELAY IT.
DISCOURAGES AND THAT IS NOT
INTENDED NOR IS THAT WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IN FACT THIS BILL
TRIES TO REMOVE THOSE KINDS OF
THE LADIES ARE WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME PROTECTING THE GOALS
OF THIS MEASURE. TRULY IT
BRINGS GREATER EFFICIENCY TO
THE SEQUENCE PROCESS BY
DEVILISH OF WORK FOR A IN
PARTIES AT THE OUTSET OF LIVING.
TO MEET AND DISCUSS THE LEDGER
OF HOW THAT MADE FOR. AS WELL
AS THE POSSIBILITY OF
SETTLEMENT WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF INFORMATION HEARINGS THROUGH
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SEARCH
OUR THAT HAVE CRIED TO WITHDRAW.
HOW WE CAN A THIS LIVE ROOM. WE
AFTER A- THE SEQUEL THE ONLY
WAY TO WORSE PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
CLUB ACT IS THROUGH. IT THE
REVENUES IT IS A LITTLE PATIENT
THE OR DIRECTED PROCESS THE
QUESTION IS WHAT CAN WE DO TO
EXT PROCESS WHAT YOU DO TO
ENCOURAGE. THIS OFFER. I
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE SO
AT ANY RATE WE HAVE A JUDICIAL
PROCESS. AND ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE
TRIED TO DO WITH THIS MEASURE
IS TO ENCOURAGE BUDGET MEETINGS
BETWEEN THE PARTIES SO THAT THE
CORD AS SHE BEGINS THE PROCESS
CAN SIT DOWN WITH THE PARTIES
AND TRIED TO ENCOURAGE
MEDIATION SETTLEMENT RESOLUTION
OF CONFLICTS IN AN EARLIER
MANNER AND IN THAT PROCESS
DURING THESE HEARINGS WE'VE HAD
SOME OF THE EXPERTS. IN THE
COURTS TALK ABOUT THE WAYS THAT
THESE VARIOUS KINDS OF EARLY
SETTLEMENT CONFERENCES AND SO
FORTH HELP HELP TO RESOLVE ANY.
ISSUES IN A MUCH MORE
EXPEDITIOUS AND EFFECTIVE
PROCESS THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
TRIES TO DO IT TRIES TO
STRUCTURE THESE MEETINGS IN A
SENSIBLE WAY TO INVITE
EFFICIENT JUDICIAL PROCESS WITH
THE GREATER POSSIBILITY OF
SETTLEMENT VERSUS CONTINUED
LITIGATION. THE BILL SUPPORT
SUFFICIENT PREPARATION OF THE
RECORD I ALLOWING AGENCIES TO
ELECT. AN ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD
UPON NOTICE OF A JUDICIAL
FILING SO LONG AS THE AGENCY
BEARS THE COSTS THAT PROVIDE
CERTAIN. AGENCIES LAW PROVIDING
PETITIONERS WITH RELIEF FROM
SIX SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF COST
ALSO THE BILL ALLOWS LITIGANTS
IN LOW POPULATION COUNTIES TO
SEEK A BENEFIT OF EXPERT JUDGES
IN OTHER VENUES AND TO SUPPORT
OUR LONG TERM EFFORTS TO BRING
MORE SEEK WHAT EXPERTISE
TORONTO STATE COURTS SYSTEM.
THIS BILL THUS REQUIRES A
SCHEMATIC REVIEW OF SHE QUIT
EXPERT JUDGES IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE THE MOST AFFECT THE-
DISH READ VERSES WEAKENED LOOK
AT LEGISLATION THAT WILL SEND
THESE MATTERS TO. SHE JUDGES IN
AN EXPEDITED FASHION WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CANNOT
COMMENT THEY DON'T EXPECTATIONS
AND THIS BILL HELPS ACROSS THIS
AND IMPORTANTLY THIS BILLS SIX
A SOLUTION LONG BYE ARC. THIS
FRANCHISE FROM WAS PUBLIC SAYS
TO LET BETTER HERE'S- SO THE
GRIP IN A SECRET IS THE IN FOR
I PROVIDE TO COME PROJECTS
APPROVED ON BEHALF OF THOSE.
BUT IF THEY ALREADY IT'S FROM
THAT A FROM DUE TO LOW A LACK
OF LANGUAGE ACCESS WE UDERMINE
THE IMPORTANT DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLES THAT ARE EMBODIED IN
SHE- AND IN ALL OUR- STATE
POLICY MORE LARGELY. SO WE KNOW
OUR STRENGTH IS IN OUR
DIVERSITY AND ARE RESIDENTS
SHOULD BE PROVIDED AN EQUAL
PLAYING FIELD TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHTS I MIGHT INDICATE THAT WE
HAVE AGREED TO AN AMENDMENT
THAT THAT WILL REDUCE THE-
TRANSLATION RESPONSIBILITIES TO
THE BASIC ONES REDUCE COST
REDUCED HARM. THIS WAS A
CONCERN EXPRESSED BY. OUR VERY
STE LOCAL AGENCIESWE'VE TAKEN
THAT AMENDMENT- AND- I BELIEVE
WE STILL HAVE RETAINED THAT
VERY VERY IMPORTANT PROVISION
TO ALLOW COMMUNITIES TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON AND TO BE ABLE
TO COMMENT. THIS BILL ALSO
PROVIDE PROMOTES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUPPORTIVE IN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR ON IN
UNDER HOUSE CALIFORNIANS BY
ESTABLISHING AN EXEMPTION
TARGETED FOR THOSE CATEGORIES
OF HOUSING NEED AND AGAIN WE
TOOK THE AMENDMENT THAT
CLARIFIES THIS. BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE AREAS
OF GREATEST CONCERN HERE IN OUR
STATE AND FINALLY. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE QUESTION IN THE
ADOPTION OF PROJECTS THROUGH
THE LOCAL ELECTIONS PROCESS-
THE BILL AFFIRMS THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHT TO VOTE ON ALL MATTERS OF
COMMUNITY CONCERN BUT IT ALSO
WEDNESDAY ABILITY FOR
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT APPROVAL
INITIATIVE. THAT IS QUALIFIED
FOR THE NEXT BALLOT TO INSTEAD
BE DIVERTED FROM THE VOTERS AND
DIRECTLY ADOPTED BY LOCAL
LEGISLATIVE BODIES. AS THE
ANALYSIS INDICATES WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON LANGUAGE-
TO ACCOMMODATE THIS AND-
CERTAINLY- WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MAKE THIS THE BEST DEAL
POSSIBLE THAT PROTECTS THE
INTERESTS OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
PRESERVES. THE INTEGRITY OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACTED SO
CRITICAL TO CALIFORNIA. AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO IT IN A
WAY THAT BRINGS ALL THE PARTIES
TOGETHER. TO MAKE THIS A BETTER
PROCESS SO AS YOU CAN SEE
BRINGS UP FORWARD SEVERAL
PROPOSALS THAT IN THEIR
TOTALITY MAKE MEANINGFUL
PROGRESS ON IMPROVING SEEK ON
SEVERAL FRONTS. IN A BALANCED
MANNER WHILE PRESERVING THE
STATUTES FUNDAMENTAL TENANTS-
AND- I APPRECIATE AGAIN THE
LENGTHY ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE
SHE- IS A BOTH A BENEFIT TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW
WHY MY INSPIRATION TO FIGHT TO
THE FIRST SEQUEL CAME FROM. AN
EXPERIENCE I HAD MANY YEARS AGO
A BEING FROM THE EAST COAST
WHEN IT GETS COLD A LOT OF
PEOPLE GO DOWN TO MIAMI BEACH.
AND I HAD THAT EXPERIENCE ONE
YEAR AND I HAVE TO SAY I AM SO
GRATEFUL FOR SINGLE BECAUSE IT
HAS. KEPT CALIFORNIA FROM
LOOKING LIKE MIAMI BEACH- THE
OUR GROWTH. IS RECENT OUR
GROWTH RESPECTS THE
ENVIRONMENT. WE NEED TO DO MORE
DEVELOPMENT BUT IT HAS TO BE
DONE IN A WAY THAT BALANCES
THOSE. CRITERIA AND THAT'S WHAT
SHE BUT HAS BEEN FOR US FOR THE
PAST FIFTEEN YEARS. SO WITH
THAT. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
MEASURE BRINGING THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE.
ACTING THE ENTIRE AND SHE C<c.cyan></c>
WHILE EXPEDITING IT AND MAKING
IT A MORE FAI AND BALANCED
PROCESS. AND TO ASSIST WITH
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WITH ME TODAY. I HAVE A DREAM
MOOSE WHO IS A SENIOR PARTNER
AT THE LAW FIRM OF RAMIE MOOSE
AND MANLY. TO ANSWER A TO SPEAK
AND THEN ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS WE KNOW THAT SHE- IS
A VERY COMPLICATED. AND THROUGH
THE YEARS THROUGH COURT
DECISIONS AND SO FORTH IS A
FAIRLY COMPLICATED PROCESS HE'S
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE AND THEN WITH.
ME ALSO IS MEDIA CHIANG WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR OF THE COUNCIL OF
INFIELD BUILDERS. AND WITH THAT
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASTRI
RIFLE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MADAM SENATOR AND NOW
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE IN
PERSON MISTER MOOSE. YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING SANDERS I AM ONE OF
THE- PRACTITIONERS THAT CENTER
JACKSON MENTIONED. RECRUITED BY
THE PLANNING CONSERVATION LAKE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROCESS.
MY BACKGROUND IS FOR THE PAST
THIRTY FIVE YEARS I'VE BEEN A
PRIVATE PRACTITIONER TYPICALLY
REPRESENT PUBLICATION SEEKS.
APPLICANTS SO WITHIN OUR GROUP
BY TO REPRESENTED PEOPLE WHO
WANTED TAKES INPUT. MY OWN
PHILOSOPHY BY THIS IS THAT I
BELIEVE IN WHAT THE IT'S A GOOD.
BUT I LIKE TO SEE IT OPERATE
MORE EFFICIENTLY I THINK THERE
ARE SOME- TRANSACTIONAL ASPECTS
OF IT THAT ARE INEFFICIENT. SO
I WENT INTO THIS PROCESS WITH
THE GOAL OF- TRYING TO.
EFFECTUATE THIS POLICY
OBJECTIVES. I THOUGHT THIS WAS
AN EXCELLENT PROCESS. I WAS SO
DELIGHTED TO BE RECRUITED TO DO
IT BECAUSE THE WHOLE PREMISE OF
IT WAS TO HAVE PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES. SIT
DOWN TALK TO EACH OTHER AND TRY
TO WORK OUT THEIR DIFFERENCES.
I IN A RESPECTFUL FASHION-
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
ALL THAT OFTEN IN OUR WORLD
TODAY- THE PACKAGE WE ENDED UP
WITH- WE BELIEVE IS BALANCED-
AS A CENTER INDICATED EITHER
SOME TWEAKS IT COULD BE MADE TO
IT AND- I THINK OUR GROUP IS
OPEN MINDED TO THOSE. THAT TAP
I SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AND I AM. HOPEFUL THAT YOU'LL
PASS IT BECAUSE I'LL BE VERY-
HEARTENED BY THAT AND IT WOULD
SEEM TO REWARD THE SORT OF
EFFORT THAT. WAS PUT TOGETHER
HERE TO GET PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES TO TRY TO. FIND
COMMON GROUND. PRODUCED THIS
PROJECT ON. TIME BY THE WAY I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE OF ONE-
UNDERSTANDS THAT WERE ASKING
EVERYONE- DECIDE TO HAVE A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES- BECAUSE
OF THE SITUATION WITH ALL THE
TECHNOLOGY BUT- BUT- YOU BEING
HERE AND WE'RE GONNA. WHAT WAS
REALLY GONNA CALL YOU TO ASK
QUESTIONS- OKAY NEXT ON OUR CO
HOST TELECONFERENCE LINE IN
SUPPORT. WE'VE GOT ME A CAN
WHOSE DIRECTOR OF COUNCIL OF
INFILL BUILDERS AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY THIS TECH.
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YEAH WE CAN HEAR YOU GREAT
HELLO. WONDERFUL THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SHERMAN ALLEN ALLEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK THIS MORNING MY NAME IS
MIA COM AND I'M IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR ON THE BOARD THE
COUNCIL DENTAL BUILDERS. THE
COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS
REPRESENT A STATEWIDE NETWORK A
REAL ESTATE PROFESSIONAL
COMMITTED TO REVITALIZING
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND TOWNS
THROUGH INFILL NEIGHBORHOOD.
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS I'VE
DEVELOPED OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED UNITS A DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE AND MARKET RATE
HOUSING AND I'VE NAVIGATED
THROUGH CALIFORNIA'S COMPLEX
PLAN YOU ENTITLEMENT PROCESSES.
HELLO CALIFORNIA'S IN THE MIDST
OF A DIRE HOUSING SHORTAGE
RELATIVE TO OUR POPULATION AND
NUMBER OF JOBS LEADING TO HIGH
RENT ON AFFORDABLE HOME PRICES
FOR MOST RESIDENTS. WE BELIEVE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S DIFFICULT
PERMIT PROCESS FOR INFILL
PROJECT IS A CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
STATE HOUSING SHORTAGE
DISCRETIONARY LOCAL PERMIT
REVIEW TRIGGER SPEAK WELL WHICH
IN TURN TRIGGERS LENGTHY DELAYS
AND SOMETIMES LITIGATION. THE
COUNCIL OF UNTIL BUILDER
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO STREAMLINE
EQUAL REVIEW FOR INFILL
PROJECTS AND WE BELIEVE SB NINE
FIFTY HAS SOME VERY IMPORTANT
PROVISIONS BUT OF ON MY
ORGANIZATION THE COURT
INCLUDING MANY LONG OVERDUE
TECHNICAL FIXES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY EXEMPTING EMERGENCY
HOUSING PROJECTS FROM SEQUEL.
WHICH COULD SPEED UP PRODUCTION
AND HELP MAKE INFILL AREAS MORE
LIVABLE AND EQUITABLE FOR ALL
RESIDENTS LIVING WITH AN
EXISTING COMMITTEES. WE APPLAUD
SENATOR JACKSON'S LEADERSHIP IN
OFFERING THESE AMENDMENTS TO
IMPROVE WHAT TO BECOME MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT. AND WE
BANKING COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
IMPORTANT WORK DURING THIS MOST
DIFFICULT TIME AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT OF NOT FIFTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THOSE ARE OUR TWO BUT I
WOULDN'T PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BY NOW WE'D LIKE TO SEE
IF THERE ARE OTHER FOLKS TO
ONE- I EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL LET'S START HERE.
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WANTS
TO ADD ON. IN SUPPORT. YEAH
THIS IS THIS IS IT IS ANYONE.
YEAH HERE THAT OKAY. HOW BOUT
ON THE LINE AND WE'VE GOT OUR-
OUR LINE GUY CAN THE MODERATOR.
DO WE HAVE FOLKS TWENTY FOUR.
BUT WE ARE GOING TWENTY FORTY.
I DON'T PLEASE ANYONE TWENTY
FORTY RIGHT NOW THAT YEAH ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO LIKE TO WITH
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
US INTO MORE LIKE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY. I'M GLAD
YOU'RE LOOKING VERY PROTECTED
THEIR- IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OKAY. MOM MUCH TO COME OVER AND
JOIN US ALL RIGHT- SO. THERE WE
ARE WE DON'T HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE BY LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY BY BY THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS IF YOU
COULD MODERATOR MAYBE PLEASE.
ARE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FIFTY AND THEN WILL
BEGIN. ARE THERE FOLKS THE
GENTLEMAN. FOR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
THE COURT SB NINE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. BUT
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T THEIR
OWN NOW. IN ONE MOMENT TO
TRIMMING. AND WE DO HAVE LINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
LINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ALAN OUR MORNING
HOPE. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. HELLO OKAY
PERFECT- GOOD MORNING SURE
ALLEN VICE CHAIR BATES AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
CONNOR MEDINA GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS SPECIALIST FOR ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL VOICING
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE FIFTY.
THANK YOU. I THINK WE WERE
LOOKING FOR SUPPORT SOME. TIME
IN THE YEARS FORTY. SO THE
MODERATOR AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIVE ZERO.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO SO LINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LNE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY
SIX MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE. LINE
SEVENTY SIX WE WILL COME BACK
TO YOU. AND WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
LINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE THIRTY FIVE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY FIVE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY WE WILL ON WE WILL GO TO
LINE NINETY NINE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
NINETY NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
LINE NINETY NINE YOU CAN SPEAK.
WE WILL I WILL ONCE AGAIN I
WILL RE PROMPT IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. NINE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND
LISTEN FOR THEIR LINE NUMBER.
IN MY NINETY NINE HAS DROPPED
ALSO WE WILL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
FLYING SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MODERN ABLE TO CONNECT IS WHAT
WE'VE BEEN TOLD. OKAY WHEN WE
GO AHEAD AND- THEY'RE JUST. ONE
MOMENT ON IT THEY'VE ALREADY
BEEN GIVEN THE LINE NUMBERS ON
HAVING THE OPERATORS GO BACK TO
RE ITERATE THEIR LINE NUMBER.
SO BEAR WITH ME ONE MOMENT
DETERMINE. ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
JUST OKAY ARE BLIND YEAH WE'RE
JUST WAITING WE DON'T ONLINE
SEVENTY IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT-
THEY DISCONNECTED ONE MOMENT.
ONCE AGAIN EVERYONE IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPORT OF SB NINE
FIVE ZERO PRESS ONE TWO ZERO
AND LISTEN FOR YOUR LINE
NUMBER. ONE MOMENT. MR TRAINING.
IN LINE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
NINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CAN MEMBERS
MOLECULAR MERRILL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND THE
COURT AT THE BELL AND ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS THAT WOULD BE MY
COLLEAGUES THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY. RIGHT YEAH. IN LINE.
SIXTY ONE SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN ALAN MY
NAME IS KEVIN JOHNSON. I AM A
CITY FOR A PARTICULAR LAWYER
FROM SAN DIEGO AND I'VE HERE
THIS WEEK WITH YOUR POINT-
ADVISERS GROUP OVER THE LAST
TWENTY ONE MONTHS WORKING TO
CREATE A- BALANCED FAIR MINDED
WORK PRODUCT. I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO MOVE SB NINE
FIFTY FOUR. ENDED SO THAT
EVERYONE CAN CONTINUE WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO FURTHER
REFINE THE PROPOSED LEGISLATION
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY. THANK YOU
AND LINE FIFTY ONE FIVE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU I AM LINDA
CROP CHIEF COUNSEL OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER A
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW FIRM THAT
REPRESENTS ENVIRONMENTAL AND
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND SHE CALLED
MATTERS. WE SUBMITTED A LETTER
ON MAY TWENTIETH INDICATING OUR
SUPPORT IS AMENDED WE ARE
PLEASED THAT SOME OF OUR
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED IN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR TO ADDRESS OUR
REMAINING ISSUES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU AND
LINE ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE LINE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS WE CAN ACROSS
THE WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ALSO IN A TO
COURT AS AMENDED POSITION AND
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS BUT THOSE. REFLECTED
IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
CENTER LETTER AND THE COMMENTS
JUST MAKE PAYMENT ACROSS. THANK
YOU. ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOUGLAS CARSON
LIMóN ATTORNEY WHICH AT BROWN
CARSTENS MATERA A PARTICIPANT
IN THE PROCESS I AM IN SUPPORT
IF AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
GOOD MORNING- THIS CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS BRIAN A WIKI
BUT CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY LIKE MANY OF THE
FOLKS WHO SPOKE ON ALREADY-
WE'VE BEEN VERY- PLEASED AND
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE- A BEING
ABLE TO RESOLVE. THE ISSUES
THAT BUT RAISED IN A LETTER
THAT THE CRAFTED ALREADY
MENTIONED- AND SUBMITTED AND
WITH THAT ARE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN LINE
ONE- TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SURE MEMBERS A SECRET AND ALSO
IS HERE CALIFORNIA LOSS ON A
SUPPORT AMENDED POSITION AND
REALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THAT
FROM. THE TECH CENTER AND LINDA
CROP THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE INTO AT THE MOMENT. I
MEAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN
SEE WHAT THE MOMENT. WE HAVE
LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE EIGHTY
NINE. YOUR NAME. YES SIR THE
GOVERNOR PERCENT EACH THANK YOU
MATTHEW BAKER WITH PLAYING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE POLICY
DIRECTOR- MARKET SHARE THE
NUMBERS GREATER DETAIL WAS.
SPONSORED THE BILL AND SO
THEATER OF THIS UNIQUE CROSS
SECTOR STROKES TO FINDING
COMMON GROUND SOLUTION I. I'M
HERE JUST READ FORMALLY SOME OF
THE BILL AND- CAN GO TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
OKAY I THINK THAT'S THAT'S SET.
REMINDER TO YEAH YES AT THE
TIME THAT THE LACK ONE. PAUL
REMINDER ONE MORE TIME IF
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OKAY ONE
LAST TIME. YOU KNOW FOLKS ONE
OF ONE OF ONE OF EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT. OKAY ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIVE
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T
ZERO THAT'S ONE ZERO IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FIVE ZERO. OKAY AND
WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S.
PATIENTS HERE I KNOW IT I KNOW
IT'S A LITTLE CLUNKY BUT- LET'S
NOW GO AHEAD AND HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION WE'VE GOT ADAM I
REGULATE OVER AT THE CAL
CHAMBER WHO IS ON THE CO HOST
TELECONFERENCE LINE AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ADAM REGULARLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. I WANT TO BEGIN DAY
BY EXPRESSING OUR APPRECIATION
FOR THE COMEDIAN THAT MEANT.
STAFFS THE GAUGE IT WITH US ON
THE BILL. UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THE MOMENT.
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEMS WITH THAT
THE NINE FIFTY. SB FIFTY IS
JUST ONE OF TEN JOB KILLER THE
YEAR ALSO IF YOU THE I A
HOUSING KILLER. IN YOUR MARKET
BY UNPRECEDENTED. SCHOOL WILL
SHUT DOWN OF OUR ECONOMY
UPDATED THE STATE BUDGET. BUT
THE UNEMPLOYMENT LEVELS NOT
SEEN AT THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
AND EXACERBATED IN EXISTING
HOUSING CRISIS WHICH IS
ILLUMINATED THAT ARE HOUSING
SHORTAGE IS NOT JUST AN
ECONOMIC ISSUE. BUT ONE OF LIFE
OR DEATH. SB NINE FIFTY TEND TO
DO TOO MUCH WITH TOO LITTLE
TIME WITH FAR TOO GREAT A
CONSEQUENCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. HOUSING PRODUCTION AND
JOBS. SB NINE FIFTY IS NOT IF
TO POINT NO. THE BILL WOULD NOT
A PRODUCT OF THE ROBUST
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. THE
GENESIS OF THE LANGUAGE BEFORE
YOU IS THE RESULT OF A WELL
INTENTIONED BUT SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE PRACTITIONERS. HAND
SELECTED BY THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL. AND NOTABLY THE ONLY TO
DEVELOPER SIDE PARTICIPANTS
ULTIMATELY RESIGNED FROM THAT
AFTER. NOT A SINGLE ENTITY
LISTED IN OPPOSITION WAS
INVITED TO BE PART OF THAT THE
OLDER PROCESS. EVEN AS SOME
REQUESTED TO DO SO. I NEEDED A
VERY ENTITIES THAT REPRESENTS
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF ACTUAL
STAKEHOLDERS IMPACTED ON A
DAILY BASIS I THINK WELL. EVEN
UNDER NORMAL TIME SB NINE FIFTY
EXTENSIVE CHANGES TO SPEAK WELL
CALIFORNIA ELECTION CODE IN
CALIFORNIA COASTAL PROCEDURE
WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE TO
ADVANCE. I NEED EXTRA ORDINARY
TIME THESE EXTENSIVE CHANGES
THE CALIFORNIA LAND USE
POLICIES. WE BELIEVE WOULD BE A
PUNISHING BLOW TO CALIFORNIA
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND GET
RIGHT CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMICAL
COVERING. A BILL OF THIS
MAGNITUDE IMPACTING ALL
SIGNIFICANT LAND USE
DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
LOOTING OR ESPECIALLY HOUSING
COMMANDER ABOUT STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS IN A FULL LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WITH MULTIPLE COMMITTEE
HEARING THAT FULLY FLESHED OUT
EVERY CHANGE CONTEMPLATED BY
THE BILL. SB NINE FIFTY SB
EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS RIGHT NOW IT
CREATES NEW COSTLY BURDENS ON
THE AGENCIES ALREADY UNDER
WATER WITH THEIR BUDGET.
INCREASES THE TIME COST AND
LITIGATION FOR HOW THE
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
OVERRULED THE SEMINAL
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
DECISION WITH IMPLICATIONS
VIRTUALLY ANY BALLOT INITIATIVE.
BY DIFFICULT ORIGINAL
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. IS NOT
PIXELATED DOCUMENT BOUND.
REMOVEDBONTA ACTION FOR
MODERATE AND HOW THE PROJECT AT
A TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE
CLASS NEEDED HOUSING MORE THAN
EVER. FOR THESE REASONS AND
THOSE ARTICULATED OUR LETTER WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE
TODAY THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU ADAM I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ALL RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE AS THIS IS NOW AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS TO VOICE%
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL I LET'S
START HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OF
THREE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO'S
HERE PRESIDENT. WHO LIKE TO
VOICE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
SEE CHRISTMAS KELLY. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CRESSMAN KAYLEE
ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE ROOM
OKAY- NEXT TWENTY FORTY ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY OF US SENATE MORE
LOCKED WOULD YOU LIKE TO WIN
NOW OKAY- AND LET'S NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE TO SEE IF FOLKS WANT TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE-
READY TO. EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO VOTE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
FIVE ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE
MOMENT TO DETERMINE. MY NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT'S JOHN KENNEDY
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE RESPECT WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSE
MOST AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT
IMPOSES SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
COSTS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES WITH RESPECT
TO THE NEW CASE TRANSFER
PROCESS- WE THANK YOU YOU KNOW
THIS IMPACTS THIRTY COUNTIES
WITH POPULATIONS UNDER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND SEVENTY
FIVE CITIES WITHIN THOSE
COUNTING. IT WILL FORCE ARE
POTENTIALLY FORCE US TO DEFEND
OURSELVES AND FOREIGN
JURISDICTIONS WHEN GIVEN THE
SHEER NUMBER OF LOCAL ACTION
BECAUSE YOU COUNT ON TO COURT
GROUNDS IT COULD BE REALLY
OVERWHELMING. WE ALSO HAVE
REALLY SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
WITH THE TRANSLATIONAL
APARTMENTS WE UNDERSTAND
AMENDMENTS ARE BEING TAKEN AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING AT WHAT
THOSE AMENDMENTS NEW- THE
AMENDMENTS ARE EQUALLY IF NOT
MORE SERIOUS FOR THE IN PERSON
TRANSLATION APARTMENTS- AND YOU
KNOW WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE- SOME
ADDITIONAL CHANGES MADE TO THE
STATE CARD BECAUSE- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE EXTENT
CONVERSATION. I HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH YOUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTS. WE APPRECIATE THE
EIGHT THAT THE ANALYSIS RAISED
A LOT OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAD ON BUT WE'VE DISCUSSED
SEVERAL OTHER CONCERNS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS- THAT REASON WE
OPPOSE ASKING FIFTY ONE LOTS OF.
MANDATORY HIS NEW BURDENS ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- AND THE
INCREASED POTENTIAL FOR LITTLE
LITIGATION RESULTING FROM THE
TRANSLATION REQUIREMENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR AND WE WERE
WE WERE HAPPY TO TAKE THAT TEST
BECAUSE- ADAM HADN'T QUITE USED
UP THE FULL THREE MINUTES BUT
WE ARE WE'RE ASKING THE REST OF
THE- FOLKS TO. TO JUST GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND ME TO AN
OBVIOUSLY WERE WERE ARRANGED IN
EVERYONE'S WRITTEN TESTIMONY AS
WELL- THE ONE CLARIFICATION BY
THE WAY YOU YOU WILL. THE CHECK
OUT THE NOW SAYS THAT THE
TRANSLATION PORTION OF THE BILL
HAS BEEN NOTHING IF DOING
AMENDED. OKAY LET'S KEEP GOING
WITHOUT WITNESSES WHO LIKE TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION MODERATE.
THANK YOU ONE FIFTY THREE. YOUR
LINE IS ALL. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
STILL BE HERE ON BEHALF CAL
BUILDING SAYS WORKERS
OPPOSITION THIS BILL HAS BEEN
TAGGD BY THE ORGANIZATION AS A
HOUSING KILLER AND ONE QUICK
NOTED THAT OUR MEMBERS BUILD
85% OF THE HOUSE IN THE STATE
THAT SINGLE FAMILY MULTI
FAMILY. THEY WOULD STRONGLY
DISAGREE THAT THIS BILL HAD
ROBUST DEVELOPER AND PUT THANK
YOU WE ARE CLOSE OKAY THANK YOU
SIR AND IT JUST A QUICK
REMINDER WE- FOR THE BILL OUT
OF BILLS TODAY WE WOULD WANT ME
TO USE AT THIS POINT-
RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALRIGHT MODERATOR NEXT NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
ONLY GATHERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE ARE ALIGNING OUR
OPPOSITION WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MR REGULATE OF CAL
CHAMBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE MODERN
AFFLECK HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
HERE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN
BE THEY DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON THE- IF YOU CAN.
THE THAT- DIGESTION AND NOW
THEY'RE SAYING. RETURN YEAH.
THANK YOU THINK YOU'RE MUCH.
LINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR KERRY NUMBERS CHRIS
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED SB NINE FIFTY
THANK YOU. SIR. ONE ONE ONE
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SURE MEMBERS THEIR DOLPHY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CITIES
MUCH RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED SB NINE FIFTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LET'S NOT I'M PRETTY
BACK OFFICE. FIVE NINE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN FIND
SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THIS IS
GAIL DEL HAND WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE'D LIKE
TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE MADE BY THE CHAMBER AND
ASK FOR YOUR KNOW THE TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS DONNA
DO FOR ON TOWARDS THE AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE
RESPECTIVELY. LINE ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS STEEP MCCARTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU LINE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NEGRITA COMMITTEE.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN RESPECT. THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT.
ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE IN THERE AGAIN. LINE NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING IF
YOU'RE SURE NUMBER TAYLOR
RUSSIAN THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN OPPOSITION. ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
AUDIBLE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANDREW
SAUL CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
GREATER RIVERSIDE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB NINE FIFTY THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MELISSA
WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FIFTY FOUR ARE YOU THERE.
WE WILL COME BACK TO YOU FOR.
LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MEMORY BARTLETT WITHIN
THE CHAMBER AND WE ARE LINING
WITH OUR NEIGHBOR CHAMBERS ODBC
FEMALE APPEARS TO. OPPOSE AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN LINE
ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
HERE IN MEMBERS MIKE MONICA
YEAH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE I
CREATES COUNCIL IN THE WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN LINE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JEAN
WONDER LIKE THIS MORNING
REPRESENTING SOUTH WAS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AS WELL AS THE
SOUTHWEST CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. MY MONO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHEN
NUMBERS K. DON'T HIT AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
BELIEVERS WE HAPPEN OPPOSE
UNLESS AND THAT INSTITUTION AND
A LETTER REPORT COMING THAT%
DETAILS ARE CONCERNED THANK YOU.
SHE. LINE ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TYLER MUNCHING
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL ENGINEERING COMPANIES
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
PERSONAL REASONS TO THE BY THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS THANK YOU.
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
HORRIBLE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MARK HIS TO THE LANCASTER
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE WISH TO
SUBMIT OUR STRONG OPPOSITION SB
NINE FIFTY THANK. THANK YOU
LINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD MEMBERS
ADAM HARPER CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ONE YOUR
LONG IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MR KERRY MEMBERS
MICHAEL RIPPED THE UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES WERE
LINED WITH THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IN LINE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHE WAS SO HIGH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION I'M NOT
EXPECTING OPPOSITION BUT DO YOU
WANT YOUR REGULAR I COULD NEVER
CAN'T CONCERNS THAT ARE LINED
WITH MISTER KENNEDY COMMENTS
FROM OUR ACCOUNTING WE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH DOCTOR
DOCTOR AND APPRECIATE THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE POLLUTION
THAT MAY WORK PROPERTY. THANK
YOU. ONE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SEVENTY SIX. ONE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TRANSPORTATION BRYANT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION
WESTERN. IN OPPOSITION THANK.
AND THAT WAS OUR LAST ONE. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE FIVE ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T ZERO ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
FIVE ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T ZERO. THANK YOU AND LINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT ON THE WE
WITH THE CENTER OF THE METRO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIFTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO. JUST JUST TO REITERATE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO HAS
OPPOSITION YOU ONCE EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL PLEASE MAKE SURE TO.
NOW THIS IS YOUR THIS IS YOUR
LAST OPPORTUNITY. MODERATORS
ANYONE ELSE THE SEA ON THE
QUEUE. THERE WAS NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THE MOMENT OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS NOW BRINGS THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE MEMBERS TO
ASK QUESTIONS AND HAVE
DISCUSSION AND YOU KNOW WE DO
HAVE ALL OF OUR WITNESSES ON ON
ON CALL WE'VE GOT A COUPLE
PEOPLE HERE IN THE AUDIENCE. IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE SO I
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE I
CENTER WITH CASKEY. I APOLOGIZE
THAT I WASN'T HERE AT THE
INTRODUCTION AND- I WANT TO.
APPLAUD THE AUTHORS HERCULEAN
EFFORT TO COME FORWARD WITH A-
A BILL LIKE THIS SOAP. SO
COMPLEX AND- OBVIOUSLY
INTELLECTUALLY DEMANDING AND
NEW ONES. ON THE- FROM THE
STAFF REPORT I'M LOOKING AT
THE- VOTER INITIATIVE.
REVISIONS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
BENEFIT OF HER THOUGHTS INTO
THE STAFF REPORT CAME IN HI.
SURE ACCEPTING THE MEMBERS WHAT
ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW THE
HOW THE INITIATIVE PROCESS MAY
BE CHANGED WITH REGARD TO SEE
CA. AND THE BEST. WE CAN
HAVE ON MUTE OKAY JUST BECAUSE
OF A FEW. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
THE THIS IS THE TWELFTH JOBS
LOOPHOLE I THINK THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO- SO IT'S LONG BEEN
ESTABLISHES YOU KNOW THAT SHE
WILL REVIEW IS NOT REQUIRED.
WHEN VOTERS TO DOT THE LOCAL
INITIATIVE THAT AUTHORIZES THE
PROJECT. BECAUSE THE
DISCRETIONARY DECISION IS MADE
BY THE ELECTORATE RATHER THAN A
LOCAL AGENCY. BUT IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN IN THE PTOLEMY JOBS
AND SMALL BUSINESS ALLIANCE
VERSUS A COURT CASE- WAS FOR.
IT HELD THAT SHEEPLE ALSO DOES
NOT APPLY TO LOCAL INITIATIVE
POSITION OF PETITIONS THAT ARE
SIGNED BY TRUST 10% OF THE
VOTERS AND THEN DIRECTLY
ADOPTED BY THE LOCAL GOVERNING
BODY RATHER THAN BEING
SUBMITTED TO THE ELECTORATE AT
THE ELECTRIC. THIS ARE
UNINTENDED LOOPHOLES LOW HAS
BEEN USED BY PARTIES WITH DEEP
POCKETS AT THE BY PASS SEQUEL
DENYING THE PUBLIC THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
MAJOR LAND USE DECISIONS SO.
THE WORDS ARE THEY GO OUT THEY
GET 10% OF THE PUBLIC TO SIGN
ON TO. A FREQUENTLY. WITH
EXPLAINING IT SOMETIMES OF
COMPLICATED THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY GIVING THE A SIGN
OR- THE ACCURATE INFORMATION
AND HEN WHAT THEY DO IS THEY
SAY OKAY NOW WE DON'T HAVE TO
GO TO THE VOTER THE LOCAL
AGENCY- THE LOCAL CITY COUNCIL
CAN MAKE THE DECISION AND THAT
CIRCUMVENTS THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS. THIS BILL SB NINE FIFTY
WOULD CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE IF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT OPS TO
ADOPT THE INITIATIVE RATHER
THAN TO SUBMIT IT TO THE VOTERS
THE NINE FIFTY WOULD ENSURE
SINGLE STILL APPLIES. IF THE-
THE INITIATIVE IS SUBMITTED TO
THE VOTERS EXISTING LAW STAYS
THE SAME SEE WHAT WON'T APPLY
BECAUSE THE VOTERS HAVE HAD
THEIR SAY NOW- IN THE
DISCUSSION WE'VE BEEN HAVING
WITH THE- COMMITTEE. I IS ONE I
THINK WHERE WE SHARE A
COMMITMENT TO FULLY CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLES SO THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. IS CLEAR AS
TO THE APPLICABILITY OF SHEBA-
BUT THERE ARE SITUATIONS- THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
EXEMPTIONS ARE THE PREFERRED
ROUTE. OF FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO EXEMPT THE PARTICULAR
CATEGORY- ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND
HOUSING PROJECTS. WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT SHOULD QUALIFY
FOR AT LEAST ONE OF THE SEVERAL
EXEMPTIONS CURRENTLY IN LAW AND
MAY QUALIFY FOR FUTURE
STATUTORY EXEMPTIONS WHAT WE
WANT TO DISCUSS AND WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO. DISCUSS GOING FORWARD
IS ARE THE BEST WAY TO DEFINE
WHAT. THOSE ENVIRONMENTALLY
SOUND- PROJECTS MIGHT BE A SO
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED TO
CREATE AN EXEMPTION BUT TO
LEAVE THE- OVER TO CLOSE IF YOU
WILL THAT SEQUEL LOOPHOLE AGAIN
IT ALLOWS REALLY DEEP POCKETS
TO COME IN AND TO CIRCUMVENT
THE SINK WILL PROCESS. THE BUT
THE AND THAT IS NOT WHERE WE
ARE I THINK WANT TO SPEAK WITH
TO GO CERTAINLY THOSE WHO
SUPPORT THE NOTION OF AN
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT YOU
KNOW SOME OF THIS IS VERY
PHILOSOPHICAL ITS IDEOLOGICAL.
ANY THE FOLKS WHO OPPOSE. SHE
WHAT ARE IN THIS BILL WILL
OPPOSE SINGLE. I AND SO WE'RE
NEVER GOING TO. IN A WE'E
NEVER GOING TO APPEAL TO THEM
WHENEVER GOIN TO SATISFY THEM
AS LONG AS THERE IS A SEQUEL-
BUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN
THE BILL IS FIND THAT BALANCE.
AS WE HAVE SEEN. AND MANY OF US
pARE PROBLEMS WAS SHE BORN AND
WE RECOGNIZE THAT AND- FRANKLY
BRINGING THIS GROUP OF PEOPLE
TOGETHER ACTUALLY. THEY BROUGHT
THEMSELVES TOGETHER- BUT FOR
YEARS AND I KNOW CENTER WHAT
CASKEY YOU BEENACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THIS AS WELL. THERE
ARE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO
TO TIGHTEN UP SEEK WATCH TO
AVOID THE KIND OF ABUSES AND
MISS USES THAT HAVE EVOLVED
OVER THE COURSE OF TIME. OUR
AND CERTAINLY THE STRONG THESE
ARE CASE IS ONE OF THOSE
EXAMPLES WHERE- WE NEED TO
TIGHTEN THAT UP AGAIN WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME. AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY DECIDE WHAT EXEMPTIONS ARE
APPROPRIATE. AND TO CREATE
THOSE EXEMPTIONS ARE TO FURTHER
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY. AND I KNOW
THAT BECAUSE OF THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS WE WERE NOT INJURED
SURE COMMITTEES I WANT TO ASK
YOU SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE-
IS. BY MEET AND CONFER
CONFERENCE THE INITIAL CASE
MANAGEMENT- THE YOU'VE AGREED
TO WORK TO SIMPLIFY THOSE
REQUIREMENTS OBVIOUSLY I WOULD.
I WOULD GUESS THAT. THE IDEAS
CAN WE REACH. ABBAS DISCUSSIONS
FROM RECENT COMPROMISE WHAT IS
YOUR- IF. I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL. STILL CHAIR TO. THE
TRUTH ON SIMPLIFYING THAT THAT
LITIGATION. FOR PUT THE PANEL
THAT YOU WORK WITH. WELL AGAIN
YOU KNOW THIS IS AN ISSUE ABOUT
SIMPLIFYING THIS PROCESS THAT
HAS HAD YEARS OF DISCUSSION.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SAY WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT MY FRIENDS OVER
THE CHAMBER NOBODY GOT
BLINDSIDED ON THIS THESE
DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN GOING ON
FOR YEARS. IN FACT AS I
MENTIONED SEVERAL YEARS AGO I
CONVENE THE MEETING OF ALL THE
STAKE HOLDERS WHO WANTED TO
JOIN US AND WE HAD ABOUT FORTY
PEOPLE IN ONE OF OUR- HEARING
ROOM SAID ABOUT ANOTHER TWENTY
OR THIRTY GROUPS. ARE ON THE
PHONE AND TALKED ABOUT AREAS
WHERE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO COME
TO COMMON AGREEMENT A LOT OF
THEM REVOLVED AROUND
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS. AND
THAT WAS. RESULTED IN A BILL I
DID A FEW YEARS AGO ON. AT
PRESIDING THE OB PREPARATION OF
THE RECORD- PUTTING MORE OF THE
INFORMATION ONLINE. THE
DOCUMENT DUMPING ISSUE WAS
RAISED THEN WE COULDN'T COME TO
ANY KIND OF ACCEPTABLE
RESOLUTION FOR ALL THE PARTY SO
WE- LEFT THAT OFF OF THE THAT
LEGISLATION. BUT THESE
DISCUSSIONS HAVE CONTINUED OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME I'VE HELD AS
RICHARD JUDICIARY IN NUMBER OF
HEARINGS. ON THIS THE USUAL SHE
OVER THE COURSE OF TIME WE
BROUGHT IN THE COURTS THEY'VE
TALKED ABOUT. HOW ONCE THEY GET
THE PARTIES TO THE TABLE. IN
THAT COURTROOM SETTING. IN
MEETINGS IN CHAMBERS WITH THE
EDGES ARE AND I MENTIONED THAT
A JUDGE ROBI IS A HAS BEEN SORT
OF THE LEADING EXPERT ON THIS
SHE IS DISCUSS WITH US. WAYS TO
EXPEDITE NOT ONLY EXPEDITE THE
PROCESS BUT TO REACH RESOLUTION
IN SETTLEMENT AND I BELIEVE THE
INDEX DID AND I MAY BE WRONG.
SOMETHING LIKE 96% OF ALL THESE
CASES COME TO FOR THE- THAT ARE.
SETTLEMENT FUNDS. SO AND THAT
SETTLE IN. I IN DO. AND NOT. IN
APPROACH. WAY AND NOT WITH THE
GAME PLAYING AND EXTENT. AT OUR-
WHAT IT IS TO. THIS TURNS WITH
JUDGES WHO ARE EX IN FIELD
REALLY GET THE TO THE TO TWIST
THEY ARE AS A NEST HAVE TO DO
TO REACH A RED. AND THE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THIS
BILL AND YES MANY MANY OF THE
BILLS THIS YEAR HAVE BEEN
HEADED A SOMEWHAT ATTENUATED
PROCESS- AND I'D LOVE TO SEE
MORE OF THESE BILLS IN THE
HOUSE AND THE HOUSING BILLS IN
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. BUT NONE
OF THESE ITEMS. ARE ANYTHING
NEW. THAT WE ARE TRYING TO WORK
PRIMARILY ON THE- SHE GENERAL
ASPECTS CLOSING LOOPHOLES ARE
REMOVING THE POLITICS AND
GETTING TO THE HEART OF THE
ISSUE ABOUT HOW WE CAN PROTECT
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AT
THE SAME TIME WE CAN IMPROVE
UPON IT AND I BELIEVE ADDING OF
THOSE ELEMENTS THROUGH THE
COURTS IS ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
EXPEDITE THIS PROCESS WHILE
RETAINING ITS SUBSTANCE AND-
SOME DO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT
INITIAL MEETING. TO DISCUSS THE
PASTA ATTENTION FOR A
SETTLEMENT CONFERENCE BEFORE
THE SETTLEMENT CONFERENCE THAT
WOULD BE WITH THE JUDGE IN A
SORT OF A THREE WAY OR JUST A
TWO WAY. THREE WAY. WELL I
DON'T KNOW I THINK HAVING
HAVING THE COURTS HAVING A
COMPETENT QUALIFIED EXPERTS SHE
WHAT JUDGE. IN THE PROCESS- OF
IT I THINK. WE'LL HELP EXPEDITE
IT WILL IT WILL LAY OUT THE
WHOLE PROCESS VERY QUICKLY IT
WILL RESOLVE ANY OF THE
DISPUTES THAT THAT MAY EXIST HE
SAID SHE SAID. THE COURT CAN
CUT THROUGH ALL OF THAT AND GET
TO THE HEART OF THE MATTER AND
SET UP A PROCESS AND IT IF
MISTER RUSSO FIVE. IF THEY'RE
SO I MISSING HERE PLEASE I
WOULD LIKE TO. WITH THROUGH THE
CHAIR INVITE MISTER MOOSE JOHN
WELL YOU JUST COMPARE WITH US
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO. IF I COULD
FOCUS EVERYONE IN THE COUNTRY
TO WHICH THE REPRESENTS
PATIENTS MAKE PREVIOUSLY. ARE
THE PRACTITIONERS THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT THE CHAMBER OR THE
BUILDERS TYRONE THAT THE- WATER
AGENCIES ARE TOLL GATE THESE
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE. IN THE
UP IN THE. IN ORDERTHE- IF YOU
WERE FOR ON THE STREET WERE
ISSUES COME TOGETHER OUR SIX IN
THE- IN A- SORT OF NON. WAY BUT
IN A REAL PRACTITIONERS WAY TO
FIX THE PROBLEMS ARE THAT
RESULT IN THESE EXTENDED
PERIODS OF TIME. WHEN NO
DEVELOPMENT IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF
THE QUALITY OF THE DEVELOPMENT
BUT BECAUSE OF THE GAMES THAT
ARE PLAYED BY WHATEVER GROUP
WHETHER IT'S A COMPETITOR YOU
KNOW THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT REASONS THAT THERE
ARE. UNNECESSARY DELAYS BY
BRINGING THE COURTS GENERALLY
WE'RE GOT WHAT THE GOAL IS TO
GET RID OF THOSE UNNECESSARY
DELAYS. OKAY MISTER MISS VERY
BRIEFLY AND THEN AND THEN IT'S
GONNA SEND OUT I'M ABLE TO
PROVIDE MORE A TECHNICAL ANSWER
TO HOW THIS PROCESS WORK RIGHT
NOW UNDER THE LAW THERE'S A
INITIAL REQUIREMENT FOR A
MANDATORY SETTLEMENT MEETING.
IN OUR COLLECTIVE JUDGMENT ITS
CURRENT TOO EARLY IN THE
PROCESS THE PARTIES AREN'T
PSYCHOLOGICALLY READY SO WE
TRANSFORM THAT INTO SORT OF THE
LAWYERS TOUCHING. BASE AND THEN
THE NEW ELEMENT WOULD BE A
MANDATORY CASE MANAGEMENT
CONFERENCE WHERE THE JUDGE
INTERVENES EARLY IN THE CASE
GETS THE PARTIES TALKING ABOUT
MOVING THE CASE ALONG QUICKLY
GETTING THE RECORD READY.
THERE'S A HAVE TO HOPE THAT THE
PARTIES WILL STIPULATE TO A
SMALLER RECORD TO KEEP THE CASE
MOVING MORE QUICKLY THAN THE
FORMAL SETTLEMENT CONFERENCE WE
COME A LITTLE LATER. LET'S
PEOPLE HAD TIME TO CALM DOWN
AND OUR STATE A LITTLE BIT
LATER SETTLEMENT CAR. ACTUALLY
BE MORE LIKELY. TO RESULT IN
SETTLEMENT BUT THE MAIN THING
IS GET THE JUDGES INVOLVED
EARLY IN THE CASE TO. GET IN ON
THE RADAR SCREENS GET THIS
BREAKING SCHEDULES- SAID
REALLY. THE HOPE OF JUST
GETTING THROUGH LITIGATION MORE
QUICKLY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER. THE RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
THE HELPFUL THANK CENTER DOLLY.
THREE YEARS CHAIR OF I'VE THAT
WE HAVE ADAM ON THE A- WHEN A
SERIES WHICH IS OFTEN HERE OF
COMMENTS HIM ABOUT THIS SELECT.
PLEASE BOGO OKAY AND DIED SO
MISS REGULARLY I AYE MAYBE WANT
TO RISK TO THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS THAT WERE JUST MADE.
SURE THAT I'M ON THE LINE AND
THERE WAS A LOT TO UNPACK THEIR
I THINK I NEED TO SPELL. WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE SENATOR
THAT THEY'RE SOMEHOW OPPOSITION
BECAUSE THE- QUOTE UNQUOTE
EIGHT PEOPLE. WE HAVE BEEN AT
THE TABLE TO HELP. FIX THE
ISSUE THAT THE PERENNIAL PEOPLE
ISSUES IN THE CAPITAL AFFECTING
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
FOR YEARS. THE NOTION THAT.
JOINT HEARING ON THE BECAUSE
SOMEHOW. EIGHT MEN OR AN
EQUIVALENT TO HOLD STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WHERE WE ARE
NEGOTIATING AMENDMENT TO A
CRITICAL ENVIRONMENTAL STATUTES
THAT WILL IMPLICATE EVERY
HOUSING I'M JACK EVERYTHING THE
LAND USE PROJECT- CUSTOMIZED-
IS NOT THE SAME HAVING A HAND
SELECTED AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
PRACTITIONERS WHICH BY THE WAY
THE ONLY DEVELOPER SIDE
REPRESENTATION RELYING FROM
OXFORD. SO EVEN THAT SMALL
STAKEHOLDER GROUP CANNOT BE
ARGUED AS A ROBOT- STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WITH ALL INTERESTS
REPRESENTED AND THE NOTION THAT
WE HAVE. DEVELOPERS UNION AND
OTHER FOLKS ALL OF HOLDING YOUR
BILL SHOULD HIGHLIGHT THE
FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS WITH THE BILL
AND THAT IT IS NOT READY FOR
PRIMETIME. AND I'M NOT ARGUING
AGAINST MOVING OUT OR MOVING I
SHOULD SAY- CHANGING HOW WE DO
CASE MANAGEMENT CONFERENCE THE-
THERE ARE BIGGER. MORE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES IN THIS BILL
AND IT WAS BEING SOLD AS A FEW
QUICK TO POINT OUT THAT BALANCE
IS. ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
INTEREST TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
ROBOT. PACKAGE EQUALLY BALLOT
WE'RE HERE AND OPPOSITION
REFLECT IT IT IS NOT BALLOT AND
THERE IS A WHOLE LOT MORE FOLKS
EITHER SUPPORTING AMENDED. OR
POSING AS AMENDED ORCHESTRATE
OPPOSING THERE ARE JUST
STRAIGHT SUPPORTERS NINETY
THAT'S REFLECTIVE OF HOW IT
BÃO THE BILL IS. THE
FUNDAMENTAL FLAW IN THE MOVIES
OUT OF COMMITTEE ON THE HOPE TO
JUST WORK ON THE NET. COULD
FUNDAMENTALLY IMPACT HOW
CALIFORNIA GET OUT OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN MY OPINION
IT'S HIGHLY INAPPROPRIATE GIVEN
WE DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
FULLY ENGAGE THE SAME WAY IN A
FULL LEGISLATING PROPER THANK
YOU SIR ARTS CENTER HELP. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR CHAIR THE
THANK YOU TO- TO SENATOR
JACKSON BECAUSE SHE'S BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND- HAS FELT
THE PAIN OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
HAVE BEEN- THAT ARE BROUGHT
EVERY TIME ANYONE TRIES TO
BRING UP THE SUBJECT OF SEQUEL
REFORM SO I RESPECT HER AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. I I'D WOULD
TAKE AN EXCEPTION BECAUSE I
THINK ONE OF THE COMMENTS WAS
THAT- ANYONE WHO IS OPPOSED TO
SEE CLOVER DOESN'T LIKE SEQUEL
A- TWO STEP AND WANT TO IMPROVE
IT THAT IS ONE OF THE LAMINATED
OR GET RID OF IT OR KILL SEE
CA AND IT I THINK THE
REALITY. IS FOR THE YEARS.
EXPERIENCE WILL LIVE WITH IT
AND OF. IT TO AS AS A CAL I
CERTAINLY HAVE BUT I THINK
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS
GOING TO BE. IN PLACE IT IS
HERE FOR A REASON AND- THE
EFFORTS ARE TO TRY TO MAKE IT
BETTER TO WORK BETTER TO
STREAMLINE IT SO THAT IT IS NOT
AT. A CUMBERSOME PROBLEM- IT SO
IT IN TO ME I LOOK AT IF WE
WERE TO IF THE A GOAL IS TO
STREAMLINE AND MAKE THE PROCESS
BETTER AND IMPROVE IT. MY
CONCERN IS IN LISTENING TO THE
OPPOSITION READING THE
OPPOSITION LETTERS. AT THE
OPPOSITION COMING FROM ALL
SIDES I MEAN IT'S NOT JUST.
IT'S ANYONE WHO IS A SEQUEL A-
WHO'D- WITH SECRETIVE WHO.
EMPLOYMENT SHE C<c.cyan> WHO IN I'M</c>
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY THEY
DON'T ACTUALLY WORK SEE WHAT
THEY DON'T USE IT NEEDED TO AN
HOUR USE IT AND- AND TRY TO
IMPLEMENTED ON A DAILY BASIS.
NO ONE IN NEWS GROUPS THAT-
HAVE ANYTHING ARE ARE
SUPPORTING THIS OR ARE FEELING
THAT THE CHANGES THAT ARE.
QUITE A FEW. ARE OFFERING A
SOLUTION TO SEEK WITH THEIR ALL
OPPOSED TO IT AND THAT'S WHERE
THE TROUBLE COMES FOR ME IS IF
WE'RE NOT MOVING THIS BAR THE
BALL FORWARD IN IMPROVING AND
REFORMING IN ANY LIGHT. THEN
WE'RE JUST CREATING MORE
OBSTACLES IN OPPOSITION FROM
EVERYBODY THAT THAT WERE SEEN
SO. I CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY I CAN'T VOTE FOR- BECAUSE
OF- OF THAT AND- I DON'T THINK
THAT THERE'S A WAY OR NOR TIME
THAT IT CAN BE IMPROVED IN THE
NEXT- OF NEXT MONTH BASICALLY A
MONTH AND A HALF SO I CAN'T
SUPPORTED THE BASED ON THE FACT
THAT THE- OF. THE WE'RE NOT
SEEING THE REFORM THAT I THINK
WE'RE ALL LOOKING FOR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATE MCGUIRE.
A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CHAIR THE INCREDIBLE STAFF OF
THE COMMITTEE A AS WELL AS
SENATOR JACKSON FOR THE WORK
THAT HAS GONE INTO THIS BILL
LEADING INTO TODAY- AND
RESEARCHER TRULY APPRECIATE IT
NOW THAT IT IS BEEN A LOT OVER
THE PAST COUPLE WEEKS. AND I
BELIEVE THE MORE WORK IS GOING
TO BE NEEDED ON THIS BILL- AND
I DO HAVE CONCERNS RELATED TO
THE BILL- BUT I WANT TO RESPECT
THE COMMITTEES PROCESS SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATION TODAY KNOWING
KNOWING THAT THIS BILL IS GOING
TO NEED TO BE REFINED- HERE IN
THE COMING WEEKS AND WHETHER IT
IS HERE IN THIS AND THIS IS FOR
YASSER IS A WHOLE NOTHER HOUSE
IN FRONT. OF THIS BILL IS WELL
AND- WE NEED TO BE A TO GO
THROUGH THAT COMMITTEE PROCESS
IN MY BELIEF NEEDING TO BE
REFINED SO SUPPORT THE BILL- IN
KNOWING THAT THERE IS MUCH MORE
WORK TO COME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SURE WITH TENDER AND I AND
EIGHT EIGHT I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR- THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ON THE SOME I WILL SAY- I
A- I A HERE AND SHARE SOME OF
THE- OPPOSITION CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN REYES I WILL SAY I
THINK AT LEAST A NUMBER OF THEM
HAVE BEEN SUBSTANTIVELY.
ADDRESSED BY THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AUTHOR IS AGREED TO-
YOU KNOW THE AS SAID TO GIVE
ANYONE WERE TO GO THROUGH THE
TRANSLATION REQUIREMENTS HAVE
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED
THAT. HAS ME HAS SOME. ALSO
AGREED. TO THE- IDEA TO.
WORKING WITH US ON. I ON ON NOT
SIR TEN HOUSING TO REACH
CERTAIN STANDARDS OF FROM THE
TAMI JOBS FIX IT TO CALL SO I
THINK I'D BE MUCH HARDER TO
CALL THE SENATE AND ANTI
HOUSING BILLS A RESULT OF THAT
CHANGE AND THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF OTHERS AND I'M HAPPY
TO GO OVER PEOPLE WANT
CLARIFIED CLARIFICATION BUT-
YOU KNOW I'LL STAND THIS IS
BEEN A BILL THAT AND HAS
CERTAINLY. STRUGGLED FROM. YOU
KNOW FROMFROM FROM FROM THE
ALL THE DIFFERENT RESPECT.
BECAUSE THIS IS A DIFFICULT
AREA TO MAKE ANY CHANGES IN
HAND- I CERTAINLY RESPECT THE
pYOU KNOW MAKE IT IS A SERIOUS
ATTEMPT HERE- AND SO I'M
CERTAINLY COMFORTABLE VOTING
FOR TODAY- BUT I ALSO YOU'RE MY
COLLEAGUES CONCERN SO. THAT'S
MIND THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AND
WITHOUT I AM A SURGEON THEIR
COMMENTS FROM- FROM THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
THE SENATE THE OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION I
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO IN
JANUARY ALL THE OPPOSITION IS
SUPPOSED TO SEE WHAT I THINK
IT'S- WORKS IN A- VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT FORMS THERE ARE SOME
THAT ARE. SAID TO IN FACT I
WOULD RATHER SHE SHE WILL GO
AWAY- BUT THERE ARE SOME
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING TOWARDS ADDRESSING THEM
WE'VE TAKEN SOME STAND
AMENDMENTS. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE BEING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS- THE NOTION THAT
THIS IS MOVING TOO FAST WITH
TOO MUCH TOO SOON I JUST WILL
HAVE TO SPECULATE DISAGREE
WITH. THESE ARE THIS BILL IS
CULMINATION OF YEARS OF WORK.
WORKING OFF OF THE STAKEHOLDER
DISCUSS WE HAD SEVERAL DAYS AGO
OUT WORK NOT FOR NUMBER IT MUST.
WE'RE JUST EARINGS. GOING WAS
BECAUSE IT IS SO. BECAUSE IT IS
SO CA BUT GOAL HERE IS HOW DO
WE MAKE IT BETTER THE THIS
STATE. GROUP ARE HAS BEEN A
GROUP THAT I SHOW I DO. A
PRACTICE ON ALSO THAT WANTED TO
IMPROVE THE PROCESS IMPROVE THE
RESULTS ARE AND- CERTAINLY WE
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF A NUMBER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS- I'M
HOPING FOR MISSIONAL SUPPORT
WITH THE PAYMENTS THAT WE ARE.
HOPING TO TAKE THIS IS BEEN AN
OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK IT A
CRITICAL TIME AND CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE WHERE WE CAN BRING THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO GET I LOOK
FORWARD TO. I HEARING. SOME
CONSTRUCTIVE SUGGESTIONS FROM
THE CHAMBER AND THOSE IN
OPPOSITION- TO ADDRESS- THEIR
CONCERNS ARE HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
SHE QUIT BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU YOU LOOK AT HAT SOME
OBJECTIONS PARK. FACT AND
SOLUTIONS TO ACTUALLY. WE HEAR
THAT FOLLOW. I AM SCHOOL IF
THAT. IF THE AGENTS ALSO TO
SPEND EIGHT EIGHT. TO OUR THE
TWELVE LOOP WHICH OF CAN WERE
WORKING ON THAT ARE THE
DOCUMENT DUMP WE'VE HEARD SOME
SHOULD DOESN'T FAR. AND YET IT
DOES ALLOW FOR PUBLIC. WHICH IS
CRITICAL WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
DEALING WITH AN ISSUE WHICH HAS
HISTORICALLY. IN ONE OF THE-
MECHANISMS BY WHICH DELAY HAS
BEEN ARE ENCOURAGED. AND THEN
OF COURSE THERE WAS THE USUAL
BONDING THERE WAS SOME
OBJECTION THAT THAT. WOULD
INCREASE THE COST WE ARE TAKING
THAT OUT OF THE BILL SO MY HOPE
IS MY REQUEST IS THAT WE ARE A
LOT OF THIS BILL TO KEEP MOVING
THIS IS A DISCUSSION THAT IS
LONG OVERDUE OR THIS IS A
DISCUSSION THAT IS A
CULMINATION OF MANY YEARS OF
DISCUSSION- AND- I'M- I. AM
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN. COME UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT ADDRESSES
THE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS THAT
ARTICULATED OTHER WITH THE SAME
TIME STILL PRESERVE SHE CAUGHT.
I THINK THAT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THOSE GROUPS WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION. LEGITIMATELY WANT
TO PRESERVE SEQUEL BUT HAVE
SOME. RECOMMENDATIONS AND
CONCERNS THAT WE CAN
INCORPORATE I AM VERY OPEN TO
THAT. AND APPRECIATE AGAIN THE
GOOD WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AS
THE CHAIR POINTED OUT THAT THIS
THIS BILL WILL GO THROUGH
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION AND
PROCESS- IF IT. IS PERMITTED TO
CONTINUE OUR AND I HEAR THE
CONCERNS AYE AYE I AM AWARE.
THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
DIFFERENT PARTIES IN INTEREST
YOUR BUT IFWE REALLY WANT TO I
HELP WITH OUR HOUSING CRISIS AT
THE SAME TIME PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT OUR COMMUNITIES WE-
WHAT. ARE WE NEED TO REFORM IT.
AND WE NEED IMPROVE UPON IT AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL TRIES TO
DO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THE CENTER I'M INNOCENT ONLY
HAS A VERY QUICK- THE JUSTICE
QUESTION I KNOW CENTER WOULD
ASK YOU SOME OF THE BILL.
PROCESS IS THIS BILL NOT GOING
TO ANOTHER COMMITTEES THIS IS.
A GOOD APPROPRIATIONS
BROKERAGE- YEAH BUT RIGHT BUT
BUT- BECAUSE WE ARE ONLY.
MORALLY SINGLE REFERRING THIS
THIS YEAR BECAUSE THE CODE
SITUATION SO YES. IT WOULD
NORMALLY GO TO RUN JUDICIARY
AND. YES THAT WAS IT OKAY YEAH.
OKAY SO THE MOTION FROM CENTER
CASKEY IS TO DO IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECTOR PLEASE CALDERON SENATORS
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES. ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
NINE FIFTY BY SENATOR JACKSON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALLEN
HI. ALLEN HI DAWALY THOUGH
DAWALY NO HERTZBERG. HILL NO
PHIL KNOW MCGUIRE BY THE BAR I
Y. CASKEY BY ASCII. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. I FOR
SENATOR A HERTZBERG PASSES SO
TO THANK YOU RIGHT I KNOW I
SEE- TENER HURTADO IS HERE AND
SHE'S HERE TO PRESENT HER BILL
THAT'S SB NINE SEVEN FOUR.
ANOTHER ANOTHER SEQUEL- RELATED
BILL THOUGH- LESS- LESS LESS
CONTROVERSIAL PERHAPS. FIVE WE
WELCOME YOU CENTER TAUGHT OF 2%
SB NINE SEVEN FOUR. THE FOR
MISTER CHAIRED MEMBERS- GOOD
NEWS FOR YOU ALL TODAY HAVE
ANOTHER SEQUEL BILL TO PRESENT
THIS MORNING- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT MY BILL
SB NINE SEVEN FOUR- I WANT TO
FIRST START BY ASSISTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ARE AS
YOU KNOW MANY SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN. DISTRICT AND BE
I HAVE EXPERIENCED DRY WATER
WELLS STREET CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORIC DROUGHT AND IN NON
DROUGHT YEARS AS WELL UP FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES UNDERTAKEN
WATER QUALITY PROJECTS LIKE
SEQUEL GUIDELINES THIS IS OFTEN
TO A COSTLY AND TIME
PROHIBITIVE- THE COMMUNITY OF
ARGAN IS ONE EXAMPLE HAVING-
YOU KNOW THE PROCESS TAKE
FIFTEEN YEARS TO COMPLETE. TEAM
TO GET SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR
THAT COMMUNITY BOB THE
CONSTRUCTION ITSELF TOOK ABOUT
A YEAR TO COMPLETE SO SB NINE
SEVEN FOUR CREATING NARAL
STATUTORY EXEMPTION FOR
DRINKING WATER PROJECTS. IN
THESE AREAS ESPECIALLY FOR
SCHOOL CHILDREN. AT THIS BILL
HELPS REDUCE COST AND SAVE TIME
ON PROJECTS THAT ADDRESS THE
DRINKING WATER CHALLENGES FACED
BY DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. I
WANT TO THINK I WANT TO THANK
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
WITH MY TEAMMATE WITH SPONSORS
FOR HELPING THIS BILL STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN IT ACHIEVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO WATER WHILE
PRESERVING THE ENVIRONMENT. AND
WILDLIFE. IN REGARDS TO.
OPPOSITION MYSELF AND MEMBERS
OF MY STAFF INCLUDING THE
SPONSORS OF SB NINE SEVEN FOUR.
HAVE BEEN AND PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES. AS A FORMER LABOR
ORGANIZER MYSELF I APPRECIATE
THE CONCERNS RAISED IN REGARDS
TO PREVAILING WAGE AN
APPRENTICESHIP SYSTEM THAT
PROVIDES ACCESS TO A AYE WHICH
CAREERS IN THE BUILDING TRADES.
DESPITE THAT. THE TRUCK TIME MY
STUFF I ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING WITH TEAM.
COLLABORATING WITH THEM TO
DEVELOP A MUTUALLY AGREEABLE UP
LANGUAGE IT IS MY INTENT TO
RESTATE THAT THESE PROJECTS ARE
COVERED BY THE PREVAILING WAGE-
WHICH ALSO ENSURES LOCAL
PRINCES WALL- THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON THESE
CLEAN WATER PROJECTS. ADDITION
I COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH OUR
SPONSORS AND THE BUILDING
TRADES TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
LABOR PROTECTIONS WILL PROVIDE
ACCESS TO COMMUNITY OUR SYSTEM
PROBABLY. BILLS TO EXPEDITE
LOCAL SKILLED CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS. ARE THOSE PROTECTIONS
WILL HELP DRIVE ECONOMIC
INVESTMENT AND CLEAN WATER TO
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
DISADVANTAGED REGIONS REGIONS.
WHILE ALSO ONE POINT A LOCAL
WORKFORCE BY PROVIDING ACCESS
TO REWARDING CAREERS IN
APPRENTICESHIPS. WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
WITNESSES TODAY WHO WILL
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. NINE
SEVEN FOUR WITH ME TODAY ARE AT
SEAMUS A GRIN. OUT FROM SELF
HELP IN A CRISIS THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION- THAT- ASSIST LOW
INCOME COMMITTEES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AND WE ALSO
HAVE BECKY CAN TANA. COMMITTEE
MEMBER OKAY SO MUCH- I WE HAVE-
MISS CONTENTED GOING FIRST IF
THAT'S OKAY FINE WITH ME OKAY
SO SEWER FIRST CAN HEAR FROM
WELL I MEAN IT I GUESS THEY'RE
BOTH ON THE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE SO WHOEVER
WHOEVER WANTS TO GO FIRST I
WOULD TO MISS CANTON AND MISTER
GUERIN. MY NAME IS BECKY BANNER
AT MY FAMILY HAS LIVED IN
SEVILLE SINCE NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN. THE BILL IS THE BLUE IS
MOSTLY FARM WORK COMMUNITY OF
ABOUT A HUNDRED HOUSES IN RURAL
NORTH AND TULARE COUNTY. FOR
THE PAST DECADE. I HAVE BEEN
PART OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
BETTER SEVILLE A GROUP OF
RESIDENTS. ADVOCATE FOR
IMPROVEMENT. IN OUR COMMUNITY.
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD PROBLEMS WITH
OUR WATER. INCLUDING BACTERIA
AND I TRADE CONTAMINATION. BUT
THE WORST CAME EVERY SUMMER
WHEN WE WOULD RUN OUT OF WATER.
WE JUST DIDN'T. HAVE WATER. AND
ARE WELL. YEAH TWENTY. WELCOME
FELL AND WE HAD NO. RAINY WHY
BUT ENTIRE SUMMER. ARKHAM
ADVOCATE FOR SAID AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING. FOUR
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU MAY WRITE TO WATER NEARLY A
DECADE AND I MET PEOPLE FROM IS
THE ROSY AND WEST GOSHEN WHO
STRUGGLED WITH CONTAMINATED
WATER AND RUNNING OUT OF WATER
JUST LIKE THAT. THE BILL. EARLY
THIS YEAR AFTER DECADES OF
RESIDENTS AND OUR PARTNERS. OUR
WATER SYSTEM HAS BEEN UPGRADED
AND OUR WORST PROBLEMS ARE
BEHIND IT. BUT I CHALLENGE
EVERYONE AND TO LEARN SOMETHING
FROM THE EXAMPLE OF OUR
COMMUNITY. HOW CAN WEDELIVER
SOLUTIONS MORE EFFICIENTLY OUR
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE BILL. NOW
AND IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
AND HERE'S- HELLO MY NAME IS
SHANNON AND I'M A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT SPECIALISTS THAT
SELF HELP ENTERPRISE THAT.
CHALLENGE IS DEAD ON WE NEED TO
LEARN THE LESSON THAT THE BILL
AND COMMUNITIES LIKE IT IF WE
DON'T HOW MANY MORE YEARS HOW
MANY MORE DECADES WILL THE
COMMUNITIES OF LEMON COKE RICH
GROW AND ALLEN FOR IT. YOU TO
GO WITHOUT SAFE DRINKING WATER.
ONE OF THE WAYS TO CONNECT
THESE I DON'T PROJECT SB SEVEN
FOR. THE PLAGUE. WHAT IS A GOOD
AND IMPORTANT ALLY AND IN MANY
WAYS PROTECT COMMUNITIES AND
WELL BEING LOW PROTECTED
NATURAL IN. HOWEVER BY APPLYING.
COULD REQUIRE TO THE SMALL
DRINKING WATER CRY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THE
RESULTING CHANGES ARE DELAYED
AND HOPPED OVER RIGHT.
COMMUNITIES LIKE HELD HANNAH
HARDWICK AND CLEAN DEAL CANNOT
WAIT ANY LONGER AND CANNOT
AFFORD TO PICK UP WHERE STATE
FINDING OUT. WE BELIEVE WHAT
THE COMMITTEES CHANGES TO
PREVENT ANY SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT. SB NINE
SEVEN FOUR WILL BE TAILOREDTO
MEET ONLY THE GENUINE URGENT
NEED. ALL COMMUNITY AND THEY
YEAR THAT. AND OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS A LAW THE WAY. AS A
RESULT ALL CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING RESIDENTS TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WILL
QUICKLY FINALLY. HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER THANK YOU.
SEAMUS OKAY A OTHER FLOW OVER
BY THE WAY I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY DAVE YOU AGREE TO THE
MOMENTS THAT CAN BE SENT TO US
OKAY AWESOME. THANK YOU. SO
FOLKS WHO WANT TO ALSO
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT I THINK
WE'VE GOT AFEW PEOPLE ON THE
LINE I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE- IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN-
NOBODY THERE- SO ONLINE
MODERATOR I THINK WE'VE GOT A
COUPLE PEOPLE WANT TO VOICE
SUPPORT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF SB NINE SEVEN FOUR
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. LINE ONE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE. IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WELCOME BACK TO
ONE YEAR ONE MOMENT. IN MIND
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY THANK YOU ON A MATURING
MEMBER DALY GATHERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF CLEAN WATER FOR ALL
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. AND MINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
OUR MEMBERS MY NAME IS MERION
ARMOR DOWN AND WITH OUR STATE
OUR CITY AND YOUR SUPPORT IN
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. NINE
ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS THIS IS
RACHEL SMITH FROM THE WORLD
COMMUNITY ACCEPTANCE
CORPORATION RC EIGHTY OF THE%
PROBLEM CO AUTHOR OF SB. NINE
SEVEN FOUR AND WE URGE YOUR
EYES OUT THANK YOU. IN MINE ONE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THIS IS LINDA COULD
CARE AND WOULD BE ADAM DELL
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICT
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY-
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS BILL PENSAR
LIMóN COAST SANITARY DISTRICT
LIMóN COOL WATER WE SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE ONE HUNDRED AND NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CAN BE
DONE YOU DROWNED THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABOR WE HAVE A
SUPPORT AMENDED POSITION IN A
LETTER IS FORTHCOMING AT THE
TOP THAT CONCERNED THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SMALLER COUNTY OF TULARE
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. IN NINE ONE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO AND GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAN
MATANYA GENERAL MANAGER- WHICH
BROKE COMMUNITY SERVICES
DISTRICT AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE SEVEN FOUR. THANK
YOU. ONE ONE FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS SHERRY HONNEUR I'M
FROM OUT OF BURKE COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICT AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVEN FOUR
THANK YOU. YEAH AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVEN
FOUR PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME FOR COMMENT. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
NINE ONE FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT AFTERNOON LITERATURE AND
HOW MANY MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS
MICHAEL BRAVO SENIOR I WHAT THE
SOUL PANEL LAST MONTH SOME
SCARES ME AND SUPPORT OF SB
NINE SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN FAVOR OF SB NINE SEVEN FOUR
IN THE QUEUE. OKAY SO ONE MORE
TIME MARIE. INTERMENT IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF SB
NINE SEVEN FORM PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY I THINK
WE'RE WE'VE GOT EVERYBODY. AND
OKAY NOW WE DON'T I DON'T HAVE
ANYONE LISTED TO COME AND
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- BUT AND
I DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE FORTY
TWO OR THREE. OR IN ROOM TWENTY.
IN THE SENATE MORE LOCK BUT
LIKE TO WEIGH IN- BUT IF IS
ANYONE ONLINE ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE TO LIKE TO VOICE
OPPOSITION MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE Q. YES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SEVEN
FOUR. PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND LINE ONE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE FORTY TWO YOU
MIGHT BE ON MUTE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARGOT PRADAL TRAINER
OUR GOOD AFTERNOON THERE ARE
NONE- MANY MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY- MY NUMBER
MICHAEL BOTTLE OPENER WORK
FOUND OUT LAST MONTH THERE THE
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE. ONE FOUR. AND ONE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY
BOUT THAT OPERATOR AND MISTER
CHAIR GERMANS NEXT YEAR BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL I
APPRECIATE THE TIME- IF YOU
WERE. IN OPPOSITION. WE CAN
VERY- JUST NEARLY OPPOSING THE
BILL- BASICALLY ON THE PRO
WORKER MEN NEXT TO SENATOR
TITLE DESCRIBED IN AND AGREE
WITH HER THAT WE'VE HAD
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
HER AND THE SPONSORS ND STAFF
WE LOOK FORWARD. THE DAYS AND
WEEKS FORWARD TO- MAKE CHANGES
TO THE BILL BASED ON ON THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I AS ONE IS
REALLY QUICKLY EXPLAIN WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR- AS WITH
EVERY SEQUESTERING ONE BILL. WE
ARE SEEKING AN EXTRA EXTRA
PROGRAMMING WHICH COVERAGE AND
SKILLED IN TRYING WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS- SO THAT WORKER
INTERESTS ARE MAINTAINED. UNDER
SPRING WHICH ENSURES THAT
WORKERS WHO WILL BE DOING THE
ACTUAL WORK ON THESE PROJECTS
GET HATE THE GROWING WAGE AND
THEIR FAMILIES OPEN. BOOKS
WHICH THE BENEFIT. USE OF THIS
CALL THE TRAIN WORK IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE TO PROVIDE WORK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONNECTION TO
A JURY CHURNING TO THEIR
PARTNERSHIP TRAINING- IT
AGREEMENT ALSO BUNCH OF THE
WORKERS NOT SEVERAL. TO BRING.
BUT BY IT CLEAR IN THE BILL
THAT THESE ARE. PROJECT HELPS
COMPLAIN ABOUT YOUR OF
PROTECTION FOR WORKERS. AND BY
ADDING A- YOU JUST GO FRAMEWORK
TO THOSE LIKE THAT NOT ONLY
NEED WORKERS YOU'RE ASKING FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP PRO. AND NOT
ONLY INTO BY UNDER. THAT THEY
ARE PAID. WAGE AND ARE MORE
LIKELY TO END UP WITH THE RIGHT
AGAINST. ACT CONTRA. OR THE YOU
TO HELP CONTAIN UP THE RIGHT.
JOSH OR PROVIDING. YOUR
PERSONAL. IT HAS THE EFFECT OF
TURNING YOUR PARTNERSHIPS AND
PROVIDING UP TO FOR THE NEW
SEVEN THOUSAND PROMISES THE
SYSTEM THIS ALLOWS THEM JOURNEY
THE TRAINING PROGRAM OR A WHAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR NEW CONNECTION
TO COME AND OF TRAINING.
FINALLY A WAY TO SCHOOL IN
TRAIN COVERS TRACKS CALM ON THE
ON THE PROJECTS NEARLY LIKELY
RECALL TO TAKE OUR TIME TO
BLUNT PROJECT BECAUSE CERTAIN
THE BY THE- THEY ALSO KNOW THE
TREAT WORK FAIRLY INTERNET THEY
HIGHLY SHOULD WORKERS WHO ARE
HIGHLY TRAINED THE JOB AT THE
TIME. RIGHT THE POOR
WORKMANSHIP OR PROP PLANNING.
WE LOOK FORWARD AS UP AS TO SET.
ONE ENORMOUS THAT HAVE
DISCUSSED. WE TO INCLUDE HER IN
THE BILL THANK YOU FOR TIME
DATE. IN LINE ONE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO AHEAD. BETTER CARE
MEMBERS MIKE MY NUMBER AT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S I KILL CALPERS
STATUS LEXICAL. IN THE
WESTCHESTER COUNCIL SHEET METAL
I WOULD LIKE TO ONLINE COMMENTS
WITH THAT OF GERMANY'S STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES.
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR ON THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED LANGUAGE AND I'M SURE
DOWN THE ROAD WHEN THAT IS
ACCOMPLISHED WE WILL BE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND ONE ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
QUEST REPRESENTING THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF THE BUILDING TRADES
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO MOVING
INTO A SUPPORT POSITION THANK
YOU. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SEVEN
FOUR. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION COMMENT.
OKAY LAST CALL FOR COMMENTS.
HEARING NONE LET'S NOW GO BACK
TO THE SPRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- QUESTION SPOTS
CONCERNS FROM THE MEMBERS WE
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
AMENDMENTS MISTER TERRORISTS I
WAS- GOING THE COMMAND THE
STAFF AND THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS MEAN THE D.
NARROWING OF THE WORK IS GOING
TO BE DONE I MEAN I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A- CHOIR OF PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT. THE CHALLENGES
WITH SEQUEL BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN EVERY COMMUNITY
DOES HIS GETS THAT INFORMATION
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
THAT WOULD BE HIT. ON A BLANK
CHECK OF ANY SORT OF WANDERED
DISTRICT WE KNOW WHETHER
THEY'RE IN YOUR DISTRICT- MY
DISTRICT. WHEN A SCHOOL IS.
THAT HAS IT IS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS A WATER DISTRICT IS
GAY AND THEN MAYOR THAT'S THE
THAT'S A PROBLEM IN TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT THAT SOME OF THE
SMALL FIELD. SYSTEMS BLACK THE
TECHNICAL SKILLS THE WE'RE WITH
ALL TO PROVIDE THIS AND THE
THEY LACKED THE- DOES THE MONEY
TO COME ON AND NOT KNOW WE'VE
HAD. CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU IN
THIS NARROWING OF THE WORK AND
IT IT'S REALLY. MY WORK IN AN
IN MY MIND IMPORTANT BECAUSE-
IT IT STREAMLINES THE PROCESS
I'M NOT. THE GUY THAT USUALLY
VOTES FOR SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS
REGIS BUT BUT THE NARROW
NARROWING HERE TODAY I FEEL
CONFIDENT YOU KNOW THAT I'M
MORE WORRIED ABOUT THAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKED IN THE
OTHER THE OPPOSITION'S IS REYES
TODAY BECAUSE BECAUSE THIS IS
THIS THIS IS THE PRIMARY
CONCERN TO HAVE SO I APPRECIATE
THE OUGHT. LOOK DEBT AND CAN
THE WORK ON THE ON THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU CENTER CASKEY.
SO SEE MYSELF WITH YOUR
COMMENTS AND- THE QUESTIONS
PARTS. OKAY I HEARD SOMEONE
HERE MOVE THE BILL I THINK WAS
YOU CENTER DOLLY PASS OF THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED- CENTER
HURTADO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST WANTED TO A CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON SB NINE
SEVEN FOUR TODAY AND-
APPRECIATE- CENTER WHAT CAL
SKIS ARE COMMENTS. I THINK. IT
WOULD YOU KNOW FOR IN THE SAME
PAGE WANT TO PROTECT THE
COMMUNITIES. AND I THINK THIS
IS A VERY REASONABLE- UP A BILL
AND- EIGHT THE- STAFF WORKING
WITH IN MAKING. A YOU KNOW JUST
WORKING WITH SISTER BALANCE. SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL. MY APPRECIATE YOU
APPRECIATING HER ARE HARD
WORKING STAFF- THE BILL'S MOVE
A SENATE DOLLY. I SEARCH PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MIND SACRAMENTO
SENATE PREFER. SB NINE. FIND
ANOTHER. SB NO SEVEN FOUR. THE
TORONTO. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AS AMENDED AS AMENDED.
ALLEN HI. HI DOLLY BY PROBABLY
AYE HERTZBERG. FILL BILL I'D
MCGUIRE HI OR I Y. CASKEY HI FI
I. OKAY WILL LEAVE THE OAD
OPEN FOR CENTER HERTZBERG TO
ADD ON. I KNOW SENATE HASEBE
WAY FOR THE WHOLE COME BACK BUT
NOW WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BILL THIS IS SB NINE NINETY
FIVE ARE PRO TEM SEN ATKINS
WILL BE PRESENTING. SB NINE
NINETY FIVE META PRETEND YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. WELL
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN I.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
NINE NINETY FIVE WHICH EXTENDS%
THE SUNSET OF EXISTING
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT OR SEEK WAS
STREAMLINING PROVISIONS. ENABLE
SMALL SCALE HOUSING PROJECTS TO
BENEFIT FROM THE STREAMLINING
AS WELL. SB NINE NINE FIVE AS
PART OF OUR HOUSING PRODUCTION
PACKAGE WHICH LAND SQUARELY
WITHIN THE SENATE PRIORITY OF
JOBS. AS WELL AS WITH THE
SHARED GOAL OF DELIVERING A
JUST AND EQUITABLE RECOVERY. I
WANT TO THANK THE GROUP OF LEAD
SENATE THAT WORKED WITH TO BE
HONEST CERTAINLY- SENATORS
MCGUIRE. AQABA GYRO DERIDE SO
SALAS STILL ROTH AND RUBIO FOR
STEPPING UP TO LEAD THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS ISSUE. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY JOINT
AUTHORS SENATOR WIENER WHO'S
MOVED THE BALL FURTHER ON
HOUSING- THAN MANY THOUGHT
POSSIBLE. AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND OUR GRATITUDE
TO HIM FOR THAT I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MISTER AYE CASKEY
FOR HIS INCREDIBLE WORK ON IT
USE. I WHICH IS REALLY LED TO
THIS WHOLE POP. PROSPECT OF-
HELPING PRODUCTION. IN A NEW
AND DIFFERENT WAY. SB NINE
NINETY FIVE IS A KEY PART OF
OUR PACKAGE IN THAT IT ENSURE
SMALL SCALE HOUSING PROJECTS
ARE NOW ELIGIBLE FOR AB NON.
PROGRAMMERS IF. S. TOTALS LOCAL.
TO CONDUCT MORE EFFICIENT
SEQUEL RIVER IS. BY UTILIZING.
THE MASTER AND FOCUSED
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT OR
THE M. E. A. R. F. YEAH OUR
PROCESS FOR THOSE WHO LOVE
ACRONYMS. IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AB NINE HUNDRED
WHICH IS STABILISED A NEW
PROCESS UNDER SEQUEL TO
STREAMLINE ADMINISTRATIVE
RECORD PAPERWORK. AN EXPEDITED
LEGAL CHALLENGES FOR LARGE
MULTI BENEFIT HOUSING CLEAN
ENERGY AND MANUFACTURING
PROJECTS. THAT HAVE A CAPITAL
INVESTMENT OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. AB NINE
HUNDRED SUNSETS ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO
DATE EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED HAS
RESULTED IN A LEAST TWELVE
SEPARATE MEGAPROJECTS
REPRESENTING OVER TWO BILLION
IN INVESTMENTS IN OUR STATE.
ACCORDING TO THE INFORMATION
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH IN THE
SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH.
THESE PROJECTS HAVE PROVIDED
OVER TEN THOUSAND NEW HOUSING
UNITS AND CREATED THOUSANDS OF
NEW HIGH WAGE CONSTRUCTION AND
PERMANENT JOBS. THIS BILL
EXTENDS AB NINE HUNDRED UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND
EXPERIENCE IT SO THAT IT WOULD
APPLY TO MUCH SMALLER HOUSING
PROJECTS. WE'RE CURRENT AB NINE
HUNDRED LAW NOW SAYS ONLY
PROJECTS OF A HUNDRED MILLION
OR GREATER OR ELIGIBLE. SB NINE
NINE FIVE LOWER SET THRESHOLD
TO FIFTEEN MILLION SO SMALLER
HOUSING PROJECTS QUALIFY. SB
NINE NINETY FIVE ALSO REQUIRES
THAT PROJECTS HAVE AT LEAST 50%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THAT THEY
WILL BE INFILL PROJECTS AND
THAT THEY MEET SPECIFIED LABOR
AND ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS.
SEPARATE FROM THE AB NINE
HUNDRED PROCESS CURRENT LAW
UNDER SEQUEL ALLOWS FOR THE USE
OF MASTER AND FOCUSED
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORTS.
THIS PROCESS WAS ENACTED INTO
LAW IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETIES DURING THE AEROSPACE
RECESSION. THE ME I OUR FBI ARE
PROCESS IS INTENDED TO
STREAMLINE SEQUEL REVIEWS BUT
HAS SUFFERED FROM A FUNDING
DRIVEN. LACK OF INTEREST AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SB NINE NINETY FIVE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE USE OF THE
MASTER PLANS- STREAMLINING FOR
HOUSING. THE STATE IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THE COST
ANALYSES. THIS WILL OPEN UP A
TOOL FOR LOCALS THAT THEY WANT
TO USE. SMALL INVESTMENT FOR
THE PAYS DIVIDENDS. YEAH BEFORE
COVERED NINETY HEAD WE WERE
ALREADY DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
ADDRESSING OTHER CRISIS SEASON
WERE FACING CALIFORNIA.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HOUSING
PRODUCTION BEING RIGHT THERE AT
THE TOP. EARLIER THIS YEAR. I
MADE A PLEDGE THAT THERE WOULD
BE A HOUSING PRODUCTION
LEGISLATION PACKAGE THE SESSION
FROM THE SENATE. SB NINE NINE
FIVE IS  KEY PART IN
FULFILLING THIS PLEDGE TO SPUR
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DEVELOPERS AND OTHERS. I AM
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS BUT I ALSO ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU
FOR STRUCTURE MEANT THANK YOU
MA'AM- PRETEND IT THAT- AND YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY APPRECIATE. YOUR
WILLINGNESS SIDE OF IT IF JUST
EXPRESSING THAT YOU'VE
EXPRESSED TO ME ON THE PHONE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AS IT
MOVES FORWARD- WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. AT THE
TIME THAT THAT THAT THIS REALLY
KEEPS WITH THE SPIRIT OF THE OF
THE LEADERSHIP PROJECTS THEY
WERE AT THE HEART OF A. B. NINE
HUNDRED THAT ARE TRULY-
ENVIRONMENTAL CONFRONT LINE
PROJECTS AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S- VERY IMPORTANT AT THIS
COMMITTEE AND- I KNOW OUR
MEMBERSHIP- I DON'T HAVE ANY
LEE WITNESSES EITHER IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. I REGISTERED BUT
I I'M I UNDERSTAND THAT MAYBE
SOME PEOPLE ON THE PHONE LINES.
HOW WE DON'T SEEM TO HAVE
ANYONE HERE. IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE A AND I DON'T SEE ANYONE
IN- TWENTY FORTY- BUT BUT
MODERATOR TELL US DO WE HAVE WE
DO HAVE FOLKS ON THE LINE. YEAH
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK ON SB NINE NINE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN THAT THAT SPEED NINE NINE
FIVE. ONE MOMENT OF TIME IN.
LINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S A
GREAT RUNNER WITH CARBON
RECEIVERS BEHALF BY SCHNEIDER
ELECTRIC ARC AMERICA OR IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND BE
DRAWN LIKE SUPPORT THE SENATOR.
AND THE ENTIRE HOUSING PACKAGE.
THANK YOU AND LINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BACKING CARE ADAM
REGULARLY AGAIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ONE REGISTER OUR SUPPORT FOR.
SB NINE NINE FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN LINE ONE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD NUMBERS THAT THE
MATTER NOT LIKE HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF.
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE IN THE COURT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE
ONE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CALIFORNIA YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU LINE ONE FIFTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MORE WERE TOP ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
ALLEY TUNING CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
INSPECTING OUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU IN LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR HONOR MEMBERS MIGHT THE
TEMPERATURES GO VERY OF
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION PUBLIC POLICY THINK
TANK KNOWN AS FOR. STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE FIVE
AND THANK PRESIDENT PRO TEM
ATKINS FOR OFFERING THE SPOT
THE LEGISLATION. OVER THE PAST
DECADE SEVERAL LARGE AND
TRANSFORM THE MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT SUPPLIES A. B. NINE
HUNDRED ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. COULD INCLUDE
THOUSANDS OF HOUSING UNITS
INCLUDING DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THIS
PROGRAM OF THE DEMONSTRATE
TRACK RECORD IN DELIVERY HIGH
QUALITY CATALYTIC PROJECTS THAT
ATTRACT MAJOR INVESTMENT IN THE
RIGHT PLACES INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES WHILE BUILDING IN A
GREEN AND SUSTAINABLE WAY. AND
GENERATING WELL PAYING JOBS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT EXTENDED THE SUN DATE
FOR THE PROGRAM AS WE FOCUS ON
ECONOMIC PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT.
BUT THE CRITICAL MOVED TO
CREATE CERTAINTY AND
PREDICTABILITY BUT ABOUT THE
PLANNING AND INVESTMENT. WE'RE
ALSO THRILLED WITH THE
AMENDMENT WILL ALLOW HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS WITH AMENDMENT
DOES NOT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM. OR HOUSING DEFICIT A
NUMBER OCCASIONS BUT DECLARE.
STATEWIDE STERN BY THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND IT MAKES SENSE
TO PRIORITIZE HOUSING IN THIS
WAY AS LONG AS AT LEAST FIFTEEN
PERCENT. OF THE PROJECT
CONTAINS AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OFTENTIMES THE VERY URBAN AND
BILL SITES NEAR JOBS IN TRANSIT
WE FAVOR MOST. ARE SMALLER IN
ACEH PARCELS AND THE PROJECT
WELL UNDER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. BUT MAYES GOODBYE
SENSE ANALYZE WITH EXISTING
STATE ALSO PRIORITIES
INVESTMENTS. TO INCLUDE THESE
DEVELOPMENTS ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. WE ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT BOND CITY TO CONDUCT
MASTERY AYE OURS UP FRONT FOR
HOUSING ELEMENT OTHER PLANS. SO
THAT WERE THE HOUSING PROJECT
CAN TEAR OFF OF THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS. THIS
IS URBAN PLANNING CAN YOU
DEVELOPMENT AT ITS FINEST.
OUTSTANDING BUILDING HERE DRIVE
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JOSE
DEMONS AND I AM A HOTEL WORKER
I LIVE IN BOYLE HEIGHTS BUT I
USED TO LIVE IN WEST HOLLYWOOD.
THE HOUSING CRISIS PUTS ME AT A
WEST HOLLYWOOD AND FURTHER FROM
MY JOB S I AGREE WE NEED MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUPPORT THE
GOALS OF THIS LAW BUT WE SHOULD
AN EXPEDITED HOTELS DRIVING TO
MY JOB I CAN KIND OF CRANES.
PUTTING UP HOTEL BUT THEY STILL
DON'T HOUSING FOR MY FAMILY TO
LIVE IN PLEASE AMEND THE BILL
TO ENSURE IT FOCUSES ON HOUSING
PROJECTS TO HELP THE COMMUNITY
NOT THE HOTELS. AND SHORT TERM
RENTAL THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CAN MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN SMITH HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE CALL AN. HI MY NAME IS
JOE NUMBER AS WELL- AND I'M
HERE AS A FORMER SANTA MONICA
HOTEL WORKER AND- I JUST WANT
TO EXPRESS YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
YOUR LOCAL LEVIN SUPPORTS GOLD.
BUT WE- YEAH HERE FIVE FOR
INCREASED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
FOR YEARS BUT WE ALSO WANT ASH
ENSURE THAT COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT DOESN'T CROWD OUT
HOUSING. SB NINE NINETY FIVE
COULD DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PROJECTS ELIGIBLE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
CERTIFICATION HOWEVER THERE ARE
LOOPHOLES IN THE DEFINITION OF
A HOUSING PROJECT IN THIS BILL.
WILL PUTTING. THREE TEACHER
TELLS OR OTHER COMMERCIAL USES
AT THE FRONT OF THE LINE IN OUR
COURT SYSTEM AND AT THE EXPENSE
OF EVERY OTHER CALIFORNIA AND-
TRYING TO HAVE THEIR DAY IN
COURT. WE URGE YOU TO CHANGES
THAT CHEN OF HOUSING PROJECTS
TO CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES AND
CARVE OUT CONTEXT WITH HOTELS
AND ADDITIONAL REQUIRE THAT YOU
KNOW YOU CAN IT. AT THE END
FROM THE- USED FOR SHORT TERM
GOALS THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS
MIKE MONOGRAMMED YEP THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
WATER CO WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE I CRINGE COUNCIL IN THE
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE FIVE.
ONE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- BOB OUR ON BEHALF OF
ONE HIGHWAY ONE IN SUPPORT OF
THE PRO TEM'S BILL SB NINE NINE
FIVE. MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT WAS
THE LAST ONE. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH- ANY ONE FINAL ROUND OF.
BUT ONE ONE ONE MORE ONE MORE
ASK OF FOLKS WHO MAY WANT TO
WEIGH IN ON THE BILL. I GUESS
WE HEARD IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO ONE ZERO. OKAY HEARING
NONE I GUESS WE GOT A MIX OF
SUPPORT AND SOME CONCERNS BUT-
I GUESS WE HAVE TO FORMALLY ASK
FOR OPPOSITION. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WANTS TO DO IS
TO ANYONE IS IN OPPOSITION. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB. NINE
NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIRMAN. ONE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
MOLECULAR AMERILA TO CALIFORNIA
WE GET CONSERVATION BETTER IT
I'M JUST WANTED TO RAISE AND WE
JUST HAVE CONCERNED- WITH THE
DAHLE AND MAKE SURE THAT ANY
PRODUCTS WHICH QUALIFY FOR THE
EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED PEOPLE
BENEFIT. I RIGHT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND GENETIC BENEFIT
AND WE LOOK TO WITH THE CAN AND
HAVE. ON THE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LEARN SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT PER LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY IN
LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS- SALVADOR I'M OFFER TO
WORK AND I LIVE IN SANTA MONICA
I LIVE AND WORK IN SANTA
MONICA. THE HOUSING HOW CAN
CRISIS HAS BEEN WITH US FOR A
LONG TIME AND WE DEFINITELY.
ENCOURAGE AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
I SUPPORT THE COURTS OVER THE
SMALL BOX. WE SURE NEXT BUT I'D
HOTEL IN OTHER COMMERCIAL
PROJECTS THAT DON'T SERVE THE
COMMUNITY WE NEED TO FOCUS
FOCUS ON HOW NOT SHORT TERM
RENTAL. RIGHT NEAR. THE END OF
MANY. DIDN'T MONICA. WE'RE
SORRY STORIES ALL LAND LAW. TO
GET OUT THERE TO PUTTING. A
VACATION RENTALS WHICH DRAW UP
READ FOR ALL OF OUR- PLEASE
CHANGE THE TO ENSURE HOLD.
PROJECT ARE EXCLUDED AND NOW OF
THEIR YOU CREATED IT. USE FOR
SHORT RENTAL. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. OKAY ONE MORE TIME AS ONE
ONE FINAL CALL FOR FOLKS TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE NINE FIVE
THAT'S ONE ZERO. OKAY NO ONE OF
JUDAH JENNIFER YOU SO MUCH
AMANDA MODERATOR ALL RIGHT NOW
THE MEASURE IS BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND I
SEE CENTER BECAUSE HIS QUESTION.
YES I'D LIKE THANK THE AUTHOR
THE FIRST FOR USING THE AB NINE
HUNDRED SERIES I MEAN WE LET'S
BE CLEAR THAT THERE IS GOING TO
BE AND HE AYE OURS COULD BE
PREPARED THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
MEDICATION THIS COULD BE
REQUIRED. THAT THERE'S COULD BE
PUBLIC HEARING THAT THERE'S
COULD BE A RIGHT TO SUE THAT
ALL THESE PACKAGES GO WINNER
THERE'S A- A RUSH FOR
EXEMPTIONS IT SEEMS TO BE THE
CLIMB THAT AROUND WITH THAT. I
IN TWO OF THE GOVERNOR- WHEN HE
MAKES A CERTIFICATION ON THESE
LEADERSHIP PROJECTS AND THEY
ARE LEADERSHIP PRIDE PROJECT
SO- HE I'LL GET AND I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE WAS C.
YOU'VE PICKED A FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR LIMIT I WAS HOW WAS THAT
ARRIVED AT BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT IS COULD GENERATE A LOT
OF. CHECKS IN IN THIS IN THIS
FIELD- THIS THE FIRST QUESTION
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
WE CASKEY WHAT WE HOPE IT
GENERATES PROJECTS FRANKLY-
THAT'S THE THAT WAS THE POINT
TO EXTENDING TO OF US FOR THREE
WHOLE TEEN. AT BEST AS ARMS.
YOU KNOW THE LARGE PREY UNDER
THE A. B. NINE HUNDRED- WE'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF THOSE PROJECTS
WHICH I THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE
IN YOUR BACKUP- IS THE ISSUE
HERE AS PART OF THE DISCUSSION
OTHER COLLEAGUES. WAS THE OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE THAT HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM A. B. NINE
HUNDRED BECAUSE OF THE SCALE OF
THE DEVELOPMENT SIDE AND IT IS
BILLION SOME PART IT'S ABOUT
SECTION OF HOUSING AND INCLUDE.
HAVE DIFFICULT IT'S NOT PART OF
YOUR- AB NOT HUNDRED BILLION.
HOLE ALSO ABOUT PARTS OF OUR
THAT HAVE BEEN A TAX THAT AND
THAT OP. LIKE HE- OUT AT
PROVIDE. OPPORTUNE SO IN AND IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT SOME PARTS OF
OUR STATE IN IN MANY CASES SOME
OF OUR MORE RURAL AREAS. THIS
IS NOW A TOOL THAT THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO USE OUR TO SUPPORT-
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING- AND SO.
THAT WAS THE THOUGHT THAT WENT
BEHIND IT SENATOR WIECKOWSKI
YOU ONE NIGHT AND CENTER HERE
OLD CALL HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
LEVIN WE VOTED ON. A. B. NINE
HUNDRED. OUR INTEREST AT THAT.
WOULD THESE. EGGS IN MARCH
PROJECTS THAT THE HUNDRED
THOUSAND THRESHOLD IS ONE IS
ONE THING BUT YOU KNOW OUR
THINKING AT THE TIME WE THOUGHT
THEY WERE LEAD CERTIFIED THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE- ENERGY
EFFICIENCY LEVELS. THE STAFF
REPORT HAS SEVEN PAGE ELEVEN
MAKES SEVERAL SUGGESTIONS ON
AMENDING IT TO MODERNIZE SAID
WITH THE GREATER ENVIRONMENTAL-
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE
TODAY THEY WERE DEMANDING OF
YOU KNOW THE OAKLAND AIDS
PROJECT WAS NET ZERO- WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON PAGE
ELEVEN. FIVE EXCELLENT
QUESTION- WE CERTAINLY
ANTICIPATE ARE FOR WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE SMALLER PROJECTS THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
THRESHOLD WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS BILT INTO THAT THAT
AS WELL IN TERMS OF
PROGRAMMATIC LIKE. WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT MODERNIZE STING THE
IT'S BEEN A DECADE SINCE AB
NINE HUNDRED ALMOST. WE DO WANT
TO TAKE. MORE THAN TWO FIVE
TALK TO- STAKEHOLDERS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WE ARE STILL IN
CONVERSATION WITH A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING ON THAT
ISSUE AND I THINK WE'RE OPEN TO
THAT AND CAN POSSIBLY INCLUDE
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD. TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND INTO EMBLEY
IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND-
CONVERSATION WITH THE CHAIR. AB
I SAID THIS IS SOMETHING WE%
NEED TO CONSIDER YEAH I MEAN I
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISPARAGING COMMENTS ABOUT
STATE SPORTS STADIUMS FROM THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH DOWN HERE AND
THE PROJECTS THAT KING MAN THAT
WENT TO THIS COMMITTEE ON WHAT
TO JUDICIARY. YOU KNOW THE
PROJECT TWENTY CENT REDUCTION
AND VEHICLE TRIPS WE HAD- THE
COME OVER TO OF THE BILL THAT
CAME THROUGH AND IT. HOME
REDUCTION SO- HOPING THAT
BECAUSE THIS. HE THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME
FOLKS THAT WANT TO HAVE. THE
OFFICIAL PLEASE WE- FOR NOW
THAN WE DID IN TWO THOUSAND AND
IN IN WOULD OF BE MAY. A SHOULD
BE EASILY TO BE ADOPTED- THIS
IS THE SINGLE REFERRED HERE
THERE'S ALWAYS A QUESTION IF
THIS WERE BEFORE THE JUDICIARY
WHICH OF LUCK- I'M JUST
HAPPENED TO BE A MEMBER WE WILL
BE ASKING ABOUT THE TAX ON THE
COURTS. AND THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL HAS AND- SET THIS BUT
DE M. SAFI PORT TALKS ABOUT THE
TO BENEFITTED WHETHER. CANNABIS
DAYS OR REAL DAYS WHEN WE GET
TO THE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE DAY EXPEDITED- AS- I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT OVERLOADING THE
COURTS- WITH. ADDITIONAL CASES
ESPECIALLY WITH THE THRESHOLDS
THAT YOU HAVE THE HAVE A
COMMENT ON THAT. WELL I WOULD
AGREE THAT WE WANT OUR COURT
SYSTEM TO OPERATE IN A FAIR AND
EVEN MANNER HI. AND I THINK-
WHEN IT COMES TO- TO THESE
PROJECTS. IT OUT THE ORIGINAL
PROJECTS AND I WILL. AGREE WITH
YOU THAT OBVIOUSLY THIS COULD
OPEN THE DOOR TO MANY MORE
PROJECTS. BUT AT THE SAME
CONCERN WAS RAISED OUR
ORIGINALLY UNDER AB NINE
HUNDRED- BACK IN TWENTY ELEVEN
BUT MOST LITIGATION WAS
RESOLVED QUICKLY. PROJECTS
NEVER EVEN IF IT UP IN THE
COURTS- ARE BOTH CURRENT LAW
AND MY MEASURE WILL GIVE
LATITUDE TO THE COURTS TO
MANAGE THEIR CALENDARS AND
PROCESS THESE CASES. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
MUCH LIKE WE DONE AB TORRENT.
HUNDRED AND PROJECT. CAME TO
THE TERM WHAT THE EXPERIENCES
AND WE CAN. YEAH WE CAN ADJUST
OUR AND OF COURSE OUR COURTS
HAVE ALWAYS NEEDED- INCREASE
FUNDING AND SUPPORT. BY THAT
WILL NOT CHANGE IN THOSE OF US
WHO CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
FUNDING FOR THE COURTS WILL
KEEP DOING THAT. I ALSO I JUST
WANNA IT TO YOUR LAST QUESTION
A POINT. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT OF
THE MEGA PROJECTS AS AS THEY'RE
SOMETIMES REFERRED. BY ANY
INVESTMENT THE STATE IT WAS TWO
BILLION DOLLARS BUT OF THOSE
PROJECTS. NO WE LOVE TO TALK
THE STADIUM ARENAS PEOPLE'S
MENTAL I'M ON THAT. I JUST WANT
OUT WE GET FIVE THE NUMBER OF
THE PRICE SAID. THE HEADLINE
BUT- IN CENTER HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO YOU. OF THE THREE OF SO
YEAR FOR TREVOR- POWER
STATIONS- TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
TO THREE THOUSAND NEW UNITS I
MEAN. I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS WE TALK ABOUT MEGA PROJECTS
WE REMEMBER THAT THIS PROJECTS
WERE ALSO ABOUT HOUSING.
LOWERING THE THRESHOLD WHILE I
UNDERSTAND IN THIS IS NEW
TERRITORY AND NEW GROUND FOR
US. I HOPE IT'S GOING TO
PROVIDE PROJECTS IN YOUR
DISTRICT MISTER DALI. AND IN
CENTRAL VALLEY AND I THINK WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MONITOR IT
AND IN TERMS OF THE DEFINITION
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
DAYS CALENDAR DAYS VERSUS
BUSINESS DAYS. THAT IS
SOMETHING WILL TAKE A LOOK AT
AS WELL AS THE ISSUES THAT THE
COMMITTEE BROUGHT UP. IN TERMS
OF CONCERNS- THAT WE LOOK AT
AND WHETHER WE DO AMENDMENTS IN
THE MODERN IS TEN PIECE OF
WHAT'S RECOMMENDED. BUT WE'LL
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND TRY TO CLARIFY SOME
OF THOSE THINGS MOVE FORWARD WE
WANT MORE CLARITY NOT LESS I
AGREE. BECAUSE THE STAFF REPORT
POINT CITED. AT TWELVE AS IT
WAS ARE SENATE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH ONCE TALKS ABOUT THE
YOU KNOW THE CLARITY OF MAKING
SURE WE GET. WE KNOW THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS HE
CREATED IN THE PROJECT ONCE
IT'S COMPLETED. AND THE OTHER-
RETAIL SPACES THAT THAT MAKES
AGAIN IF WE WERE LABELING THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
PROJECT SO. HI FI A HOPE FOR.
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD THAT
WE CONSIDER THE REDUCTION AND
TRANSPORTATION EFFICIENCIES THE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN THE
BUILDING AND THE ACTUAL- LEED
CERTIFIED LEVEL DEAD DEAD WITH
THEIR SMALL IN- SIERRA COUNTY
OR BIG IN SAM AT AND SAN DIEGO
THEY HAVE THERE'S A THERE'S A
STYLE THERE'S SOMETHING A
SIGNATURE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PUTS ON THESE
PROJECTS THAT SAY THIS IS THE
TYPE OF. ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP PROJECT WE WANT TO
SEE HER A BILL BECAUSE AT THE
END OF MY QUESTIONS MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR CENTER. PLEASE SECURE
BE BRIEF I JUST WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE TO
PRETEND ON THE CLAMOR PROCESS
THAT SHE IS ESTABLISHING THIS.
BRINGING TOGETHER INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY HAVE HAD CHALLENGES TO
PREVIOUS HOUSING BILLS IN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO SUPPORTED THE
PREVIOUS HOUSING BILLS IN HOW
TO BE A TO BRING FORWARD A
CONSENSUS DRIVEN PROCESS. TO BE
GET SOMETHING DONE THIS YEAR
AND FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH A
COMMITMENT. IN THE SENATE BUT
ALSO TO THE REST OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND CANDIDLY THIS
WILL BE. ONE OF THE BOLDEST
PACKAGES THAT WE'VE SEEN
RELATED TO HOUSING IN ONE OF
THE MOST CHALLENGING ERRORS
THAT WE HAVE WHEN IT COMES TO
HAS BEEN ESPECIALLY. IN THE ERA.
OF THIS THIS- THE OTHER
IMPORTANT DE THIS IS IT THIS
WILL CREATE THAT THE HIGHEST
MANDATORY STATEWIDE
AFFORDABILITY. REQUIREMENT
ENACTED INTO LAW. WHICH IS
CREATING NEW FIFTEEN PERCENT.
MINIMUM WHEN IT COMES TO-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO FOR
DEVELOPER RECEIVED A
STREAMLINED PROCESS THEN THEY
HAVE TO BUILD AT MINIMUM 15%
THAT'S JUST. FOR OBVIOUSLY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COULD GO
HIGHER THAN THAT I JUST THINK
THATIS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL HI
TO COME WHEN IT COMES TO
SOLVING OUR PROCESS. AND I
THINK IT WAS MISS CABALLERO
THAT SAID THIS- IN THE WORKING
GROUP SHE SAID WHAT'S GOOD FOR
MILLIONAIRES AND BILLIONAIRES
WHEN IT COMES OF STADIUM
PROJECTS SHOULD BE GOOD FOR
WORKING FAMILIES. IN
CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE CLASS AND I
THINK THAT. THIS BILL
ACCOMPLISHES JUST THAT JUST
ONCE A THINK IT THE PROTEIN HER
PARK BECAUSE RICHARD. THANK YOU
CAN ACQUIRE. SO I AM I
CERTAINLY REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENTS YOU'VE JUST MADE
ADD TO BOTH THE COMMITTEE AND
ALSO TO CENTER WILL CASKEY- I
THINK. IF YOU KNOW WHEN A. B.
NINE HUNDRED WAS WRITTEN IT
REALLY WAS ALL ABOUT.
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
PROJECTS AND I THINK AND WE ALL
VERY MUCH AGREE WITH THE NEED
FOR- FOR DRESSING WRAPPING
CHALLENGES- WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE IN THIS OF COURSE IS
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE SO THIS IS OUR- THE
SENATE'S. PLACE TO TALK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL. AND YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT FOR
OFFERING. THIS SPECIAL
STREAMLINING. THE THAT THE
PROJECT REALLY DO ME HI
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH US TO ENSURE THAT
THAT'S THE CASE. THAT THE STONE
WAS FOR ANSWER WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING I'M CERTAINLY NOT
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE AND
HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY AND YOUR LEADERSHIP N
THIS. DIFFICULT AND IMPORTANT
ISSUE SO. WITH THAT AS IN HERS.
EITHER I DO SAID THIS OTHER
CONTEXTS BUT I THINK IT'S AND-
HI MY FOR JUST TO GET A CALL.
FEW WITH THE LOS ANGELES
DELEGATE. REALLY MEANT A LOT OF
TIMES. ABOUT HOUSING ISSUES WE
HAVE MET WITH EXPERTS FROM. THE
UC SYSTEM AND A NUMBER OF
CONSULTING FIRMS. AND THINKING
THROUGH OUR AND ACROSS THE
BOARD ALL OF US IN ALL
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE VERY
LARGE COUNTY. ABOUT WHAT TO DO
AND THIS MEASURE FITS RIGHT IN
WITH RESPECT TO THE LARGER
THINKING. DO THE VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AT THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR NUMBER
CERTAINLY I THINK WE THINK
IT'LL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT. IN INCENTIVIZING FOLKS
TO. TO ME THANK. JORDAN HOW DO
WE HAVE A PROCESS COUNTY WHICH
ONE IS THAT FOR THE RECORD
THANKS VERY MUCH MINIMUM. PUT
FOR THIS MEASURE. MEMBER TO MY
REALIZE THAT THERE'S ONE
IMPORTANT AS HOUSEKEEPING
THERE'S ONE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
THAT I A CENTER STAND YOU'RE
ACCEPTING AND IN ADDITION. OKAY
YES AND YES YES AND YES OKAY SO
JUST AS- IT WITH THAT. WITH
THAT- CERTAINLY ENTERTAIN A
MOTION AS IS REMOVED BY THE
MAJORITY LEADER- AS SECRETARY
CUT I'M SORRY MADAM PRESIDENT.
A QUICKLY I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
HERE FOR AWHILE I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
WEAR MULTIPLE HATS THAT WAS THE
DIRECTION WE GAVE WE SINGLY
REFERRED BILLS. AT THAT YOU
TAKE SERIOUSLY THE JOB OF
COVERING ALL OF THE COMMITTEES
THAT WOULD NORMALLY HE'LL HERE.
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION WE
CLEARLY HAVE SOME WORK TO DO
OUT WITH STAKEHOLDERS STILL
LIKE NOT MUCH THAT IN. CONTENT
TO DO THAT. THIS IS NOT MY WELL
THIS IS A WORK PRODUCT NAY MAY
BE ON THE BILL WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR THIS WORK PRODUCT OF A
LOT OF INPUT AND- STEAK THERE'S
A- WITH. CAN TAKE TO TRY WORK
THROUGH. I'M WE HAD TO THINK IN
OF. I'M UP A NEW TO OR TRY TO
OUT HOW TO SPUR HOUSING
PRODUCTION- I WILL SAY AND
REMIND FOLKS THAT UNDER THE
ORIGINAL AB NINE HUNDRED. AND
THIS WILL APPLY AT THESE
PROJECT AS WELL THE DESIRE ODD
FOR US TO MEET THOSE-
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND THE
OTHER BLOG AND GUIDELINES IS
STILL IN PLACE AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THESE PROJECTS
GO. OUR AND- PR AS WELL AS THE
J. L. R. B. THAT THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET THE OFFICE
OF RESEARCH AND PLANNING AND
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD SO AS
NOT TO USE ALL THOSE INITIALS.
THAT IS THOSE ARE THOSE ARE IN
PLACE FOR A REASON- SO THAT WE
MEET THE INTENT OF WHAT THE
ORIGINAL AB NINE HUNDRED WAS
FOR- SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE REMEMBERED THAT AS
PART OF THE PROCESS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU. AS
WE MOVE THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FORWARD. NUMBER TEN
OKAY SO THE BILL'S MOVE BY SEN
HURTS FOR A SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR BIKES. ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB NINE NINE FIVE BY SO I
CAN. DO PASSAGE TENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI DOLLY. HERTZBERG BY
HERTZBERG AYE HILL. MCGUIRE HI
MCGUIRE AYE BY CASKEY. FIVE MY
COUNTY I. OKAY. THANK YOU- WE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
CENTER HELL TO ADD ON- BUT IT
DEPRECIATED. I'M ART ON. THANK
YOU ONE THE MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR THIS IS SB TEN FORTY FOUR
WOULD SENATOR ALLEN. SENATOR
PLEASE PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
SB TEN FORTY FOUR PROHIBITS THE
MANUFACTURE SALE AND USE OF
CERTAIN FIRE FIGHTING FOAMS
THAT CONTAINS THE CHEMICALS PER
AND POLY FLORA KILLS SUBSTANCES
WHICH ARE KNOWN AS P. FUSS.
HAPPY FATHERS ARE LONG LASTING
CHEMICALS THAT BUILD UP IN OUR
BODIES IN THEIR LINKED TO
NUMEROUS HEALTH PROBLEMS
INCLUDING CANCER DAMAGE TO THE
KIDNEYS AND LIVER AS WELL. P.
FIVE ARE ACTUALLY HARMFUL TO
INFANTS AND CHILDREN AND CAN
CAUSE DAMAGE THAT LASTS INTO
ADULTHOOD. AND THAT THESE
pCHEMICALS HAVE BEEN USED IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND THEY'RE IN
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
PRODUCTS SUCH AS CARPETS
CLOTHING OTHER EVERYDAY
MATERIALS THAT ARE RESISTANT TO
SHEET STEENS AGREES AND WATER.
AND IN A PART OF THE VALUE OF
THE CHEMICALS IS THAT THEY'RE
SO STATE. BUT THAT THE COURSE
BECOMES ONE OF THE BIG PROBLEMS
WITH THE CHEMICALS BECAUSE
THEY'RE SO STABLE THEY DON'T
BREAK DOWN THE END UP
ACCUMULATING IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT. AND IN THE END UP
INOUR BODIES AND IT TURNS OUT
NOW SO WHITES THAT NEARLY EVERY
PUT. AN EXPOSE AS TO THESE
CHEMICALS I SOMETHING LIKE 98%
NOW I HAVE P. FIVE. CAN IN
THERE HE'S AND- ALSO KNOWN TO
CONTAIN. DRINKING WATER ON THE
COUNTRY. THE OF FIRE FIGHTING
PHONE THAT'S BEEN USED TO FIGHT
LIQUID FIRES AS A PRIMARY
SOURCE OF THIS CONTAMINATION
AND ENDS UP IN THE ENVIRONMENT
SEEPING INTO THE WATER. AND NOW
RECENT STUDIES SHOW ON THAT AND
SOMETHING LIKE SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
OUR OUR HAVE THEIR WHAT. CAN
TO. BY P. FIVE. AND WE ALSO
KNOW. THAT SOME OF THE FOLKS
WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE TO THIS
TYPE OF CHEMICAL ARE- OUR MEN
AND WOMEN. WHO ARE. FIVE YEAH
THE EYES IT IS FAR ARE ENDING
RISK OF DEVELOPING HEALTH
PROBLEMS- AND WE CERTAINLY SEE
THAT ELEVATED LEVELS OF P. FIVE
CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED
IN THE BODIES OF FIREFIGHTERS
PUTTING EVEN GREATER RISK OF
HARM INCLUDE. FIVE THERE'S BEEN-VERY LITTLE MOVEMENT ON IN THIS
AREA HERE INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA
I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THIS FOR
QUITE SOME TIME AND WE REALLY
DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE A MOVE ON
THIS UNTIL WE UNTIL OUR FRIENDS
IN THE FIRE FIGHTING COMMUNITY
FELT COMFORTABLE ULTIMATELY SO
MUCH OF THIS HAS TO DO WITH
PROTECT THEM BUT OUR FRIENDS
THE FIREFIGHT THE WORK CONSISTS
POLICE INITIALLY BRIDGE THAT
FOUR YEARS AGO ABOUT DOING SOME
WORK IN THIS AREA THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE. TOUGH COMFORTABLE.
WE WERE TO MOVE FOR ON A BILL
LIKE THIS THERE WOULD BE
ALTERNATIVES OUT THERE THAT
WOULD BE BECAUSE THEY
ULTIMATELY CARE ABOUT FIGHTING
FIRES THEY CARE ABOUT THEIR
MEMBERS- HEALTH OF COURSE
WANTED 2% BUT YOU KNOW THE
PROBLEMS CAUSED BY PETE ARE
LONG TERM THE PROBLEM IS BY NOT
HOW GOOD IT. THERE IS A- I CAN
IMAGINE THAT ARE FOR THE FIRE
pCOMFORTABLE THAT I ANY MOVEMENT
IN THIS AREA WOULD NOT HINDER
THEIR ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY
FIGHT FIRES THAT PROVIDE AN
IMMEDIATE RISK TO THEIR LIVES
AND HEALTH AND OF COURSE TO
THOSE OF OUR COMMUNITIES BUT-
BUT THE THING. THAT OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS AND REALLY GOOD
ALTERNATIVES HAVE EMERGED. HI
AND YOU NOW HAVE. YOU KNOW-
FAUCET WOULD COURSES OFTENTIMES
USING AIRPORTS AROUND THE WORLD
WELL- BEEN OF HEATHROW AIRPORT
AND HAS BEEN HAS TOTALLY PHASED
OUT P. FIGHTS ALL THE MAJOR
AUSTRALIAN PARTS. FEES UP TO US
FOR THE REASONS THAT WE'VE JUST
DISCUSSED OTHER YOU UPDATES
ALREADY ENACTED LAWS THAT
BANNED MOST USE THE P. FILES
CONTAINING FIREFIGHTING FOAM
AND THEY'VE MOVED TO
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE FAR
SAFER. AND SO BILL ADDRESSES
TWO SOURCES OF P. FIVE
CHEMICALS BY BANNING THE USE OF
FIRE FIGHTING FROM CONTAINING
P. FIVE SIX. SITUATE WORDS
FINALLY RIGHT THAT WAS AN ISSUE
THAT WAS RAISED IN WEEK WE WANT
TO END UP. CONFLICT FEDERAL LAW.
HE'S IN THIS AREA YOU TO DRESS
OPPOSITION. WE RECENTLY AMENDED
THE BILL TO PERMIT THE USE OF
P. FOSS FIREFIGHTING PHONE
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THERE WAS AN ISSUE.
THAT COME UP WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE GIVE THEM A LONG.
A RUN TIME. TO TRANSITION. I
HAD A CHEMICAL PLANTS FUEL
STORAGE AND DISTRIBUTION FOR.
AN OIL REFINERY SO WE WE'VE
PROVIDED SOME FLEXIBILITY- FOR
LARGE ATMOSPHERIC STORAGE
TANKS- YOU KNOW WHO MAY HAVE
FIRES AND IN THOSE AREAS WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING TO JEOPARDIZE. THE
ABILITY OF WRITERS IN THOSE
FACILITIES TO FIGHT FIRES. NOW
I. JUST TALKED TO CENTER DOLLAR
THE OPPOSITION COALITION SINCE.
CUSTOMER OFFICE YES YESTERDAY.
WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE TAKEN A
PRELIMINARY- LOOK AT THEM BUT I
WILL YOU KNOW IS A BLAST IN A
REQUEST. WE ARE. ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THEM- YOU KNOW WE- WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO- GET TO
SITUATION WHERE SIGNIFICANT
COSTS. ARE ADDED TO THE BILL
GIVEN THE CURRENT OUT OF IT
FINANCIAL CRISIS THAT IS
IMPACTING THE STATE BUT
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO TALK I'M A-
VACATIONS BILL TO DROP IN THE
CAN. THE BEEN RAISED FOLKS FOR
WAS BY OTHERS AS LONG AS IT
DOES. HARM MARK GOAL HERE WHICH
IS TO ENSURE THAT- THAT WE
PROTECT PEOPLE'S HEALTH- BUT
BUT CERTAINLY- THE A TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR.
FLEXIBILITY WHEN THEY'RE EVEN
WHEN THERE IS IN A STRONG-
ALTERNATIVE- TYPIFIES YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION WORK WITH
THEM AND SEE IF WE CAN COME UP
WITH SOME. MUTUALLY AGREEABLE
LANGUAGE. AND AS I CONTINUE TO
REITERATE OUR FRIENDS IN THE
FAR FIND COMMUNITY. WE KNOW
WOULD NOT BE AS INVOLVED IN
HELPING TO PASS THIS BILL. IF
THEY DIDN'T FEEL AS THOUGH IT
WAS BOTH IMPORTANT FOR THEIR
OWN HEALTH BUT ALSO FOR FIRE
FIGHTING. AND SO THE LAST THING
WE WANT TO DO IS DO ANYTHING
THE HANDER- OUR OUR FIRE
THERE'S ABILITY TO FIGHT FIRES
FIVE YOU RIGHT NOW. HI TODAY WE
THE P. FIVE ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASED RISK OF ASTHMA IMMUNE
SYSTEM DYSFUNCTION AND KIDNEY
AND LIVER DISEASE THESE ARE
SERIOUS UNDERLYING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS THAT ARE ALSO TOP OF
MIND RIGHT NOW THESE DAYS GIVEN
THAT THEIR- YOU KNOW THAT THEY
CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN FOUND TO
CONTRIBUTE TO HIGHER RISK
SEVERE ASSERTED ASSOCIATE
COVERT. ADDITIONALLY IT'S FOUND
THE P. FAST CAN REDUCE ANTIBODY
RESPONSES TO VACCINES. AND
THAT'SCERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WERE YOU KNOW IS OF CONCERN-
GIVEN THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW
OUR RETURN TO NORMALCY RIGHT
NOW IS IT SEEMS TO HAVE JOHN.
THE DEVELOPMENT- AND WIDESPREAD
DISTRIBUTION AND USE OF A OF AN
EFFECTIVE COVER NINETEEN
VACCINES SO- IT'S OUR FEELING
THAT THE TIME IS CALM FOR US TO
STEP UP PROTECT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN OUR ENVIRONMENT
COMMUNITIES. FROM THIS
UNNECESSARY SOURCE OF P. FOSS
EXPOSURE AND WITH ME ON THE
LINE I REPRESENTING OUR
FIREFIGHTERS IS THERE AND WHEN
HE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FIREFIGHTER HE'S CONTEST.
SUPPORT I DEREK'S TESTIMONY.
OUT WORK WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
DOCTOR AND- THAT- A VERY
ACCOMPLISHED CHEMIST. WHO'S
ALSO STAFF SCIENTISTS AT THE
NATIONAL RESOURCES DEFENSE-COUNCIL PAUL EXPLAINED TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARING TO
TECHNICAL CONSIDERATIONS IN THE
NEW CLEANING PROTOCOLS.
COMMITTEES WILL INSTITUTED A
TIME LIMIT ON TESTIMONY SO
ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE WILL ONLY
BE PERMITTED THE TOTAL THREE
MINUTES. ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MISS LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO ANY AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MATTER. FIRST
WITNESS. HEADS THE TIME VALUE
LIGHT. A GERMAN ONLY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME A MOMENT TO SPEAK
EXPORTERS SB TEN FORTY FOUR. MY
NAME IS JACQUELYN WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIREFIGHTERS
LOCAL TEN FOURTEEN. QUITE OLD
MASTER'S DEGREE IN CHEMISTRY
AND I'M IN THE FINAL YEAR OF MY
PHD STUDIES WHERE MY RESEARCH
EXAMINES HOW CHEMICALS
ACCOUNTED BY FIREFIGHTERS
CALLED DNA DAMAGE. I ALSO LOVE
MY BROTHER TO CANCER WHEN HE
WAS JUST THIRTY THREE YEARS OLD.
THE PUBLIC IS WELL AWARE THAT
USE FIREFIGHTERS BUT OUR LIVES
ON THE LINE DALY. FACING THE
DANGERS OF FIREFIGHTING BECAUSE
THAT'S OUR DUTY. UNLESS YOU'RE
NOT DANGER THAT WE FACE. THE
TELEVISION LEVELS OF CANCER IN
THE FIRES. NUMEROUS STUDIES
HAVE FOUND AN OCCUPATION THANK
TO DOUBLE CANCERS AMONG
FIREFIGHTERS. ANSWERS ONE. THAT
I WANT TO WORK. ELEVATOR LEVELS
OF CANCER EXPOSURE TO COST IN A
ARE SUCH THE INTERNET AGING FOR
RESEARCH ON CANCER. ACTUALLY
CLASS FIREFIGHTING ACOSTA
CARCINOGENIC OCCUPATION. THE
BEST SCIENTIFIC MINDS IN THE
WORLD SUSPECT BUT OUR LINE OF
WORK CAUSES CANCER. MANY CRAFTY
FIRE FIGHTING FOAMS AND EIGHTY
FIVE CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN LINKED
TO SEVERAL CANCER. AND A
VARIETY OF OTHER HEALTH
PROBLEMS. THE MORE RESEARCH ON
THEIR PART LEADING DP EQUIPMENT
WHICH WE THE WHY DID OUR JOBS.
YOU CAN TRAIN PEOPLE CAMELS.
CAMPBELL'S AFFECT NOT ONLY FIRE.
BUT EVERY MEMBER OF EVERY
COMMUNITY THAT WE SERVE. WE
FIREFIGHTERS BOYS BUT OUR DUTY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC FIRST.
EDUCATION WERE REPEATEDLY
EXPOSED TO CONDITION INCREASE
OUR RISK OF BEING DIAGNOSED
WITH CANCER ONE DAY. AS A
RESULT WE NEED TO MAKE A QUIP
IN OUR BATTLE AGAINST CANCER IN
THE PARK SERVICE BY MINIMIZING
ARE EXPOSED TO CARCINOGENS
WHEREVER POSSIBLE. MEETING
REDUCING EXPOSURE ACOSTA
MICHAEL'S IN FIRE FIGHTING
FOAMS AN INCREASE IN AWARENESS
ABOUT. I'M BECAUSE IN OUR DEAR
UP TO MAKE UP SOME OF THAT
GROUND. SO WHAT WE IN THE FIRE
SERVICE- WE STAND READY TO HELP
THOSE IN NEED THIS IS WHERE WE
NEED YOUR HELP IN OUR EFFORTS
TO STOP CANCERS THAT EVENTUALLY
LEAD MANY OF OUR FAMILIES
WITHOUT MOTHERS OR FATHERS.
SONS DAUGHTERS. REASON THAT WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT SB TEN
FORTY FOUR TODAY. THANK YOU
NEXT NEXT WITNESS ON THE LINE.
SUPPORT A GOOD AFTERNOON HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME AS I CAN. GO AHEAD
A GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY MY NAME IS ANNA READ AND-
I AM NOT. FIND ANOTHER DOCTOR
DEGREE IN DEVELOPMENTAL BIOLOGY
FROM UC SAN FRANCISCO.
SCIENTISTS AT THIRTY THE BODIES
IN HOW ON OF TOXIC YOU'RE
TALKING. INCLUDED THAT PIZZA
OTHER CLASSICAL IN BERMAN SOLD
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT.
EXTREMELY CONSISTENT THEY CAN
BUILD UP IN OUR BODIES AND OUR
ASSOCIATED WITH A WIDE WIDE
ARRAY OF HARMFUL HELP PUTTING
CANCER INTERCEDED FUNCTION
PERSONAL MENTAL HEALTH EFFECTS.
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS AND OTHERS.
ARE CONCLUDED THAT PEOPLE ARE
CUTTING FROM SHOULD BE PHASED
OUT AND IT'S A FOR A
ALTERNATIVES ARE AVAILABLE.
VIABLE AND I'M GOING. FOR
EXAMPLE DURING FREE PHONES HAVE
BEEN USED SUCCESSFULLY IN
AIRCRAFT FIRED A LARGE DANISH
QUIRK FIRE INVOLVING CALMLY ON
FERTILIZERS AND CHEMICAL
FACTORY IN MELBOURNE IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY OF AUSTRALIA
TRANSITION AWAY FROM. HOME YOUR
SOURCE OF ASIAN GET THEIR
SYNCHRO. AVAILABLE TO. SB TEN
FORTY FOUR WILL ANY UNNECESSARY
USE OF PEOPLE OFTEN. FROM AND
PROTECT OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES FROM THE TALK
TO CORRECT A CHEMICAL THANK YOU
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW LET'S
HEAR TESTIMONY FROM WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY. FORTY TWO
OR THREE. NINE ME. IN WITNESSES.
IN ROOM TWO. ZERO FOUR ZERO NOT
SEEING ANY THERE IN SUPPORT OF
A- SB TEN FORTY FOUR- MELTS
MOVED TO WITNESSES WILLING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
MODERATE. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. SB. TEN
FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT SB TEN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
INTO SUPPORT SB TEN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
CHAIRMAN. AT THIS MOMENT WE
HAVE NO ONE TO ANOTHER OKAY
LET'S GO TO THE WITNESSES. OKAY
YES FOR MORE TO LOOK FOR MORE
TIMES IF ANYBODY'S WAITING. YES
SIR WHAT IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT
SB TEN FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT. THE
TERM. THIS.
TRAIN ONLINE TO
SHE'S DOUBLE CHECKING HER
SCREEN.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
ONLINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. P. TEN
FORTY FOUR. WE DO HAVE MINE ONE
ELEVEN SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF SB
TEN FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER ONE.
NINE ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MEGAN TO WORK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WE ARE PROUD COAST
I'M THIRDS. STOLEN LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MODERATE MIX WITH THIS.
NINE ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS KATHY VIA
TELL ON BEHALF OF METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. NINE ONE SIX THREE
FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
DIVIDEND YIELD BLACK WHITE MALE
WITH A CALIFORNIA MINUTES WILL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. ONE HUNDRED. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- RICHARD BILL
GETS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES CORD THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU ON THE
OTHER CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
SHIPPED TEMPLE AND NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL IN PORT THANK
YOU. MY ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ACROSS
THE COUNTRY FIRST AT THE
COMPOUND BOW BUT YOUR REGISTRY
THE COURT ON BEHALF OF BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNER. THE
WORKING GROUP ALL OF THE CO
SPONSORS ON THE- ADDITION TO
THE CALIFORNIA HELPING L. ONE
COLLABORATIVE CALIFORNIA LEGAL
CONSERVATION VOTERS. TO HELP
HER DAUGHTER FOR ENVIRONMENT A
WHOLE. BUT WILDLIFE COMMITTEE
WATER CENTER AND I'M OF OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THANK
YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
IT. SB TEN FORTY FOUR PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ONE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREA
VENTURA I AM- WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND I HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
ASKED TO READ. THIRTY THREE
NAMES OF PETITIONS THERE IN
SUPPORT SO I WILL DO THAT
QUICKLY- SOME HAVE BEEN NAMED
CLEAN WATER ACTION BEING ONE OF
THAT BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN ACTUALLY.
CANCEL WILL CO SPONSOR.
CALIFORNIA FIFTIES SANITATION
AGING. WORK LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT. KOBE
KEEPER WOMEN'S VOICES FOR THE
BREAST CANCER ACTION TO THE
PUBLIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
OVERSIGHT CALIFORNIA COULD
KEEP- ALLIANCE. THE STATE
COALITION THE NATIONAL ACTION
COUNCIL THE GREEN SCIENCE
POLICY INSTITUTE THE CALIFORNIA
HELPING NAIL SALON
COLLABORATIVE. COMMITTEE ON
COMMUNITY CENTER'S LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
ACCOUNTABILITY SAVE OUR SHORES
THE PLASTIC POOL- POLLUTION
COALITION THE CENTER FOR
OCEANIC AWARENESS RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION. THE FIVE DRYERS
INSTITUTE SEVENTH GENERATION
ADVISORS TO HELP HER. FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION ON
CALIFORNIA. WHAT CALIFORNIA
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE CENTER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. CHOI
ALREADY AN ENVIRONMENTAL
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS HOLY WATER
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY CHAPTER
OF FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
ENVIRONMENTAL ALLIANCE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE OKAY NOW
WE FOR FROM THE SUPPORTERS NOW
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION I
SEE NO ONE HERE IN ROOM. KING
OVER ROOM FOR. TWO ZERO FOUR
ZERO I SEE NO WITNESSES THERE
MODERATOR I WOULD PLEASE WOULD
YOU PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB TEN FORTY FOUR.
WELCOME AND JUST MISTER TEARS
MY UNDERSECRETARY WE'VE GOT
WE'VE GOT TO. TWO TWO PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THOSE
ARE. WE ARE HERE ON THE LIST
THAT WE READ TIM STICK FROM THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
MARGOT PARKS FROM WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM SO THEY'LL
FIND ME OKAY MODERATE CAN WE
PLEASE ACCEPT HIM GESICHT. WITH
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
AND MARCO PARKS WITH THE
WHISPER. THE CASE THE OF THE
DEAL HAVE THREE MINUTES TEST.
TESTIFIED DIVIDED ISSUE LIKE
HOW PLEASE PROCEED. THE CHEST
X. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
A COMMITTEE CAN SHOW SICK- WITH
THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. WE COME IN
WRITTEN OUR LETTER TO THE WE
AND ON A NUMBER OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL. CERTAINLY SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE
UNINTENTIONAL RELEASE OF PEOPLE
OF CHEMISTRIES. PROVIDED BY THE
GOVERNMENT IN THE ENVIRONMENT
AND I THINK OUR EXPERIENCE HAS
SHOWN THAT THE LEGACY
CONTAMINATION FROM THE STONE
HAS. MADE LARGELY ATTRIBUTED TO
PAST PRACTICES OF UNCONTROLLED-
DISCHARGED DURING TRAINING. AND
TESTING IT CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THE- ASIANS ARE. IN THE OF
THESE UP FOR THESE TYPES OF.
THAT WOULD BE CONCERT WITH
OTHER US IN THE PAST. THE SPACE.
BUT WE DO HAVE EARNS THOUGH
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY FORTY
EIGHT- MISS PARKS WILL BE ABLE
TO LIVE GREAT ON THAT IN HER
TESTIMONY BUT- TO SEE. IN THE
BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR.
ONGOING PROCESS TO UTILIZE
THESE PHONES UP BEYOND THE
TWENTY TWENTY FORTY EIGHT-
OVERSEEN BY THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL AGAIN THIS WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATURE
ALSO BEEN PASSED. IN OTHER
STATES. AND RESEARCH IN
OCCURRING FULL TOWARD FREE
PHONES WE JUST NOT BELIEVE THAT
THE TWENTY TWENTY FORTY IT IS A
REALISTIC TIME FRAME SO- I KNOW
MISTER MISS SCHUBERT- EXPERT ON
THIS TOPIC HE IS IN THE PUBLIC
KEY LINE- YOU CAN BE THEY'LL-
TECHNICAL QUESTION. BUT THIS
TIME DOES THAT LESSEN THANK YOU
FOR GOODNESS PARKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK CARD HAPPEN
WESTERN BUT FOR IF THEY- I'M
ONE I THINK THAT SENATOR HEAD
OPENING COMMENTS WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING. TO WORK
WITH YOU IT ISSUE AND WE LIKE
START BREAKING THE WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE ALL AND FONG AND
THAT BIRTHDAY CAKE TO KEEP DOWN
WE AS MR SACK EXCEPT THE COURT
BANNED ME IN TRAINING. I THANK
ARE IN TOP I NEED THAT FIRE
CURTAIN ALL THAT WE HAVE THE-
FOR THE FIGHT THE FIRE. AND.
SENATE REGGAE ON ACTING. WHILE
MUCH PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
WITH QUARRY THREE FOUND THAT
AT. THAT AT THAT POINT OUR
COMPANIES BELIEVE THERE'S
LIMITATIONS AND ARE UNWILLING
TO ACCEPT A SITUATION IN WHICH
THEY ARE UNABLE TO ADEQUATELY
CONTROL FIRE. BECAUSE THE BAND
NEEDS THE NECESSARY IMPROVE AND
FIRE FIGHTING TOOL. MUCH OF
DEBATE ABOUT POURING GREAT FUN.
WILL AFTER GET AND PERFORM FOR
THE MAJORITY OF CLASS BE FIRED.
AS YOU ADD CHLORINATED FOUND.
EVEN IF THE GREEN ON THE TIME
LINE YOU CAN'T IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE ACCEPT THE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR BAND OUTLINED. FOR
THE SAFETY OF OUR EMPLOYEES ARE
TRYING TO COMMUNITIES HAVE THE
ABILITY YOU WARNING IT FOUND
AND HOW MUCH OF TIME THEN
EQUALLY EFFECTIVE PHONE IS
AVAILABLE. BUT THE SCOPE AND
SCALE OF CALIFORNIA OPERATIONS.
I IN THAT MAIN WE LIKE TO THINK
THAT THE NINE MEANT THAT THE
AUTHOR I REFERENCE IN THAT. GET
A WELL THAT'LL- UP FOR THE
CONTINUED. THE PRODUCT. ON
EFFORT. IS OR I. CAN ABLE TO.
DEMONSTRATE THAT. AND
DEMONSTRATE THEIR TRANSITION TO
AN- ALTERNATE AT. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
APPROACH THAT WILL ENSURE
CONTINUED SAFETY OF OUR
EMPLOYEES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING I HAD TO MAKE EIGHT.
TRANSACTION AND AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING OFF THEIR ON
SCREEN YEAH THANK YOU
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
OPEN LINES IN CALL THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
A ROW NOW. FOR MORE LIMITED AND
THEN. LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY CARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OUT OF ROUGHLY I WOULD
LIKE OUTLINED MY COMMENTS WITH
THE TO ME WITNESSES WE- WE'RE
HAVING OPPOSE UNLIKE THE MINUTE
THE MISSION. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YEAH
THANK YOU. X. LINE ONE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO KAREN SENATOR THIS
IS MIGHTY DANCES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE ARE
ALSO HAVING OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED PETITION AND ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE AMERICAN-CHEMISTRY. COUNCIL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. TAX THANK YOU IN
LINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MAKES YOU
BURKE REPRESENTING THE
FIREFIGHTING FORM COALITION
WORKS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AS IT'S CURRENTLY
WRITTEN THANK YOU. X. ANOTHER
TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN THOUGH IT
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE MODERN ONE
WE PLEASE CHECK THE OPEN LINES
AGAIN TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
INDIVIDUAL WISHING TO TESTIFY
AGAINST S. P. TEN FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN. BEFORE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANTED CUED UP VERY
GOOD WE WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE MEMBERS CENTRE DOLLY
EUROPE I RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I ACTUALLY AM
GOING TO BE PITCHING FOR
SENATOR BATES WHO I BELIEVE I
COULDN'T GET BACK TO THIS TIME
ASKS QUESTIONS FOR IT I MAY.
CAN YOU GIVE. FOR ME TO WORK
CAN YOU GIVE US EXAMPLES OF
FIRES- SITUATIONS WHERE P. FOSS
PHONE ARE STILL NECESSARY IN
WHY A BLANKET PROHIBITION MAY
NOT BE APPROPRIATE THAT'S THE I
HAVE ONE MORE AFTER THAT. OKAY.
HE SAID THAT I ASSUME YOU'RE
ASKING FOR ASK ME UP OPPOSITION
YEAH HE'S ON THE I THINK HE'S
ONLINE MISTER SAYS SICK. BEST
TECH IS MAKING. ITS FOR MITCH
HUBERT IS WHAT SHE HAS HERE
THAT SHE SENT ME AN EMAIL.
MATCH. THEIR WORK OUT HE CAN
CAN SHIP THE CARE AYE MR HE
WORKS ON THE PUBLIC KEY LIME
PIE I DON'T KNOW HOW TO GET HIM
BACK. THE FEELING IS. WELL
MISTER DISH AS A KID YOU. AFTER
THE COULD YOU ANSWER THAT
QUESTION ABOUT THAT YEAH. YEAH
THANK YOU CENTER SO YOU KNOW
THERE ARE THERE ARE CERTAIN
CERTAIN FLAMMABLE LIQUIDS- THAT.
THESE PEOPLE OF CHEMISTRY WE
WOULD BE NECESSARY AND I THINK
IT BOILS DOWN TO NOT ONLY ONLY
THE TYPE OF THE LIQUID BUYERS
BUT THE SETTING IN WHICH THOSE
THOSE. FUEL MAY BE. MAYBE YOU
DO SO- I WOULD I WOULD HAVE TO
DEFER TO MR HUBER WEEKLY A
FOLLOW UP ON THAT WITH WITH A
COMMITTEE ON SOME SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES- AND LISTENS PARK HAS
SOME- SOON TO CYNICAL OR-
ISSUES- THAT. THAT YOU. SHED
SOME LIGHT ON. WANT TO FOLLOW
UP QUESTION THEN MAYBE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ANALYSIS
INCLUDE COMMENT THAT ACCORDING
TO THE INTERNATIONAL POLLUTANT
ELIMINATION NETWORK I. P. E. N.
EXPERT PANEL REPORT FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. FLORIAN
FREE PASTA FORWARD FOR. PHONES
ARE AVAILABLE CERTIFIED IN
EFFECT FOR ALL FIREFIGHTING
APPLICATIONS ARE YOU WHERE THE
REPORT AND DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT STATEMENT. FOR
THE COLLISION DESPERATE IS FOR
TIM. MORE MARGIE HADER DAILY
I'M NOT- I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
THAT SPECIFIC THE IN DEPTH OF
THAT REPORT- I KNOW MISTER
HUBERT IS FOR SATURDAY
PERMEABLE TO GET HIM BACK ON
THE LINE- THIS IS NOT WE CAN.
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON THAT.
SEVEN ON PAGE NINE OF THE STAFF
REPORT. REFERENCE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ASKED SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOUR
BATES- BUT I DO HAVE A COMMON
MY OWN I WOULD I'M GONNA BE
LAYING OFF THE BILL I LIKE BILL
I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT DRESS
JUST ONE OF YOUR THAT. YOU KNOW
THERE'S- CALL WHEN WE HAVE MTBE
WHICH MADE OUR WHICH WAS A
GASOLINE ADDITIVE THAT HELP
THEIR AIR QUALITY BUT ALSO
CONTAMINATE OUR GROUND WATER
THE SAME TIME THIS COMPANY TOOK
FOREVER TO GET THAT. SO I'M
EXCITED BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T PUT OUR FIREFIGHTERS.
IN A POSITION WHERE. YOU KNOW
WE'RE SAVING THEM BUT WE'RE NOT
BUT THE KID TO THE WHEN THE
FIRES BURNING THEY'RE ALL KINDS
OF CONTAMINANTS THAT IT IF YOU
DON'T GET THE FIRE UNDER PROPER
TIME CAPSULE. THE FIREFIGHTERS
AS WELL AS A FIREMAN- SO I'LL
BE LOOKING AT THOSE THE MEMBERS
THAT THEY ASKED ABOUT LAST
NIGHT WHICH I KNOW THAT YOU
WILL TAKE A LOOK AT TWO AND
THEN EVERY RESERVE FOR MY VOTE
FOR THE POOR LATER MAYBE.
PRESIDENT CAUGHT THAT WE CAN
GET THE THANKS FOR THANK YOU.
NOT IN ANY OTHER COMMENT
SUPPORT OUR QUESTIONS BUT
MEMBERS TENDER YOU MAY CLOSE NO
JUST APPRECIATE THE FOB I'M IN
MY COLLEAGUE IN NINETY AYE I
CERTAINLY. TO A SPOT WHERE YOU
WOULD FEEL. ABOUT COME ON
BECAUSE I MEAN ULTIMATELY THIS
IS ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
FIREFIGHTERS PROTECTING. OUR
WATER AND- YOU KNOW PROTECT OUR
FIRE INVOLVED WITH A LOT. YOU
SURE THEY DON'T GET BUT ALSO. I
NEED. I'M A THE RIGHT THE FIRES
SO I WHY THEY SAY I MASS
COMMITTED TAKING A LONG HARD
LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS WERE
BROUGHT TO US TODAY AND SING
DUE TO PRESS THE OR OPPOSITION
CONCERNS- WERE WERE VERY GOOD
TO WORK IN THE OPPOSITION AB OR
ALSO AND WE'RE VERY COMMITTED
TO PROTECTING PATTERSON AREN'T
AND SO THAT'S WHAT HERE IN. I
WITH. EXCELLENT CENTER CENTER
MOTION YOU MAY THAN OR MOTION
BY SENATE MCGUIRE THE ROLE.
PLEASE NINE YOU'RE MY- I AM PER
FOR TEN FORTY FOUR BY SO OUT.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE SO OF
COMMITTEE ALLEN HI ALLEN AYE.
DOLLY HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE
ALL RIGHT MCGUIRE AYE WHY
CASKEY HI WE'LL KEEP THAT
MATTER ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND I'LL RETURN TO
CAVELL BACK TO THE CHAIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH ALRIGHT WELL IF IT
DOES TAKE A APPRECIATE THAT
MEMBERS AND LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ITEM ITEM. THIS A
IS DODD BILL SB NINE AND I'LL
UNDERSTAND SENT WHO YOU'RE
AMENDMENTS WERE BRINGING ON AS
A JOINT CO AUTHOR A MEASURE
GOING UP THERE OKAY OUT
PRESENTING PLEASE WELL BELOW
WELCOME YOU TO THE BEST. HERE
ASSN OR DOT TO PRESENT SB
NINETY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE AND BY
THE WAY. I JUST WANT TO JUST
JUST FOR FOLKS TO KNOW BECAUSE
WE WILL JUST TO GET SOME
CLARITY ON THIS THIS IS AT THE
FIRST OF TWO BACK UP GENERATOR
BILLS THAT WE HAVE. COMMITTEE
TODAY I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF DISCUSSION ON THE BILLS- I
BELIEVE IT YOU KNOW WE WILL
CONTINUE ON THE BUT I DO I
THINK THE AUTHORS AND STAPLES
FOR THEIR COMMITMENT TO FINDING
OUT FOR IT I. FIRST GONNA COME.
THANK BUT DOWN. SENATE NOT OF
CYNICAL IN AND CERTAINLY GOT
THE COMMITTEES AS WELL AND SOME
OF THE STATE. GREAT THANK BOB
PLEASE TO PUT TO TEN NINETY
NINE FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
ALONG WITH SENATOR GLAZER. SOME
TO EXPRESS MY SINCERE
APPRECIATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S EFFORTS TO
COLLABORATE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. I BELIEVE THE
PROPOSED- APPROACH IS
MEANINGFUL AND I WILL BE EXCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS. AS A WILDFIRE
SEASON GETS WORSE IN TERMS OF
TOTAL ACREAGE AND IMPACTS WE
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE REQUIRED
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTOR ON THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO IN
CORPORATE. PUBLIC POWER SAFETY
SHUT OFFS INTO THERE WALL FAR
MITIGATION PLANS TO REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF POWER LINES AND
ANY OTHER UTILITY EQUIPMENT.
THE FIRE BECAUSE CRITICAL
FACILITIES BE LIABLE POWER
PROVIDE CENTRAL SERVICES
DIFFERENT ELECTRICAL PROVIDER
TRIGGERS A P. S. P. S. THE
OPERATORS THESE FACILITIES
MUST. UTILIZE THEIR EMERGENCY
BACKUP GENERAL. I'D OFTEN.
SERVICE OUR STATE MEDICARE
DESTROY RESTRICTIONS FOR SOME
GENERATORS THAT WERE DOT TRY TO
THE WIDESPREAD USE OF PS PS IN
THESE- RESTRICTIONS DO NOT
PROVIDE ENOUGH TIME FOR PROPER
TESTING IN ADVANCE OF THE PS
PSP VI<c.cyan> OR OFF RUN TIME FOR</c>
SEX THE SEASONS. PS BUT- ALL
THIS COAST AIR MAY DISTRICT HAS
A RIGHT TIME RESTRICTION OF TWO
HUNDRED HOURS PER YEAR IN OUR
BASE LIMITATIONS FOR TESTING
AND MAINTENANCE OF THESE BACKUP
GENERATORS THE BILL WOULD
COMMITTEE. FOCUSES ON THE AIR
DISTRICTS EXISTING STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP A
STIPULATED ORDER OF ABATEMENT A
LEGALLY BINDING AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE NEIGHBOR DISTRICTS
OF FACILITY OPERATING A
STATIONARY. BUT POLLUTION
SOURCE. THERE THERE ARE
CONCERNS AT THIS BILL WAS
UNNECESSARY WELLNESS TRUE THAT
WE HAVE NOT BEEN WHITE THEIR OF
DOBBY WIDESPREAD FIGHT FOR
NOTICES OF VIOLATION RELATED TO
EXCEED AND SAYS THAT'S FAR. THE
TAX APPEAR YES OUR TOTALLY
PREDICTABLE IT'S FOOLISH TO
WAIT FOR DOES THROUGH THE STRAW.
THAT BEING SAID WE HAVE BEEN
COMMUNICATING WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THEIR CONCERNS
AND I'M COMMITTED TO FINDING A
PROCESS THEY CAN. PROVIDE
CERTAINTY. PLEX ABILITY FOR ALL
THE PARTICULARLY WE HAVE HAD A
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH HOSPITALS. TO WORK ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS CENTER GLAZER MY
JOINT AUTHORS ON THE PHONE TO
CALL. HI DEAD CHAIRMAN ALAN CAN
HEAR ME. THANKS AGAIN OKAY YEAH
VERY GOOD WELL I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND THE STAFF IS CENTERED
ABOUT AS INDICATED WORKING WITH
US ON THE BILL I CERTAINLY WANT
TO THANK SENATOR DOT FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. IT WAS THROUGH THE
WAY OF CENTER REQUIRE IN. RUBIO
THROUGH. THIS THAT THERE ARE
BILLS THAT WAS SUGGESTED THAT
ARE BILLS. BE COMBINED. I'D
BECOME A CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL
AND I THINK THOSE SENATORS FOR
THEIR- THEIR WORK AS WELL. THE
BILL THAT IS BEING ABSORBED
INTO SENATOR DODD'S BILL WAS MY
SB EIGHT OH TWO. AND THE
PURPOSE OF IT WAS TO TAKE UP. A
MAN BE GUILTY IN THE LAW.
WHETHER BILLS CAN RUN GENERAL.
OUR BLYTHE GENERAL DURING THESE
POP PAST. AT ELEVEN EIGHT THAT
THAT. I THAT REALLY WAS THE
GOAL IS A WAS CA. TO APPLY ONLY
B. LIMIT CIRCUMSTANCES
OBVIOUSLY CIRCUMSTANCES OUT OF
THE CONTROL OF THE HOSPITALS
BUT THESE PS PS COME STANCES
THEY'RE LIKE DISASTER BEING
CREATED WHEN YOU SHUT DOWN THE
POWER AND BY THE WAY. TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLS WERE
IMPACTED. BY FIRE AND POWER
OUTAGES THIS PAST YEAR TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ACCORDING TO
THE- THE- YEAH TOP THIS OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. SO THAT.
THAT IS A COMPLETE DISASTER FOR
A HEALTH CARE SYSTEM LIKE A
HOSPITAL SO WE WERE LOOKING FOR
A NEARLY CRAFT. ABILITY TO OPEN
EIGHT EIGHT UTILITIES SO THAT
THEY THEIR GENERATORS KNOWS
UNIQUE I'M STATUS WHICH WE ALL
HOPE DECLINE RIGHT HIS WERE
ASKING THE POWER COMPANIES TO
HARDEN THEIR GRID. AND TO HAVE
THESE SAYS A THESE ARE YES IT'S
AGAINST A DECREASE AND
HOPEFULLY BE ELIMINATED BUT- WE
HAVE NARROW. IN WHAT. PLAYER
THAT. SO I JOIN SENATOR DIED IN
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THE COMMITTEE HASPROPOSED BUT
I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT. WON THE
RACE IS THIS ISSUE OF RETIRING
NARRATORS. I KNOW THAT IS A
LONG STANDING. GOAL FOR THE AIR
DISTRICTS AND I APPRECIATED AND
I UNDERSTAND WHY- BUT THAT IT
THIS THIS. LEGISLATION BEFORE
YOU IS NOT PLACE TO HAVE THAT
DISAGREEMENT OR TO RESOLVE THAT
DISPUTE. POST AND DIED AND I
ARE WE TRIED TO. WORK IN A VERY
NARROW SPACE OF CRISES FOR
THESE. IMPORTANT FACILITIES
LIKE HOSPITALS AND WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS AND THAT
REALLY WAS THE NARROW GOAL OF
THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY I WANT TO THANK. CENTER
OUT IN FOR YOU AND YOUR STAFF
WORK BUT MY HOPE WOULD BE THAT
IS THAT THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
TODAY AND I HOPE THAT IT DOES.
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU TO. STAYING THE- RED.
OF THE BOOKS. THAT SEEKING IN
THIS BILL. AND AS YES THANK YOU
THE THANK YOU SENATOR AND YOU
KNOW I THINK PART OF SAYS YOU
KNOW WE'VE ALL BEEN AND
INVOLVED IN THIS INTENSE
CONVERSATION AS YOU KNOW- YOU
CAME IN WITH A BILL THAT WAS
VERY SPECIFIC TO. THE HOSPITAL
AND OF COURSE SENATE DOT HAD A
AT A DIFFERENT APPROACH AND SO-
WE'VE BEEN TRYING OUR BEST TO
FIND SOME CLARITY HERE WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. PERCENT RATIONS ARE UP TO
CONTINUE DURING. THIS PS BOB
WHILE TIMING. AS AS AB
IMPOSSIBLE I MEAN MY FIRST.
YEAH THE PEOPLE SHOULD BE ON
THE HOOK HERE'S PGD RIGHT I
MEAN THEY'RE THE ONES WHO WERE
SITTING DOWN THE POWER AND
INCLUDING SITUATIONS WERE VOTER
HAVEN'T USE GENERATOR SOME IT
WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET THEM ON THE HOOK. FOR THE
POLLUTION CAUSED BY THE
JAPANESE WHICH WHICH ARE
SERIOUS POLLUTANTS AND I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR ABOUT THAT
FROM POSITION. WHO IS ABOUT TO
COME UP SO NGUYEN ASTRI THAT
WELL I'M SORRY SO WE HAVE OTHER
FOLKS TO ONE OF MY VOICE
SUPPORT STRUCTURE. TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN NINETY
NINE TODAY OR DAVE PATTERSON
WITH THE LOS VIRGINIS.
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. AND A
PLACE IT HIDING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION. I'M ABOUT THAT
HIGH I'M IN A DEFERRED TO DAVE
CHECK THE CARS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SURE ALLEN DODD UNDER
GLAZER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
THE COURT ABOUT THE TEN NINETY
NINE MY NAME IS DAVE PETERSON
I'M THE GENERAL MANAGER OF
BURGEONING MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT WHERE WATER AND
WASTEWATER EIGHT. QUARTERED IN
CALABASAS. IT WAS ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO I IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF.
SEVEN THIRTY MORE. EFFORT
EXPERIENCED THE WALL BE. THAT'S
WHAT THROUGH THE SIR AREA OF MY
AGE OF THE AND THE COMMUNITY.
ULTIMATELY THAT FIRE BURN TWO
THIRDS OF OUR DISTRICT- AND
DESTROYED SIXTEEN HUNDRED
STRUCTURES. INCLUDING THE HOME
OF ONE OF THE LONGEST SERVING
DIRECTORS- ART. WILL BE FIRE
AND REALLY MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
LESSONS THAT WE LEARNED FROM
THAT FIRE OUR WHAT PROMPTED UP
TO APPROACH THE ANYWAY ON BILL
AND PUBLICLY. I THE BILL. A
LITTLE OF THE FIRE THAT WORKING
OUT THE FIRE BROKE OUT. NEAR
THE SENATE THE BALLOT THE LAB.
IT WAS A THURSDAY AFTERNOON AND
BY THE FOLLOWING MORNING ON
FRIDAY AT SIX AM THE FIRE HAD
JUMPED ONE A ONE THREE WAY AND
KNOCKED OUT POWER ALMOST
EVERYTHING IS. IN MY DISTRICT
SERVICE AREA AND THE CALL. A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SQUARE MILE
AREA. WE HAVE YOU. EXPERIENCED
BEING THAT WOULD THAT YOU MAY
THAT. AND PUT SO MANY COULD OUT
OF SERVICE AT THE TIME WE HAVE
BY THAT WILL COME INTO THE AREA
NOT FROM ACROSS THE REGION AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO PROTECT
OUR HOME. AND OUR NUMBER ONE.
LOCAL DURING THAT EVENT WHAT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
WATER FLOWING AND TO ENSURE
THAT THERE WAS NOT A SINGLE
FIREFIGHTER THAT CAME ACROSS
THE DRY FIRE EMERGENCY
GENERATORS. WERE THE KEY AND
MAKING OUT OFF THE BALL AND WE
WERE SUCCESSFUL BUT I WILL SAY
IT WOULD NOT WITHOUT INCIDENT.
WE ACTIVATED A COMBINATION OF
STATIONARY GENERATOR AND ALSO
DEPLOYED PORTABLE ONE OUT
THROUGHOUT OUR DISTRICT. WE ARE
GOING TO THE FIRE FRONT. WE
CALLED FOR MUTUAL AID AND WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO RECEIVE GENERATORS
FROM AS FAR AWAY AS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. OUR FIELD EMPLOYEES-
WE'RE WE'RE HEROES IN THE
RESPONSE AND THEY HAULED THAT
WE'RE TRAILER MOUNTED. OVER
MOUNTAIN ROAD WITH NEAR ZERO
VISIBILITY INTAKE BLACK SMOKE.
AND DEALT WITH DOWNED POWER
LINES THE BLOCKED THEIR WAY.
ONE EXPERIENCE WE HAD IS A
PORTABLE GENERATOR THAT WE HAD
RECEIVED FROM A NEARBY CITY BOB
TRAIL DURING THE FIRE AND IT
HAD ON FORGING NOT BEEN WELL
MAINTAINED. WE FOUND
REPLACEMENT FROM THE FRESNO
AREA BUT WE COULD NOT GET THAT
REPLACEMENT EMPLOYEE AND HOOKED
UP AND OPERATING BEFORE. WE
LOST CRITICAL WATER STORAGE AND
A PORTION OF OUR SYSTEM THAT WE
CALL THE I'M ALL. SUBSYSTEM
ABOUT THAT TIME WE ALSO HAD A
BRIDGE FAILURE OF MULHOLLAND
HIGHWAY I'M AN AVERAGE WHEN IT
FAILED IT KNOCKED OUT ONE OF
OUR KEEP WATER MAIN. THE
COMBINED EFFECT OF THOSE TWO
EVENTS YES WERE AUTHORIZED
WHICH ASK YOU TO WRAP IT UP IF
YOU IF YOU DON'T MIND. ALL
RIGHT AND WE GOT. WATER ORDER
THAT COULD HAVE IMPACTED OUR
ABILITY TO SERVE WATER IF IT
WITHIN YOUR MESS BOB THE
OPPONENT ABOUT THE TEN NINETY
NINE OKAY THE DEBATE SOLUTION
TO A PROBLEM I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THAT IS NOT THE CASE WE'VE
LIVED THROUGH. THE VERY. THAT
WE- WERE ABOUT HERE WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
COMMITTEE STAFF THAN YOURSELF
THAT SHARE. OUT TO FIND AN
ACCEPTABLE SOLUTION WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT AS WE GO FORWARD.
AND I THINK IF WE CAN WORK OUT
THE LANGUAGE THE ROUNDING THE
STIPULATED AGREEMENT WALL BEING
MIND OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
KEEPING UP WATER RATES ARE LOW.
ENOUGH FOR. SB TEN NINETY NINE
I THINK GO A LONG WAYS TO
ATTRACTING. CHALLENGE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR OKAY- OKAY OTHER
FOLKS TO ONE OF THE CITY VOICE
SUPPORT JUST DOWN. NO I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE HAD. YET DANIELLE
BUT QUITE WHAT CALIFORNIA
MINUTES BUT UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION- I KNOW THAT- I
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME BUTI
DID WANT TO. MAKE A COUPLE
POINTS- AS OF THE CLOSE BOND
THERE AND AT THE TEN NINETY
NINE IF THAT'S OKAY. OKAY I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. OKAY
THANK YOU ALL I'LL BE BRIEF- I
DEFINITELY DID WANTED THINK
SENATORS DIED AND GLAZER FOR
TAKING LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND- YOU CHAIR ALLEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THE STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE
EXTENSIVE WORK ON THE AMENDMENT.
WE DO BELIEVE AS- THE
AMENDMENTS ARE EIGHTY DEPARTURE
BROWN THE ORIGINAL APPROACH
THAT WE HAD WORKED ON WITH AND
WITH IT- BUT WE BELIEVE. IS
DIRECTLY BALANCE BY SETTING UP
A- NOT THAT IT IS DESIGNED TO
MEET BOTH THE OPERATOR OF THE
CRITICAL DISABILITY AND THE AIR
DISTRICT NEEDS- NOT SOMETHING
ONE WILL BE FORCED INTO THAT
THE THAT THE- GREEN MEANT THAT.
AND THAT THE TWO PARTIES WE
NEED TO COME TOGETHER ON AND ON
THE REPLACEMENT SCHEDULED
CONCERNED YOU KNOW ADD THERE'S
LANGUAGE IN THE AMENDMENT- THE
REPLACEMENT SCHEDULE
IMPORTANTLY WOULD NEED TO BE
TECHNICALLY ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE. AND THE CONSIDERING.
A GOOD THING GENERATORS WE
ROUNDERS ARE IMPORTANT. AND I
WILL ONLY I WANT TO READ THAT
WE ARE TO A SOLUTION THAT WORKS
FOR ALL PARTIES INVOLVED
INCLUDING THOSE THAT HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL IN PRINT
OR THE AMENDMENT. ACT TALK WITH
IF YOU HAVE CONCERNS INCLUDING
THE AIR DISTRICT REGARDING
POTENTIAL APPROACH IS BREAKING
EVEN BE TAKEN. MR PROCESS WILL
BE SURE KEEP THE MANY OF CRIED.
OUT OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS ENGINE
WITH THEIR- MANY OTHERS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
IPHONE. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO HAVE OTHER
FOLKS WHO WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL I KNOW WE DON'T
HAVE THEM HERE IN THE ROOM BUT-
THE FORTY. WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
OVER THERE ARE AMONG. MODERATOR
ANYWAY. ON THEIR SUPPORT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SUPPORT SB TEN NINETY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR- ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SUPPORT SB TEN NINETY NINE.
ONE ZERO. IN ONE MOMENT
CHAIRMAN. LINE ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
PRISCILLA KIDDER HERE ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN PROPANE GAS STATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
WITHOUT MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ANTHONY MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY WATER AGENCY IN MESA
WATER DISTRICT AND OR THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ADAM ROBIN WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SCHERING
SENATORS JANICE THE TA HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION IN THE
COURT THANK YOU. WITH LINE
NUMBER THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE NUMBER
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
THIRTY SEVEN. LINE ONE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE ONE
EIGHTY. THURMOND MEMBERS BERNIE
OROZCO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IN LINE ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS CHRISTY FOR A WITH
THREE VALUED MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE NINETEEN EVEN ONE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WELL I REALLY GO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALTRAIN
HOSPITALIZATION- WE'RE SORT OF
IN THE IN BETWEEN- EIGHT ON
THIS BILL- REALLY WANT TO THANK
SENATOR DODD ENGINER GLAZER FOR
THE LEAD THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE- WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE ON THE ALTAR
STAFF. FOR THE WORK- ON THIS
DAY AS RELATES JACKIE KENNEDY
NINE WE DO NOT HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION AT THE MOMENT- WE HAVE
EXPRESSED OUR CONCERNS
REGARDING SOME OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND IS OFFICE- HOWEVER WE ARE
FULLY COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALL THROUGH THE COMMITTEE-
AND. STOPS WORKING WORKABLE.
THAT CLEARLY BOB. I YOU CAN
ARGUE. YEAH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FIND ONE TWO ONE ONE EIGHT
ONE IS OPEN PLEASE CALL. MR AND
BASS LOCKED SO ON BEHALF OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY ONE PER LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER HERBERT THEIR BREAD ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
ON THE BILL YEAH BUT ONE OF THE
CONCERNS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION- WE
PENDING REVIEW OF THE AMENDMENT
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT ON OUR SMALL
THE HOSPITAL. A GREAT THIRD.
TIME YEAH. ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
REQUIRED. CAN YOU HEAR ME. MAN
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS KATHY
VEHICLE WITH THE METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND PRINT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE NEW
LANGUAGE AND PRINT. THEM AND
CREATE YOUR EFFORT THANK YOU.
THE TERM WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
COMING UP AT THE LAST MOMENT
ONE MOMENT SIR. LINE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOR MY NUMBER THIRTY
YEAR LINE IS ME IT'S A MUTED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ENTER MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JULIA HALL WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE WERE PREVIOUSLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE CURRENT THE BILL
AND FILL THE PRECLUSION TO THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THE PS
YEAH. WE DON'T HAVE A CURRENT
MISSION ON THE PODIUM AND
LOOKED IN THE LANGUAGE ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE CONCERNS
THAT THE PROPOSED APPROACH
RELATED. AGENCIES I THINK
YOU'RE NEED A FUNDS ARE NOT
ILLUSION. THE TERM AND THAT WAS
OUR LAST ONE. OKAY ONE LAST
FINAL CALL FOR ANYBODY WHO MAY
WILL BE INTERESTED IN
EXPRESSING THEIR SUPPORT. WITH
YES. OKAY LET'S NOT GO TO
OPPOSITION I KNOW WE'VE GOT
NGUYEN MASTERY FROM SOUTH
BECAUSE THEY KI<c.cyan> DE AND</c>
BRANDON I TO HATE CREWS FROM
CALIFORNIA CLOSE CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND
THEY'RE ON THE CO HOST
TELECONFERENCE LINE. HM NO WAY
NASRI AND- ON THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION. SB TEN NINETY NINE.
I DISTRICTS UNDERSTAND WELL THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF BACKUP
GENERATORS OPERATING DOING PS
PS OF AND OR ANY OTHER
EMERGENCIES PROVIDE NECESSARY
POWER. WE WOULD NEVER EXPECT OR
EVEN. PROVIDING YOU SENT
SERVICE. GO WITHOUT POWER DUE
TO ANY OF OUR REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS HAVE AN ESTABLISHED
TRACK RECORD TO ENSURE THE
LOCAL POWER REMAINS AVAILABLE
DURING EMERGENCIES AND TODAY
THE BILL SUPPORTERS HAVE NOT
IDENTIFIED A SINGLE INSTANCE OF
AN AIR DISTRICT SPENDING AT
CENTRAL SERVICE PROVIDERS FROM
OPERATING BACK OF GENERATED
ANALYZE YOU USE. IN RESPONSE
ACTUAL EMERGENCY. IT TO THE
TIME ALREADY THEY FOR USE OF
BACK GENERATORS EXEMPTIONS TO
THOSE LIMITS ARE GRANTED TO THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICT BERRIES
PROCESS WHICH IS STREAMLINING
CAN BE PURSUED TO THE
COMPLETION. THE MIDDLE OF FORMS
ALONE. DISTRICTS ARE FOCUSED ON
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS IT
WAS STILL TAKE THE GRANTING OF
RELIEF AND RELATED FEES ARE
OFTEN WAY. IN OUR LOCAL
PROJECTS ARE IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT POWER IS PROVIDED IN A WAY
THAT MINIMIZES THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACT OF EMISSIONS.
FROM THE OPERATION OF DIESEL
BACKUP GENERATORS. AND
IMPORTANT BECAUSE JUST WITHIN
THE SOUTH COAST THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF SUCH GENERATORS
THAT COULD BE AFFECTED BY THIS
BILL WITH SOME OF THOSE BEING
OVER FORTY YEARS OLD. ALL OF
THESE POTENTIAL TREATMENT. OUT
FOUR OKAY OF NITROGEN WHAT WE
CALLED DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER A POTENT CARCINOGEN THE
MANY OF THESE BACK UP
GENERATORS ARE NEW RESIDENTS IN
SCHOOL. FOR EXAMPLE FOR A PEER
TO PEER YES YES EVENT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN IN LA IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY WE CALCULATE
THE NEARLY SIX TONS OF KNOX
MISSIONS PER DAY WERE ADMITTED
MADE WE NEEDED. BY THE
GENERATED IN THE S. P. S.
AFFECTED AREA. DOES EMISSIONS
ARE HIGHER THAN AVERAGE DAILY
MISSION OF THE LARGEST FINALLY.
IN THE SOUTH COAST. SO IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THIS. PER OF CURRENT
RECORD ANSWER. WE NOW BUT THEN
WE TRIED TO REACH A LOCAL NON
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION TO THIS
ISSUE. HE OFFERED LOCAL RULE
CHANGES TO PROVIDE A REGULATORY
PATDRESS THE SPONSORS
EXPRESSED CONCERN. EVER THERE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE BILL AND WE STILL
POSIBILIDAD POSE COULD BE
AMENDED. WHICH INCLUDE TO
STIPULATE ORDER OF ABATEMENT
APPROACH. LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND I
THINK BANDITS UP NEXT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
READY FOR ME ALTHOUGH I HAD-
BRENDON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
PRESENTING THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS FROM ALL THIRTY FIVE
LOCAL AND DISTRICTS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MATTER
MEASURE I WILL MINOR COMMENTS
WITNESSED ASTRIUM OP ED. ONLY
ONE SURE THAT ESSENTIAL
SERVICES HAD BACK POWER SHOULD
BE A PS. AND OTHER EMERGING
EVENTS. THAT TODAY THE BILL ON
HAS NOT PROVIDE A SINGLE EGGS
OF AN AIR DISTRICTS A BACKUP
GENERATOR OPERATOR. READING AN
EMERGENCY OR SHUTTING ANYONE
DOWN WHILE OPERATING DURING AN
EMERGENCY WE BELIEVE THE
CURRENT LOCAL PROCESS WORKS
WELL. IN A STRUCTURED ADDRESS
EVEN ISSUES RAISED BY THE BILL
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THE
NECESSARY AND RETAIN OPPOSED
THANK YOU. OKAY SO THOSE ARE
TWO OF FORMAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO VOICE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL EITHER
HERE IN PERSON FORTY TWO A
THREE OUNCE ANYONE TWENTY
FORTY. MR ONE OF HER ON HOW THE
PHONE MATAMATA. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO VOTE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TEN NINETY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN A CAN OF
SB TEN NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. I MEAN. IN LINE
ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ERICA
CALIFORNIA WE HAD HAD AN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL ACTUALLY
BECAUSE THEY THINK THAT IT'LL
GENERATE TURNER. HORRIBLE
CONTRIBUTOR TO AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE RELIANCE ON
THE GENERATOR WORKING
CALIFORNIA AIR QUALITY CAL. WE
WELL AND ONE OF THE LANGUAGE OF
OR VIEW IT AND TAKE IT FOR
ALLEGED COMMITTEE WOULD BE DONE
IN THE LIKE THE BILL OKAY CAN
HAPPEN OR DIRECTION AND WE
DON'T MAKE SURE THAT WE DOING
AT WE TO MAKE THAT WE ARE
MOVING IN THE DIRECTION OF OUT.
OU LOOK AT. EACH CLICK. ON
MAYBE THAT'S AN OPTION THAT
FURTHER WITH ADDITIONAL SUCH AS
REQUIRING IS THAT THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY TAKEN BECAUSE THEM HELP
AND LEADING PEOPLE AFTER BUT
LIKE I WILL REVIEW THEM AND ONE
FRANK LOOKING FOR WORK YEAH
OFFICES AND THE CAN THE COURT
THANK YOU. SEVENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PERHAPS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION ALIGNING MY COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
SOUTH COAST AIR DISTRICT IN ON
YOUR POLLUTION. LOCATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND ONE ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HEARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MICHAEL THAT WITH THE
GRAY AND MAKE KAYLEE ON BEHALF
OF REPUBLIC SERVICES. WE ARE
OPPOSED. TO THE- TEN NINETY
NINE AND EXHIBITED A LETTER
OUTLINING OUR CONCERNS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THESE CONCERNS THANK YOU. AND
THAT WAS OUR LAST ONE. OKAY ANY
FINAL VOLKSWAGEN CALL FOR FOLKS
ONE RAISE CONCERNS. OKAY AND
OUT OF SB TEN NINETY NINE STARS
TURN. TO DO IS A MATTER
MODERATE JUST CONFIRMING WE
DON'T WE DON'T WE STILL DON'T
HAVE ANY NEW PEOPLE. CURRENT
ONLY. OKAY OKAY ALL RIGHT. SO
THE MATTER IS NOW BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE I MEAN LOOK I YOU
KNOW I THINK EVERYONE HEARD THE
TESTIMONY BOTH SIDES THIS IS A
SITUATION. YOU KNOW I THINK.
THAT WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
TOGETHER WITH THE AUTHORS AND
CLEARLY WE'VE GOTTEN A
SITUATION WHERE. YOU KNOW THE
TOP LEAST WE MEET AT THAT THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE RAISED CONCERNS
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO POINT TO
ANY EXAMPLE OF TIMES WHEN- WHEN
THEIR BOARDS HAVE A FIND.
AGENCIES OR HOSPITALS OR-
WATER- WATER DEPARTMENTS WATER
AGENCIES- FOR. POLLUTION
ASSOCIATED WITH THE USE OF
GENERATORS THAT WERE USED
DURING THE S. P. S. ADVANTAGE.
BE SORRY DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN-
I'M INTERESTED IN THE KIND OF
CONSTRAINTS THAT EVERYONE'S
UNDER WHEN THERE IS A P. S. P.
S. OF AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND.
THE YOU KNOW. THE ACT IS IN THE-
REYES AND I'M ALL THE FOOTWORK
WITHIN THESE ORGANS FOR IN
CERTAINTY I THINK THE GUY NO
PLACE. FIVE AND YOU HEARD THAT.
YOU KNOW YOUR PEOPLE JUST RAISE
EM AT THE GUN ON THE ON THE
BILL SIDE YOU KNOW BOB THEY
WANT TO AS EXPENSIVE AS BILLS
POSSIBLE ON THE AIR DISTRICTS
AYE THE BIG I THINK JUST OBJECT
TO THE GENERAL IDEA OF THE
BILL. BUT WE TEND TO A PLACE
WHERE I THINK WE'VE- THE-
PROVIDES BOTH SIDES WITH WITH
WHAT THEY NEED NOW THAT BEING
SAID I UNDERSTAND SOCIAL
CONCERNS OUT THERE ABOUT
HOSPITALS LASSEN WE WANT TO DO
IS HAVE. SPITTLE YEAH BE FEAR
FOR. OF FIVE STAYING BECAUSE
OF- OF CONCERNS OF. COMPLIANCE
THAT BEING SAID WE ALSO DON'T
WANT ANYONE TO USE THESE.
HIGHLY POLLUTING GENERATORS
ANYMORE THEY ACTUALLY NEED TO
BE. AND SO THAT'S AND THAT'S
REALLY WHERE WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO BREAK A BALANCE HERE. AND I
JUST. MY KIND OF. IT IS THE
THIRD OF YOU HAVE WITH SAID IT
WOULD HAVE IN IRAQ LITTLE TO
SIGN BAR WHEN I MADE MY CALL
ABOUT THE EARLIER AND GET YOU
CERTAINLY. THE WILD CARDS ARE
MUCH SEVERE. BEFORE AND THEY
CITY OF THIS IS THE FALL OF
CLIMATE N<c.cyan>CA ABOUT IT. I</c>
SAY. THAT CERTAINLY APPEARS
THAT TOWN THAT THE UTILITY DOWN
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVE
SOMEHOW FOUND A WAY. TO HAVE
MUCH MORE FORGET IT YES YES.
MUCH MORE G. OTHER. PS EVENTS
OF THE FAR FEWER PEOPLE ARE
GETTING THEIR POWER CUT OFF
AND- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
GOING TO BE INSTANCES WHERE WE
TO CUT PEOPLE'S POWER NO
PROVIDE CERTAINTY. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME HOW WE ALSO- YOU KNOW
ME. THIS IS THIS IS A VERY
TANGIBLE EXAMPLE. HOW THE LACK
OF INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT.
OF P. JEANNIE COMPARE TO THEIR
SISTER BROTHER I DOWN TO THE
GULF. REAL NOT ONLY HARMING
CONSUMERS BUT ALSO HARMING OUR
ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE-
UNFORTUNATELY THE MAIN
ALTERNATIVE OUT THERE AND I
THINK THE PERSON FROM THE
SIERRA CLUB SAID THIS PAST THE
MIDDLE. OUT THERE AND THE
PRINCE. THE ARTIST BECAUSE
GENERATORS ARE HIGHLY
POLLUTING- THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
THIS IS NOT GOOD ALTERNATIVE
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT
WHERE I MOVED TOWARD
ELECTRIFICATION. AND YET WE
WILL NEED A WE NEED. OUT WE
NEED TO HELP DEVELOP BETTER
WAYS OF ADDRESSING THE- HE HAD
USE OF POWER DURING. I THESE
WILDFIRES A WORK THAT ARE
ENFORCING TO CONTINUE TO BE A
NEW NORMAL AS CLIMATE CHANGE
GETS WORSE AS OUR DROUGHTS
CONTINUE TO. DEEPEN SO YOU KNOW
I THINK WE'VE WE'VE COME CLOSE
TO FINDING AN ELEGANT
COMPROMISE HERE I KNOW THIS
CONVERSATION'S GOING TO
CONTINUE THEIR STILL THERE'S A
LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS OBVIOUS YOU
OFFER. THEM ALL ON THE CALL I
DO WANT TO THANK MY STAFF FOR
ERIKA AND THEN GABRIELLE AND
OTHERS FROM OUR TEAM HAVE
REALLY BEEN WORKING HARD
CREDIT. THREAD THE NEEDLE HERE.
I'M NO ONE'S ENTIRELY HAPPY
WITH FOR THESE BILLS ARE YET
BUT I THINK GET PLACE WHERE YOU
CAN. AND WE CAN COME UP WITH
SOME REALLY GREAT PEOPLE
SOLUTIONS. THAT THE CURRENT
CORE PRINCIPLES THAT I'VE I'VE
TRIED TO ARTICULATE- SO THAT'S
ACTUALLY STEP PHILOSOPHY WITH
WHICH WE'VE BEEN APPROACHING
THIS. IS A IT AS I AM THAT'S.
BECAUSE OF PUTS ON THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. ON THIS TOPIC A
ABOUT IT I ABSOLUTE AGREE OUR
FRIENDS ZERO CLUB SAYS THE END
OF THE DAY WE HAVE TO MOVE TO
CALL WAY. OF GENERATING
INDEPENDENT POWER DURING THESE-KINDS OF INSISTED IN INCIDENCES
SO- WITHOUT A LOVE TO HEAR THE
THOUGHTS OF MY COLLEAGUE SAYS
AND WHAT CASKEY. I'M ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS I SEE IN
BOULDER IS FOR SUGGESTED- TERMS
AND CONDITIONS TO THE
LEGISLATION THAT WE HAVE FIVE.
MINUTES YOU KNOW THE RICH TO
THE RETIREMENT OF THESE
POLLUTING GENERATORS. WHAT TYPE
OF SHAPE IS THAT WOMAN.
LANGUAGE AND- ARE YOU ARE YOU
ACCEPTING IN CONCEPT IT'S THE
STAFF WELL. YES IT BE YOU HEARD
THERE WAS STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
OKAY WOULD WOULD OKAY WITH
THESE THESE AMENDMENTS AND WE
TOLD CHAIR YOU KNOW THAT WE
WERE OKAY OKAY WITH THE CHAIR
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY HEARING SOME
OF THE BIG BASS HOSPITALS AND
BARELY REPUBLIC. SERVICES THAT
FEEL LIKE. HERE WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE NOW. THESE
BUSINESSES ARE BEING REQUIRED
TO GET INTO A NEW AGREEMENT-
WITH REGARD TO A P. S. P. S.
THAT. YOU KNOW THAT NOBODY
DIABETES WHAT IT WHAT IT THE I
THINK THEY BELIEVE THAT THESE
AGREEMENTS SHOULD BE A MORE
HOLISTIC OVER. BUT IT IS USING
A GENERATOR IF THEY'VE GOT A
PROBLEM WITH DIESEL POLLUTANTS
WHICH WE DO AND I AGREE WITH
THE CHAIR IN HIS COMMENTS.
THOSE THOSE REGULATION SHOULD
BE COMING NOT NECESSARILY AS A
RESULT OF THE P. S. P. S. TYPE
OF SITUATION BETTER AS A RESULT
FOR IT NEED. HERE DISTRICT AND
I STE HE ALSO YES WORD WERE
TAKING THESE AMENDMENTS TODAY.
BUT WE'VE TALKED TO THE CHAIR
ABOUT HAVING FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS IS THIS THING YOU
KNOW MOVES ON TO THE PERHAPS
THE OTHER SIDE AND- WE WILL-
YEAH WORK WITH THE CHAIR ALL.
STEP OF THE WAY BECAUSE I MEAN
WE IT IT GETS INTO WERE USED
THE TERM ESSENTIAL FACILITIES
AND NOW WE HAVE CRITICAL
FACILITIES IN. I GUESS THAT
DEPENDS ON WHO. WHO WHO. I
BUSINESSES BEING AFFECTED YOU
KNOW A- BILL I KNOW MY TOWN OUR
WATERS TREATMENTS DISTRICT IS
GOT THEY'VE GOT THE TREATMENT
FACILITY THIS THERE AND THEN
THEY GOT A MINISTRY TO FILL.
BUILDING ONE OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BUILDING THESE
RUN A GENERATOR IF THERE'S A PS
PS RESIST THE POINT THAT. RIGHT
SO. BECAUSE YOUR CALL WHO ON
THEIR INTO THAT HE TO HAVE NAY
ON THEIR- DEFINITION FOR HEALTH
SIX THEIR YOUR YOUR- STEPHEN IF
SUPPORTERS INCLUDING GASOLINE
STATIONS AND GROCERY STORES
SWITCHER IF YOU'RE OUT OF GAS
THAT'S CRITICAL FACILITY I
DOUBT BUT- FOR THIS LIMITED
TIME DURING THE PSP AT. DO WE
WANT TO STAY WILL NOT THESE
THINGS SHUT DOWN AND YOU CAN'T
YOU CAN'T RUN YOUR FACILITY TO
SELL CIGARETTES WHERE IN
MINUTES THERE'S- GOING TO BE
VERY NARROW I THINK. ON WHO IS
A NUMBER FOR. YES AND WHO ARE
THE REST OF US MY FATHER IN LAW
INCLUDING WHO'S GOT ONE THESE
GENERATORS OR TURN IT ON I MEAN
IF WE KNOW PEOPLE ARE TRYING A
MONTH SO. I'M TO DO. SOMETHING
WORKED OUT BETWEEN OFFICE. THE
LOCAL THEIR DISTRICT YOU KNOW
SOMETHING ITS- SCHEDULE. IF WE
HAVE A TO BROADEN THE
DEFINITION OF WHAT IS A
CRITICAL FACILITY THAT COULD
OPEN IT UP SO. YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE THESE DIRTY.
GENERATORS THEY KNOW THEY'RE
GONNA QUIT SHORT MY DAY ONLY
TURN IT UP. THEIR THEIR
POLLUTANTS ARE EMISSIONS ARE
GOING TO BE. COUNTED AGAIN BY
THE LOCAL TEST SO I'M HOPING
FOR. I DID GO AHEAD WELL I
WOULD HOPE THAT THAT WE HAVE
REGULATIONS IN PLACE THAT
RETIRE THOSE. AT SOME SPECIFIED
PERIOD OF TIME THAT'S WHAT THE
AGREEMENT IS BENT. BUT FOR YES
THAT'S WHY I SHOULD. I SHOULD
ALL THE SAID SPEAK. ANOTHER
LEVEL OF BUREAUCRACY THAT. PUTS
FURTHER RESTRICTIONS ON- YET
COMPANIES BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING TO STAY IN BUSINESS I
WOULD SUGGEST COVERT NINETEEN
IN. SUCH AN IN PEOPLE BEING OUT
OF BUSINESS A LONG AS THEY ARE.
I DON'T THINK OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND BUSINESSES THE TO HAPPY
WITH US. IT THE PSP TO NOT.
THAT THEY HAVE TO SHOW DOWN THE
BUSINESSES FOR. TWO OR THREE
TWO THREE DAYS SO IT'S THESE
ARE TOUGH SITUATIONS I'M
CERTAINLY OPEN TO LOOKING AT.
NARROWING IT DOWN THERE IN THAT
I MEAN ORIGINALLY THE I THINK
THE OTHER THING IS TO THE NEEDS
TO BE SAID THAT I'M GONNA TURN
OVER TO. SPUR GLAZER. IT IS IN
A TEN BY TO BE COOPERATIVE WITH
THE SENATE AND MERGE BILL SO WE
HAVE FAR FEWER BILL STAFF TO
HERE. IN FRONT OF OUR
COMMITTEES AND OBVIOUSLY IN
FRONT OF THE FULL SENATE WE'VE
MERGED BILLS AND SO THE INTENT
OF MY BILL FOR EXAMPLE. IS THE
ALBUM MORE NARROW AT THE- AND
NOW. SENATOR GLAZERS BILL I
THINK HE IS IN TUNE WITH THAT
MIRRORING THAT MORE JUST TO
CRITICAL HEALTH. FACILITIES SO
LET'S LET'S HAVE SENATOR.
GLAZER MISTER CHAIR IF THAT'S
OKAY WITH YOU ARE POINTING OUT
AND I'M SURE IT'S AN ENGLISH AS
A STRONG OPINION I KNOW HE
DOES. FOR PUTTING TENSION
EXISTS IN THIS RIGHT. HERE
THERE. IS ALL THE STUFF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REQUIRES A KIND
THE NEW ONES OF A LOCAL
CONVERSATION HOW YOU KNOW. DOES
THE CURRENT CONDITIONS AND THE
SUIT XIN AT THE- FACILITY. I
THINK GLAZER. FOR MORE WHY
THIRTY TO. LEAVE THIS UP TO.
KIND OF YOU AND YOU DISTURBED.
TITIAN BUT THERE'S- I DO THAT
LATER BUT I'M SURE YOU I'M SURE
YOU. ARTICULATE PUSHED BACK.
ALL RIGHT Q. IS THIRD FIVE AIR
DOES. THIRTY FIVE THEIR
DISTRICTS. AND YET THERE'S NO
SAND. FIND PASSABLE WILL THAT
WILL TAKE A LA EIGHT THAT CA.
WE'RE TRYING TO CLEAR UP AND
BEGIN. AND THIS ORDER THE ALL.
BUT ARE OUR- CLICK WITH WE'RE
GOING TO NOW SIX KATIS. BUT YOU
FOR A HOSPITALS. ALL THAT'S
GOING. ON WITH THE PAN. AND WE
CREATE YOUR- BE. SOMETHING THAT
NO ONE ARE YOU WITH. I
APPRECIATE THAT THE COULD ABOUT.
PLACE TO IT IN THIS OVER TRYING
TO THE HOT. KEEP THE LIGHTS ON
TO KEEP THE POWER TO KEEP A LOT.
THAT'S WHAT I TRYING TO DO IN
THIS PART OF THE BILL. AND
THEIR DISTRICTS TO CREATE
BUREAUCRACY TO GET IN THE WAY
THAT THEY'RE NOT ARGUE. THE A
SERIOUS. I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT. YEAH BUT I
APPRECIATE THE CONSTRUCTIVE
NATURE OF THE CONVERSATION OF
THE SHARES ENGAGEMENT.
CERTAINLY OF SENATOR DODD'S
LEADERSHIP. AND THAT'S REALLY
WHERE I'M HOPING THAT LET'S
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
THE I TRY TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
YES THERE IS THAT AND- THAT
WE'RE TAKING THE- SUCH AS
BACKWARD. POSSIBLES IN THAT
NARROW SPACE. PS PS IS ARE ARE
NOT. HAVING BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES HERE THEY ARE BRAND
NEW. AND THEY'RE VERY UNUSUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WE WANT TO
ELIMINATE THEM. AS THE PROBLEM
OF THE HOSPITALS. THAT HAVE PUT
THEMSELVES IN THIS SITUATION SO
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO NARAL.
PROVIDE THAT. NOW WHAT I HOPE
WE CAN DO GOING FORWARD. DID
YOU. I HEARD YOU GRIMLY ON YOUR
BREATH I AND IT IT IT IT'S YOU
WANT TO HAVE A UNIVERSAL
MULLICAN FOR EVERY HOSPITALS
THAT MAY HAVE THREE YEAR OLD
GENERATOR TO TURN IT OFF. AND
THAT AND I SEE THAT PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES BUT- OTHER PART
OF IT IS IT'S SAYING YOU KNOW.
YOU CAN YOU'VE GOT TO IT MAY
HAVE TO CALL MONEY AND I CAN I
GET THAT WITH THE COVERT NINE.
YOU GOT A READ IT THE
GENERATORS ARE YOU WANT TO GET
THERE THE CENTER MORE BLACK TO
GET A LET'S THE. GUEST WHAT DO
YOU SOMEBODY YOU AMEND TACTIC
ON. ON THE INVITE RIGHT
TESTIMONY IS THE THESE ARE THIS
IS A THESE REALLY BAD
POLLUTANTS THAT TO THE BIG
CHILDREN IN THE AFFECTED
POLLUTE PEOPLE THAT ARE THERE
SO IT'S A IT'S A LOT OF BAD.
OUTCOMES RIGHT THE FACT THAT
YOU IN YES I GET GET FULL THING
I'M- HEY MAYBE YOU KNOW. OR
BROUGH I MEAN I'M VERY BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MOVE ON BUT BUT MAKE
YOU KNOW CAN YOU CAN YOU JUST
ANSWER WHOLE ISSUE IS OURS.
THIS IS THE- DIDN'T WIN TO.
HOURS THERE. THE LIKE THIS. DO
EITHER OF YOU WANTED VERY.
CLARIFY THIS. YEAH CHAIRMAN
ALAN ANYWHERE NOT CREATE ANY
EXTRA BUREAUCRACY OR ANYTHING
EXTRA RIGHT NOW WE ALREADY HAVE
A WAY TO DEAL WITH IT AND WE DO
DEAL WITH IT AND AS WE'VE TOLD
OTHERS DEBATE COMMENDED
BATTENBERG SEE NAY GOT. DEAL
WITH IT AFTER. WE'VE GOT TO.
PLACE IN THAT'S WHERE WE KEEP
GOING TO HOLD IT UNDER THE
CHALLENGE. THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA
SHOULD ANYBODY DOWN BUT WE'RE
GONNA MAKE SURE THAT AFTERWARDS
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT WAS A REAL EMERGENCY AND
THEN IT WAS BONTA THING AND AS
LONG AS PEOPLE DOING WHAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE. YEAH WE HAVE
ESSENTIAL. ALREADY WITH OUR OWN.
REGULATIONS WOULD ASK. CHIEF
BEING PULLED AWAY IN A DEFINITE
THAT THAT THAT'S ALL ALREADY
DEFINED. I DID IT BARBARA YOU
ON THE LINE. YEAH NHI<c.cyan> LET</c>
LET'S SO WHAT I THINK I LOOK I
THINK I MEAN THIS LET'S TALK
ABOUT THIS BILL THIS IT THESE
TWO BILLS THAT WERE SORT OF
EXCRUCIATINGLY CLOSE I THINK
WE'RE KIND OF SEEING THINGS
THAT ARE NOT DISCORDANT BUT YOU
KNOW GETTING PLACER WE SHOULD
BOTH FULLY PROMOTE STATE IN A
WEIRD WAY. I APPRECIATE THE- OF
MARCH. BECAUSE IT HE LEAVES A
MARK. BUT THE INSTRUCTOR FOR
ALL OF US MOST FORWARD AND
THAT'S WITH YOU KNOW TO BE
GREAT FRIENDS IN COLLEGE WHO
ARE YOU KNOW I TRY TO DO GOOD
THINGS SO- ANYHOW I. THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I SUFFER LIKE ME I'M I'M
A LOT MORE CONFUSED NOW SINCE
THE TESTIMONIES BEEN GOING ON
THAN IT WAS BEFORE. THE BILL SO
LOOK AT THE END OF THE DAY.
NOBODY WANTS IS KIRSTEN ENGINES
A COME OUT OF DIESEL
PARTICULATES NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO. NOBODY WANTS TO HAVE THEIR
HOSPITAL SHUT DOWN THE SAME
TIME BECAUSE HE THE NUMBER ONE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD. TO PUT IN A
NEW MODERN. IT ENERGY EFFICIENT
OR A MORE. AIR QUALITY
EFFICIENT GENERATOR OR A
BATTERY BACKUP FOR WHAT WHAT
YOU HAVE SO THAT WE HAVE TO
STRIKE A BALANCE HERE I HEARD I
DID NOT HEAR FROM EITHER.
PATROL OFFICERS. I DIDN'T IT
JUST IF THEY FIND ANYBODY FOR
RUNNING OVER THEIR HOURS OF.
WHATEVER THEIR SEARCHES WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE SO THAT'S WHAT I
WANT TO FIND OUT IS LIKE AT THE
END OF THE DAY- I DON'T WANT MY
HEART I HAVE TO GO OUT THESE
ARE NOT. INEXPENSIVE THESE ARE
VERY AND WE DISTRICT.
THROUGHOUT THE- THERE ALL THAT
ARE. PART OF THREAD RIGHT NOW.
TO DO FOR THEM TO HAVE TO BUY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR.
GENERATOR WOULD BE DEVASTATING
TO THEM RIGHT NOW SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
PUTTING THOSE. HARMS WAY THERE
WAS SOME OF. THE BE ABLE. TO
FOR A GRANT I DON'T. THAT WOULD
HAPPEN BUT MY POINT IS THAT.
RATHER FORTY YOUR- SPITTLE.
HAVING A NEW. THERE HAVE THIS
IS WHEN I'M GONNA GET A-
BECAUSE- AND BE OUT OF. SO I'M
TO CLARA THAT SURF SOMEONE
CLOSE BY THAT FOR ME PLEASE.
SIR MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
BRENDAN TELLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER DOLLY AGAIN YES WE THE
BILL SPONSORS HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED A SINGLE EXAMPLE. TAKE
FINING. RUNNING ABOUT. DOING AN
pDOWN DURING AN EMERGENCY WE'RE
VERY SENSITIVE. TO THAT ISSUE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ADEQUATE POWER
EMERGENCIES AND I FOR INSTANCE.
THAT YOU'RE HEARING SHOWS THE
ONE FROM THE LOCAL PROCESS IN
THE NUANCES THE PROCESS AND
IT'S EACH DISTRICT ON BANNING.
ALL SORTS AND HAVING THE
RELATIONSHIPS BEING ABLE TO
WORK THROUGH THESE ISSUES SO
NOW WE HAVE A THERE HAVEN'T
BEEN ANY FROM. OR AT. WE'RE A
OF. I'M THIS IS DANIEL THAT WE
YOU A I CAN CHIME IN REALLY
QUICKLY AS AS THE CODE FONG I
WANTED TO MENTION THAT YEAH
TRUE WE AGREE THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN A IN CHRIS. THEIR DISTRICT
ARE SAYING I AND I THINK OUR
CONCERN IS THAT YEAH THE ARE
NEW WORRY OUT. EIGHT AND THERE
HAS BEEN A- WHERE THE HAVE BEEN
A- AND SO WE ARE CAN. AND
LOOKING FOR THAT CLEAR BUT AS I
KNOW IN MY- MARCH WE ARE.
WORKING WITH BEARD IS. THE IF
THERE WAYS TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
SO WE WANT TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION THEN AND BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS A WAY. TO
DISTRACT ABOUT THAT WORKS FOR.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S OUR THAT'S OUR HOPE-
ANGELA. HI SO YOU KNOW I A I
THAT I CAN'T HELP BUT FEEL WE
GOT A BILL TO GET THEIR GIVEN
HOW EVERYONE IS BASICALLY. TING
SAID SIMILAR THINGS I ALSO
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS A-
THERE'S AN INTERESTING DYNAMIC
IN YEAH. I DON'T KNOW I AM
CERTAINLY COMFORTABLE MOVING
FORWARD- WITH BY THE BILL WHERE
AS TO WHERE WE ARE BUT I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE FACT IT'S GOING
TAKE SOME ADDITIONAL WORK- AND
I REALLY DO THAT EVERY TIME I
COME TOGETHER WITH. MY
BERNARDIN AND TRY TO. IF AS AS
BEST AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN AS WE-
MOVE FORWARD THIS TO GO CHASING
ASSUMING THAT IT'S OUT I'M I'M-
CERTAINLY. VOTE FOR TODAY I
WITHOUT UNDERSTAND. SO WITH
THAT I WILL THAT BABY ENTERTAIN
A MOTION ALL. OKAY SO SENATOR
AND HELD. TO PASS AS AMENDED-
CENTER DIED CENTER GLAZER IF
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION I WOULD SEE AS THE
PAIR IN THIS LEGISLATURE THERE
ARE PLENTY OF THE GET OUT OF
COMMITTEES THAT ARE FOR THE
LAST TWO. AT THIS POINT. DO YOU
CENTER. BOTH SIDES END COME TO
COME UP TO SOME SORT OF
AGREEMENT WORKING WITH THE
CHAIR AND HIS STAFF
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU AND I SEE I SEE A
VERY NICE NOD FROM MY FRIEND-
FROM FORMER INTO. AND WITH THAT
IT'S MOVED BY CENTER HILL AND
SUCH A PLEASE CALL. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB TEN NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR DODD. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED ALLEN HI ALLEN
HI DOLLY SO. DOLLY GNOME
HERTZBERG HILL HI HILL AYE
MCGUIRE. MY CAL SCHEME. OKAY
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF AND FOR
THE OTHER MEMBERS THAT ON AND
THE A TO DO YOU SHOULD AND
EVERYONE'S HARD WORK ON THIS I
KNOW IT'S NOT BEEN AN EASY TIME.
THE RUNS WERE SO LET'S CALL OUR-
LAST NOT LEAST NOT. LIVE FROM
WHERE HE BROUGHT HERE IN THE
FLESH FROM ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
OUR GOOD FRIEND FROM ORANGE
COUNTY. THE FORMER COUNTY
TREASURER OF OUR COLLEAGUE. DR
MORLOCK. AND I WILL SAY YOUR
BEARD IS LOOKING RESPLENDENT.
AT AT AT A COVERED UP AND- SO I
CAN STOP BREATHING NOW THEY DO
ALLOW BEARD TRIMMERS ARE
CERTAINLY PERMITTED- IF YOU DO
IT YOURSELF I JUST YOU KNOW
JUST TO. MAKE SURE YOU'RE AWARE
THAT I AM I AM PROTESTING OKAY
AND IT'S EASIER IT'S YOUR IT'S
YOUR YOUR PLAYOFF BEARD. IN
THERE I GO START BY GOING UP MY
CLASS. THANKS FOR LETTING ME.
SITTING ROOM TWENTY FORTY IT
SEEMS LIKE NO ONE HAS BEEN IN
THERE YOU LOOK SO LONELY OVER
THERE WE- HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PERSON IN THE- WORLD IS TIME.
THANK YOU MAY. SURE I'M HERE TO
PRESENT. ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE.
STARTED WITH A CASUAL
CONVERSATION WITH THE MAYOR MY
CITY WE WERE JUST CHATTING YET
REMODELED IS HOME. AND THE-
CARBON SORT OF A TO CHATTING
AND HE SAID YEAH ONE THING I
DID THAT I'M REALLY HAPPY WITH
WAS THAT I. INSTALL THE
GENERATOR WHEN I REBUILT THE
HOUSE AND- I AM AND I GOT A GAS
GENERATOR JUST TOOK IT UP TO
THE GAS LINE. AND THIS AND HAD
A POWER OUTAGE KIND OF PLAN BUT
IT WENT FOR LIKE EIGHT HOURS IN
THE EVENING AND- MY- SEND THEM.
I'M THE ONLY HOUSE IN THE WHOLE
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT'S LIT UP. AND
I THOUGHT GOODNESS WHAT IT YOU
KNOW JUST A SIMPLE IDEA OF
HAVING OUR START LOOKING IT UP.
THERE'S NO SIX B. TO MEET
SOMEONE JUST TAKE THIS OP. AYE
AYE AYE SIR LOOKING IT UP
ONLINE HOW DO WE GET A
GENERATOR AND ENSURE THAT
THERE'S NATURAL GENERATORS AND-
BY THE COMPANY BY WESCOTT EVEN
LOOK UP THEIR STOCK PRICE IN
HOUSE GENERATORS MUST REALLY BE.
BRING A LOT BUT- NEWS FOR THE
TAMPA BECAUSE OF WHAT'S
CALIFORNIA SURE NAPA JUST A LOT
OF ACTIVISTS ARE STARTED
WORKING ON IT FOR MY FOR MY
HOME IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S A BIG
DEAL YOU GOT IT IS NOT. YOU
KNOW IN AN EMERGENCY. THIS
WOULD BE GREAT. I THOUGHT WHAT
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR
STATE WITH THAT PS PS AND HOW
WOULD THIS BE HELPFUL IN SO
THAT- MISTER CHAIR WAS THE SORT
OF THAT. THE ENDING OF A- THE
BILL THAT WE HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE AND WE
CERTAINLY HAVE SEEN THESE
GENERATORS SELL WELL BUT WE
ALSO NEED HIM FOR BUSINESSES I.
READING THE PAPER THAT I LAST
FALL IT SHOWS WAS TRYING TO
GIVE AWAY ALL THEIR FROZEN FOOD
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T KEEP THE-
FREEZER'S GOING UP. YES CAN OF.
BURKE ALL THESE BUSINESS UP IN
THE STATE THAT ARE IN LOUISE
OWNS- I'M USED TO HAVING BACKUP
GENERATORS AT THE COUNTY- BIG
DIESEL ENGINES READY TO GO- BUT
I WOULDN'T. THIS BILL IS NOT
DESIGNED TO SAY IT'S- IN A-
WHAT'S THERE BUT IF YOU'RE
BORED REMODELING OR WORKING ON
SOMETHING NEW THEN YOU SHOULD
BE AT LEAST LOOKING AT THAT BUT
THAT. THE NATURAL GAS WHICH I
THINK IS AN OBVIOUS FORMER
FUELING BACKUP GENERATION
NATURAL GAS IS CLEANER THAN
DIESEL FUEL YOU'VE DEBATED
THAT. IN MOST CASES IT'S
AVAILABLE THROUGH FIFTY NATURAL
GAS INFRASTRUCTURE YOU JUST
HOOK RIGHT UP TO. UTILITY THE
VOICE TO. TRUCK OR TRANSPORT
LARGE AMOUNTS OF DIESEL FUEL-
IT WHICH WOULD BE EXTREMELY
AWKWARD DURING THE FIRE
SITUATION OR CONDITION- LET
ALONE HAVING TO STORED AT ALL
TIMES. THIS IS OUR ISSUED THERE
IS CONSIDERATION GIVEN TO THE
TECHNOLOGY UTILIZED FOR BACKUP
GENERATION. IN DOING SO WE HOPE
THAT EMERGENCY VARIANCES ARE
GRANTED RAPIDLY AND WITH EASE
TO OPERATORS OF NAT GAS BACKUP
GENERATORS. SPLA THE WHEN
EIGHTY FIVE WITH A PRETTY GOOD
FACILITIES BAKER YOU'D- DIESEL
GENERATOR FROM CAN TO A- THE
KEY STANDARD IMAGE BILL IS A
VERY. POWERS AND APPLYING FOR
HIM THE FIRE. IT IS NOT MANDATE
IN THIS BILL THAT IT OPERATOR
SWITCH TO. GAS OR A FORMS OF
GENERATE. THIS BILL IS INTENDED
TO EASE THE ISSUANCE OF
EMERGENCY VARIANCES
PARTICULARLY FORD TRUCK HAS NOT
BURDEN THE ISSUANCE OF PERMITS
THE- MISSING THESE. THE LATEST
VERSION THE BILL FAR FROM.
AFTER WORK IT WAS IT YOUR
COMMUTE. INTO A AGREEMENT THAT
EMERGE BURKE ARE THE BEST
AVENUE FOR SO TO GO THROUGH AND
TO. OPERATE BRING PS P. OF AN-
THE BILL IS NOT PER BUT IT'S A
START GIVEN THE SHORT TIME MY
WE ARE UP UNDER AND THE
CONSTANTLY EVOLVING NATURE OF
OTHER BACK UP GENERATOR BILLS
IN THE LEGISLATURE. WE ARRIVED
AT VERSION OF THE MEASURE THIS
PAST. I AM ASKING FOR YOUR UP
SO THAT WE CAN CAN THIS
CONVERSATION AND FURTHER WORK
ON THIS BILL TO ENSURE THAT
EMERGENCY VARIANCES ARE
GRANTED. DURING THE S. P. S.
EVENTS THAT NATURAL. REMAINS
PART OF THE ANSWER TO THIS
ISSUE. BY STAFF WORKED
TIRELESSLY COMMITTEE THE KEEPER
VERSION OF THIS BILL LIVE SO
THAT NATURAL GAS BACK UP
GENERATION NOW EMERGENCY
VARIANCES CAN CONTINUE TO BE A
PIECE OF THE BACKUP GENERAL
CONVERSATION. IN THE CURRENT
WHAT THE BILL IS DIRECT. ON
SEPTEMBER. MISTER CHAIR FOR ALL
THERE ARE WORK AS MY STAFF. I
THIS TO MOVE THE BILL SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE. ON THIS ISSUE.
THE HAVE A AND WOULDN'T SETTLE.
THE LINE. I BURKE OROZCO WITH
THE CAL CABLE IN TELE. IS TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU. FOR
SHOULD THAT TIME OKAY BUT LET'S
FOR. HERE YET WITH FROM FROM
BERNIE. AS YOUR SUPPORT WHEN.
HE'S ON THE PUBLIC LINE. YOU
ASKED THE. HERE TO FIND A CALL
PUBLIC LINE OKAY MODERATOR
WE'RE FOR BURKE ROSS. FROM THE
CABLE TELL ASSOCIATION AND THE
PICTURE OF ON THE PUBLIC LINE.
MR OROZCO IF YOU ARE ON THE
LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ONE
THEN ALSO. ONE MOMENT MISTER
TURNER. OKAY DOES. WHERE DO
CHECKING TO SEE HE WHERE ARE WE
HAVE COME ON THE LINE WILL
DETECT THAT DEMO. OKAY. THERE
ARE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GREAT
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS BERNERO WITH THE CABLE
AND TELL. SO SPEAKING TODAY AND
OF THE ELEVEN EIGHTY CARS IN
THE WAKE OF THE Y. PARDON
CALIFORNIA MORE RE AT THE
AUTHOR THEY BY THE LAW. AND
PUBLIC. AND FOUR LECTOR UTILITY
SHUT POWER. YEAH BEEN ACTIVELY.
ALL MAKERS FRANCE WHEN HIGH CAN
CONNECTED FOR COULD
COMMUNICATION FACILITIES. WE
ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO USE OUR
GENERATORS WHEN. THE POWER GOES
OFF TO KEEP COMMUNICATIONS
RUNNING. GREAT DISCUSSION ON
THE PREVIOUS BILL I KNOW WHO WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT WE TALKED
PENSION. AND OF THAT THE CAVE
INDUSTRY HAS NEW THOUSAND
DIFFERENT. HE COULD STILL USE
THAT NEED TO BE UP AND RUNNING
DURING OUR SHUT OFF STATE WATER
IN A RECENT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
SITUATION WHEN THE POWER WAS
pHAVE REQUIRED YOU THINK
INDIVIDUAL PORTABLE GENERATORS
THAT THIS WAS THE STORIES UP
AND RUNNING BUT THE WHITE HOUSE
THE WHAT ABOUT BALANCE WE
REALIZED THAT WE CANNOT ENTIRE
QUICKLY UP THE ONE WE'RE
WORKING WITH BETTER MCGUIRE AND
IT FOR THIRTY ONE. WHAT ARE THE
KEY FACILITIES THAT WE SHOULD
KEEP OPERATING DURING THAT. BUT
YOU OF GENERATOR HE NEED TO
THAT. SENATE ENERGY CAN AND
GENERATE A- ON THE ONE PICKLE
HAD AN ADMIRING AS THAT WE
REQUIRE REQUIRE MARK POWER. SO
WE'RE OF THE BILL WOMAN TARA
AND THE WE ARE WITH NINETY NINE
WE HOPE THAT WE CAN GET YOUA
BETTER PLACE BUT- HERE IN
SPORTS TODAY. THANK YOU MR
FOSCO. OKAY IS OUR LET'S LET'S
NOW OPEN UP WELL FIRST OF ALL I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE IN FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO
I WOULD LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL WE CAN GO LOOK AT
THE LONELY LONELY ROOM TWENTY.
ON THE LINE EIGHT. NINE WHO I
WOULD LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT.
ALLEN CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. HM THIS IS WHY NAZARIAN
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE SOUTH
COAST AND WE KNOW MR MASSEY'S
MY UNDERSTANDING YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. WHERE WOULD MOVING
OUT OPPOSITION FOR PURPOSES OF
THIS COMMITTEE WE'RE REVIEWING
THE AMENDMENTS AND AS THAT
SOUNDED MORE LIKE SAID. THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF WORK ON THIS SHOW
FOR PURPOSES OF THE COMMITTEE
WERE REMOVED IN OPPOSITION.
WE'RE STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING TE IMPACT- AND WE'RE
DEFINITELY WORKING WITH THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE. AND WE WILL
REMAIN ENGAGED- IN ON THIS
WHOLE EFFORT. WELL WE REALLY
APPRECIATE MISTER NASTY. AND WE
CERTAINLY- JOBS LEE COURAGE YOU
TO WORK ABOUT AS I WAS ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEES OFFICE WE YOU KNOW
AS AS I THINK YOU KNOW WE WILL
IN THE. AS A COMMITTEE. MUCH
YOU'RE- TURNED OUT AIR QUALITY
IN EVERY. OUR PRE. SO LET'S
WORK TO ON THIS MOVING FOR
THANK YOU BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE
DID WITH THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND EVERYONE
FOR CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT OTHER FOLKS WHO
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. NOW IT LATER. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE NOW.
ONE MOMENT DETERMINE. LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU IN
LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHIANG COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL THAT
I AM MAKING ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES WE ARE IN
SUPPORT IF AMENDED ON THIS
MEASURE AND IMPLEMENTED A
LETTER OUTLINING OUR AMENDMENT
TO THE COMMITTEE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR YOUR- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND ONE ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI IT'S JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION YEAH BECAUSE
THE BILL WAS RECENTLY AMENDED
IN MORE CAREFULLY REVIEWING
THOSE AMENDMENTS. AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED WE DO HAVE SOME THERE
ARE CONCERNS THE BILL WILL
QUICKLY. AND EMERGENCY
VARIANCES FOR CONTINUED
OPERATIONAL CRITICAL FACILITIES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE- WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT BUT WE THINK
THAT THE OPERATION OF. WHICH
ENDED THOUGH AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ITH HIM TO
AVOID THESE PROBLEMS THAT THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU
IN LINE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FIFTY SEVEN MAYBE YOU'RE ON
MUTE. ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SO HONORABLY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOTTERY EACH AND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN
LINE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND ONE
EIGHTEEN MAYBE YOUR MUTED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE YOUR
LINE OF THEM YOU. GET OUT THE
INSURED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- DO HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION- ONE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THAT OF
JOHN KENNEDY OUT FOR MORE HERE
SHE I WILL HAVE A FULL LIST ON
THE BILL MOMENT BUT YOU LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH CENTER
ONE LOCK- AND HIS STAFF ARE
STILL. LOOKING FOR THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE
YOUR LINES ON MUTE. LINE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH ONE
LAST FINAL CALL FOR. OF FOLKS
WANNA TESTIFY. WE DO HAVE LINE
ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
LINE ONE EIGHTEEN. HELLO IF WE
CAN HEAR YOU. WELL I WOULDN'T
ON THE LINE HIALYSSA SO HIGH
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICT ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE AN IMPORTANT CONCEPT WITH
THIS IN ON THE CELL PRIOR TO
THE AMENDMENT AND ARE CURRENTLY
BODY IN THE NEW LANGUAGE AND WE
SUPPORT THE GOAL OF THE SPELL
BUT DO YOU ANTICIPATE CONCERNS
WITH THE- IMPACT ON. THE
CLIPPERS SURE AND- THREE THE
INTERROGATION EVENTS WE
COMMUNICATED COOPER THE OPERAS
OFFICE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
WHAT WITH MY POLLUTION COMING
FORWARD THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE.
LIMITED THAT WAS ALL. OKAY
THERE WE ARE SO- NOW I GUESS SO
WITH NOW I HAD- MR NASH YOU
DOWN AS AN OPPOSITION WHEN THIS.
I MEAN WE BE HEARING FROM WHAT
WHAT WHAT DO WE HAVE ANYONE
WHO'S NOW WHO IS NOW SIGNED ON
AS IT OPPOSITION WHEN IS PHILIP
CRAPPIE FROM. SOUTH BECAUSE
THEY DEAR BARBARA BAIRD OR OR
BRANDON- OR OR YOU GUYS ARE
GONNA TWEETERS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE STILL
HAVEN'T OPPOSE POSITION. WE
THINK THE WAY THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED IT COULD
ACTUALLY TAKE LONGER TO GET AN
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AN
EMERGENCY EVENT SO AGAIN WE'RE
SENSITIVE TO EMERGENCIES AND
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ESSENTIAL SERVICES PROVIDERS
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE. POWER
DURING PS PS AGAINST ANOTHER
EMERGENCY AND THIS LANGUAGE
DOES RAISE SOME QUESTION ABOUT.
ABOUT THE ABILITY TO DO THAT.
OKAY HOPEFULLY WE ADDRESSED. I
ANYONE ELSE ANYWAY THE OTHER
FOLKS WHO WANNA RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL I'M I DON'T SEE
ANY HERE IN THIS ROOM TWENTY
FORTY EIGHT I. I SEE WAS STILL
EMPTY AND LONELY. WELL I'M-
MODERATOR ANYONE WE HAVING Q.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE THAT. YOUR OWN NOW. I ONE
MOMENT THURMOND. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE BARBER MYERS
ONLINE. IS THAT RIGHT HELLO YES
MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FOUR YES
SHE IS BOB REPAIR IS ONLINE HER
LINE IS OPEN OKAY. YES I'M WITH
COAST AND I MIGHT- OPPOSITION
AS YOU HEARD FROM MISTER ASTRI
IS WITHDRAWN. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IN MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES DOWN TO THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
THAT WERE IN THE SAME. POSITION
AS THE SOUTH COAST A Q. M. D.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
SENATOR IN A STAFF OF GUN TO-
TO IT TO RICH. ABOUT THE BAY
AREA KIM DO IS ORIGINAL AN UP.
BY WE WERE- AT TEMPORARILY
REMOVING THAT WHILE YOU LOOK AT
THE NEW LANGUAGE BUT WE'RE
HOPEFUL WE CAN WORK SOMETHING
OUT MOVING FORWARD THANK. OKAY
THAT'S HOPEFUL. I ANYONE ELSE
EGGMAN MODERATOR. YES CLIMB ONE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT CAN YOU
HEAR ME SORRY BUT THE PROBLEM
ARE YOU GOING HOME WITH THEIR
CLOTHES CALIFORNIA WE'RE STILL
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ARE
WE THERE BURNING I THANK GOD
FOR BACK UP TOWARDS THE LIMIT.
BLOOM COMPARING ATMOSPHERE-
NOTHING DOWN GENERATION ACTION
OXIDE AND LEAD TO RESPIRATORY
PROBLEMS AND- OTHER ADVERSE
HEALTH IMPACT NOTHING IS A
GREENHOUSE GAS. BUT I ANY.
CARMEN THAT SO ALL OF THEIR
OPTIONS AND THESE. NOTHING
HAPPENED A HIGHLY COLD WILL
KILL AND OF WE PROBLEMS WITH IT
BEING IN A- OF HEALTH SAFETY
CODE THE PROJECT AND BUT OF ALL
ID CREAM UP ESPECIALLY WHEN OUR
LONG LOOTING THAT OUT AVAIL TO
PROVIDE MARK BACK APART THANK
YOU. CAN OTHERS LIMITED TERM
THERE IS NO ELSE THINKS. FINAL
CALL FINAL FOR WHO WANT TO WIN
ON EITHER SIDE OF THIS ON THE
LINE. OKAY ARE HEARING NINE
LET'S GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION. MISTER SENATOR-
HE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY YOU DO
THIS IN LATE AMENDMENTS AND SO
SOME SOME OF THE OPPOSITION IS
FLIP WHICH IS GOOD I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE GETTING. CLOSER BUT
I ALSO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW AS
YOU AS YOU MENTIONED THERE'S
STILL SOME WORK TO BE DONE AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN. WE CAN FIGURE
THIS ALL OUT SO. OUR QUESTIONS
FROM THE FROM THE COMMITTEE
THOUGHTS CONCERNS IF YOU HAVE
AND MOVE THE BILL WHICH WOULD
YOU MOVE BY SENATOR HILL- SORT
OF MORE LIKE. JACK THAT MOVED
BY HER. YEAH NOBODY COULD HAVE.
BEEN ARE A CENTER MORE LOCK YOU
BE MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
I AM. I'M HAPPY TO BE
PRESENTING THE LAST BILL WHAT
THE LAST DAY OF THIS WEEK
THANKS FOR THE HONOR. THEY'VE
BEEN INTERESTING TO BE IN THESE
SESSIONS AND THE BIGGEST
QUESTION THAT'S BEEN ASKED THE-
IS CAN YOU HEAR ME. THOSE BEEN
KIND OF AN INTERESTING WEEK BUT
I WANT TO THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
FOR- REVIEWING THE BILL I THINK
THIS. WAY TO GO AND IT SHOULD
BE- BUT IN THE STATE CODE AND I
WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE RC RC IT'S AN ORGANIZATION
I HIGHLY REGARD RESPECT AND THE
OTHERS AND- I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY- SO. SO
CENTER ALLEN SURE THANK FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND- I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY YEAH THAT IT'S BEEN
MOVED CENTER HELP BURKE AND-
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MIKE'S ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR
MORLOCK THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ALAN.
ALLEN HI ALLEN HI DOLLY.
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL
BY HILL BY REQUIRED. BY CASKEY
BY CASSIE I'M BURKE. OKAY SO-
WE WILL LEGAL ROLE OPEN FOR
SENATE MCGUIRE TO RETURN. LET'S
OPEN THE ROAD THANK YOU SO MUCH
A CENTER MORE LIKE WE
APPRECIATE YOU. LET'S OPEN THE
ROLE ON ALL OF OUR ITEMS
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED TO GIVE MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON AND
HOPEFULLY- ASSN HEARD MCGUIRE
WILL BE ON HIS WAY. AND SO WE
WILL RE OPEN THE ROLE ON. ITEM
NUMBER ONE THIS IS SB NINE
FIFTY SENATOR JACKSON'S BILL.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB NINE FIFTY
BY SENATOR JACKSON THE MOTION
IS DO PASSES AMENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TWO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I'D- HERTZBERG. OKAY WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE ON ITEM ONE SB
NINE FIFTY WITHOUT OBJECTION
OFF FOR RECONSIDERATION. TO THE
AUTHOR. LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO I
REMEMBER. TWO THAT'S- SB NINE
SEVENTY FOUR HER TITLE. SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB NINE SEVENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR HER TADO THE MOTION
IS DO PASSES MENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT BOAT IS. FIVE TWO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
ONLINE. HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG
FIVE. THAT SIX ZERO OKAY AT SIX
ZERO. I'M NOW THAT IT WILL
CLOSE A ROLE ON THAT THAT NOW
IS GOING OVER DO APPROACH
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AS AS AMENDED OKAY NEXT ITEM SB
NINE NINETY FIVE CENTER ATKINS
BILL. SUCH A PEACEFUL WORLD.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE NINE
FIVE BY SENATOR ACTIONS THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FOR TWO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING ON TIME. DOLLY HILL HI
BILL I. THAT'S. FIVE TWO ZERO
OKAY FIVE ZERO WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE ON THAT ITEM. THAT GOES
OVER PROVISIONS AS WELL. NOW
CENTER ALLEN IS FANTASTIC BILL
THIS IS JUST THE BEST OF THE
DAY- NEVER ITEM FOR SB TEN
FORTY FOUR ALLEN SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB TEN FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR
ALAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING ONLINE ALL BECAME DOLLY.
HERTZBERG IT'S ONLY THREE ZERO.
HA HA. HERTZBERG I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL BY HILL I. FIVE FOUR
FIVE ZERO OKAY THAT'S FIVE TWO
ZERO I THINK YOU MEMBERS. EIGHT
AND AS DIFFICULT VOTE FOR SOME
OF YOU IT WAS VERY CHALLENGING-
AND NOW WE'LL GO WE'RE CLOSE
THE ROLE IN THAT WILL GO TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THAT'S SB TEN
NINETY NINE CENTER DODDS BILL.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND NUMBER FIVE SB TEN NINETY
NINE BY SENATOR DODD THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'D- VOTE
IS TWO TO ONE. HERTZBERG THE
OLD AMOUNTS WILL BURGER WE DO I.
THE WORK HERTZBERG FIVE MCGUIRE.
BY CASKEY. OKAY WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ASSN ROOK MCGUIRE
WHO'S ON HIS WAY NO BETTER J.
IT DO WE HAVE ALL VOTES COUNTED
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR OKAY
WHEN WE OPEN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS IS JUST ITEM
NUMBER SIX IS THIS BILL INTO
THE SIX ARE TO LET ON LITHIUM
BATTERIES SUCH A. UNDER BY
CASKEY SO CINEMA CASKEY. OKAY
WELL I THINK HE'S LEFT SO LET'S
CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT. AND
WHAT LITTLE I'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
IN CASE HE WANTS TO RUN BACK
BUT AND DID CENTER WILL CASKEY
STAFF IS ON LISTENING TO THIS
CALL- WORSTED VESTED. CHECK IF
THE CHARGES WOULD LIKE TO CALL
TO GET BACK TO VOTE FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED WELL WELL THAT OPEN
OKAY- FINALLY CENTER MORLOCKS
BILL THE BILL WE JUST HEARD
THIS IS SB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE I
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR MORLOCK
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
HAVE CURRENT IS FOR TUESDAY.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING ONLINE.
DOLLY MCGUIRE. OKAY WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR SENATE MCGUIRE WHO
IS. IT WILL BE ALRIGHT YES I AM
WITH THE VOTE COUNT ON THAT OR
FORTY ZERO OKAY SO YEAH THAT
BILL IS OUT AND IN SPITE OF
FIVE SOME MORE LOCKS COLLEAGUES
THAT. ABSTENTION BUT- BYE BYE
CENTER HELBERG AND- CENTER MORE
SEVERAL MCGUIRE IS BACK SO THAT
I SECRETARY I GUESS WE ARE NOT
A LOT OF SIXTY TWO AND WHAT
THOSE DO WE NEED TO. BUT BILLS
WE NEED TO GO THROUGH. SB TEN
NINETY NINE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
OKAY SO LET'S START WITH- SB
TEN NINE AND SEVEN FIVE CENTER
DODDS BILL SURGERY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
TEN NINETY NINE BY SENATOR DODD
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TO ONE-
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I. EXCUSE
ME- CORRECT MYSELF- THE CURRENT
VOTE IS. THREE THREE ONE THREE
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
MCGUIRE BY WIRE HI OKAY SO THAT
NOW HAS ENOUGH THAT WILL CLOSER
ON THAT YET. OKAY LET'S NOW
ALSO OPEN THE KID DID YOU
FIGURE CENTER LET'S NOW OPEN
THE CONSENT CALENDAR I SEE-
CENTER CASKEY IS HERE AND
PRESENT. A SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ITEM NUMBER SIX. BY
CAO SCHEME BY CASKEY AYE SIX
ZERO OKAY SIX ZERO FOR THE
CONSENT COUNTY WILL CLOSER ON
THAT I THINK YOU ARE YOUR WORK
HERE IS DONE CINEMA CASKEY.
FIVE FROM SEVEN THIS IS MORE
LOCKS SB LEVY FIVE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB ELEVEN NINE
EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR MORLOCK
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE- THE CURRENT VOTE IS.
FOR TWO ZERO- WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING EYEING DOLLY. MCGUIRE BY
WIRE I. FIVE ZERO EIGHT FIVE
ZERO SO SOON MORE LIKE HAS THE
VOTES HE NEEDS AND WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THAT SO I THINK
THAT SENTIMENT MCGUIRE ANY ANY
OPEN VOTES WE NEED FOR SENATE
MCGUIRE NO OKAY I THINK WE'RE
GOOD SO- HAS MENTIONED WE'VE
OFFERED RECONSIDERATION ON SB
NINE FIFTY BUT ALL THE OTHER
BILLS OF HAVE FIVE PASSED
THEY'RE GONE. I THINK EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM HAD NO TO AN
APPROPRIATE. SO FAR. GREAT DID
YOU COLLEAGUES YOU TO OUR VERY
HARD WORKING STAFF THAT IS AND
YOU KNOW THAT THAT DID THIS
WORK FOR HIM FOR PARTICULAR
DILIGENTLY UNDER THESE BIZARRE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE FACE FIND
OURSELVES IN- WE CERTAINLY ARE
ALSO APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S HARD
WORK AND JUST TRYING TO HELP
MAKE THIS CLUNKY A SYSTEM OF
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE OR- VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS-
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS WE
ALSO. I JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT TO US THAT AND IN
SPITE OF ALL OF THE SPECIAL-
MEASURES THAT WE HAVE TAKEN TO
PROMOTE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
THAT WE DO. GET A ROBUST PUBLIC
INPUT INTO THE BILL SO WE ARE
CONSIDERING SO WE THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR PATIENCE AND
THEIR OPERATION. WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA TODAY AND
WE NOW. TURN THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON A FROM A QUALITY
THANK YOU EVERYONE'S HEARD FROM
HER WORK.